NUMBER THREE AND HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES I'M A WELCOME
EVERYONE HERE TODAY SO THIS I
GUESS THE FIRST HEARING OF THE
THE NEW SESSION.
AND I FIRST OF AL BEFORE WE
BEGIN I ACTUALLY WANT --
TO WELCOME --
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FIRST OF ALL I WELCOME CENTER
TADO WELCOME TO THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE AND ALSO RECOGNIZE
AND UNDERSTAND CENTER STONE
WHO'S A VETERAN THIS COMMITTEE
WILL BE COMING IN AND OUTS BUT
ALSO I RECOGNIZE.
HIM AS WELL WE LOOK FORWARD --
TO REPRODUCTIVE A SAID HEARINGS --
REGARDING THE STATE BUDGET WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT --
I GOVERNOR NEWSOME AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION'S PRIORITIZING --
HEALTH AND SAID IN A IN A AND
HOME HUMAN SERVICES AND AND HIS --
AND IN MANY OF HIS A STATEMENT
SANTA AND HIS ACTIONS AND SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING AND
LEARNING MORE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT THE
SPECIFICS ABOUT MAY OF HIS --
PORT POLICY PROPOSALS AS WE GO
THROUGH THE WICKS.
EXPECT THIS HEARING --
PRY TAKE FORTY FIVE HOURS MAYBE
A LITTLE LESS IF WE'RE LUCKY --
BASICALLY --
WE HAVE SEVERAL ITEMS FOR
DISCUSSION TODAY WILL BE
COVERING --
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING
DEVELOPMENT AND PART OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH WE
ALSO WILL --
WE ARE NOT TAKING ANY.
ACTIONS ON ITEMS AT TODAY'S
HEARING.
BUT WE WILL BE SOLICITING PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER COMPLETION OF
MAJOR DIVISIONS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT'S BEING HEARD --
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT WE ASK THAT
YOU TRY TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS --
TO ONE MINUTE OF COURSE WE
ALWAYS OUT WELCOME WRITTEN --
TESTIMONY MATERIAL AS WELL --
TOO IF YOU WISH TO OPERATE ON
THE PUBLIC ON THE COMMENTS
YOU'VE MADE DIED HERE ON THE
RECORD FOR A PUBLIC COMMENT.
AS WELL SO --
WITH THAT THE FARM EMERGENCY
SERVICES MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY TO COME UP AND GIVE IT
A REVIEW AND ALSO TH AND INVITES --
THE LA -- ON
THE PART OF FINANCE TO COME UP
AS WELL AND SO WILL FIRST USE
WILL TAKE UP THE OVERVIEW.
AND ACTUALLY WHAT WE'LL DO IS A
THING OF THIS PARTICULAR --
CATEGORY WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE CONCLUSION OF THE
ALL THE ISSUES OF FOR THE EMS
AUTHORITY SO WITH THAT --
WELCOME I'M GONNA ASK THAT
EVERYONE FIRST INTRODUCED
THEMSELVES FOR THE RECORD --
AND THEN --
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND BEGIN WITH
THE OVERVIEW TESTIMONY SO WE'LL
START WITH THE THE AGENCY.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR HOWARD BACKER
HAD THE DIRECTOR OF THEM SO.
DâN SMILEY CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THEM SO OKAY L. L..
ANY PADDICK ALEJO THANK YOU
FINANCE.
ALL ALL DEPARTED FINANCE.
IN THE AROMAS AFFIRMATIVE
FINANCE THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL
RIGHT SO LET'S BEGIN WITH THE
OVERVIEW WELCOME FACTOR THAT
DIRECTOR OF EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICESAUTHORITY THAT ALL
REFER TO AS EMS AUTHORITY --
LET ME START WITH A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF OUR DEPARTMENT AND
BUDGET AND THEN MOVED TO THE
PENDING BUT EVERY CLASS.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET.
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN AND TWENTY
TWENTY RELEASED IN JANUARY THIS
YEAR INCLUDES EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY IN THE AMOUNT OF
THIRTY FOUR POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS.
AND SEVENTY SIX PERMANENT
POSITIONS OF THIS 44% IS
DELEGATED FOR STATE OPERATIONS.
AND 56% IS DELEGATED TO LOCAL
ASSISTANCE.
ARIANNA SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA WAS
CREATED IN NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE
IN THE HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE.
WITH THE INTENT OF CREATING A
STATEWIDE EMS SYSTEM WITH THE MS
AUTHORITY RESPONSIBLE.
FOR THE COORDINATION AND
INTEGRATION OF ALL STATE
ACTIVITIES TO ENSURE THE
PROVISION OF EFFECTIVE AND
<c.blue>FFICIENT EMERGENCY MEDICAL CARE.</c>
OUR GOALIS TO ORGANIZE
EMERGENCY CARE SYSTEMS WITHIN
CALIFORNIA JUST TO PROVIDE HIGH
QUALITY PATIENT CARE.
MS AS A SMALL DEPARTMENT BUT
WITHSIGNIFICANT
RESPONSIBILITIES IN THREE
CATEGORIES.
FIRST PRE HOSPITAL EMERGENCY
SERVICES WHICH IS ONE PIECE OF
AN INTEGRATED EMERGENCY CARE
NETWORK.
THE PROVIDES ONE OF OUR MAJOR
HEALTH CARE SAFETY NETS.
HOSPITAL NINE ONE ONE SERVICES
ARE WIDELY SEEN BY THE PUBLIC AS
A GUARANTEED MEDICAL SERVICE
REGARDLESS OF INSURANCE STATUS.
IN CALIFORNIA THERE ARE
CURRENTLY SIXTY THREE THOUSAND
CERTIFIED EMTS AND TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND LICENSE PARAMEDICS THE
RESPOND TO MORE THAN FOUR
MILLION NINE ONE ONE CALLS USING
AIR AND GROUND AMBULANCES.
SPECIFICALLY THE EMS AUTHORITY
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR SCOPE OF
PRACTICE TRAINING STANDARDS AND
REGULATIONS FOR EMT AND
PARAMEDIC PRACTICE AS WELL AS
PUBLIC SAFETY --
PERSONNEL.
WE LICENSE PARAMEDICS AND
DISCIPLINE THOSE LICENSES WHEN
NECESSARY.
WE ALSO OVERSEE FIRST AID
TRAINING STANDARDS AND
REGULATIONS THAT INCLUDE --
FOR THE PUBLIC --
AS WELL AS PUBLIC SAFETY
PERSONNEL THAT INCLUDE TACTICAL
MEDICAL CARE AUTOMATED EXTERNAL
DEFIBRILLATORS EPINEPHRINE FOR
ALLERGIC REACTIONS NALOXONE FOR
NARCOTIC OVERDOSE AND CARDIO
PULMONARY RESUSCITATION. ONE
IMPORTANT INITIATIVE FROM THE MS
AUTHORITY REGARDING THE ROLE OF
PARAMEDICS IS AN APPROVED HEALTH
WORKFORCE PILOT PROJECT. TO THE
OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT TO TEST
AND EVALUATE THE USED TO PICK OF
PARAMEDICS.
AND EXPANDED MOBILE HEALTH CARE
ROLES TO FILL SOME OF THE GAPS
IN OUR LOCAL HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
IMPROVE ACCESS. TO CARE AND
INTEGRATION CARE.
SOME OF THESE PROJECTS BEING
TESTED INCLUDE USE OF PARAMEDICS
FOR POST --
HOSPITAL DISCHARGE SHORT TERM
FOLLOW UP TO PREVENT READMISSION
ENGAGING IN LINKING NINE ONE ONE
OR MERGING SEE FREQUENT USERS TO
SOCIAL ANOTHER HEALTH SERVICES
TO BETTER MEET THEIR NEEDS.
SCREENING PATIENTS WITH MENTAL
MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS OR
ALCOHOL INTOXICATION AND
TRANSPORTING THOSE WITHOUT A
CUTE MEDICAL PROBLEMS DIRECTLY
TO A MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS CENTER
OR TO A SOBERING CENTER RATHER
THAN TO THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT.
AND WORKING WITH HOSPICE NURSES
TO PER DEPARTMENT VISITS AT THE
END OF LIFE.
THESE PROJECTS HAVE BEEN ROLLED
WELL OVER FOUR THOUSAND PATIENTS
WITH NO ADVERSE IMPACT.
AND OF SHOWN DEMONSTRABLE
BENEFIT ACCORDING TO OUR
INDEPENDENT EVALUATOR.
SECONDLY THE MS AUTHORITY
DEVELOPS GUIDELINES AND APPROVES
PLANS FOR EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SYSTEMS THAT ARE IMPLEMENTED AND
OPERATED BY --
THIRTY THREE LOCAL EMS AGENCIES.
THAT ARE COMPRISED OF TWENTY SIX
SINGLE COUNTY AGENCIES IN SEVEN
RURAL MULTI COUNTY AGENCIES.
DIRECT NINE ONE ONE AMBULANCE
SERVICES PROVIDED BY A MIXTURE
OF PUBLIC FIRE AGENCIES AND
PRIVATE PROVIDERS.
IN THIS OVERSIGHT ROLE THE EMS
AUTHORITY --
ALSO DEVELOPS REGULATIONS FOR
DESIGN AND QUALITY OF THE-SPECIALTY CARE SYSTEMS THAT
INCLUDE THE TRAUMA SYSTEM.
PEDIATRIC EMERGENCY CARE CENTERS
STROKES CENTERS CARDIAC CENTERS
AND POINT THE POISON CONTROL
CENTER.
THE ACTUAL FACILITIES ARE
DESIGNATED BY THE LOCAL EMS
AGENCIES. ONE OF OUR PRIORITY
INITIATIVES IS TO ASSESS THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE EMS SYSTEM
USING LOCAL AND REGIONAL DATA.
WE ALSO HAVE A GRANT FROM THE
CENTERS --
FOR MEDICAID AND AND MEDICARE
SERVICES TO DEVELOP HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGE BETWEEN EMS
AND HOSPITALS.
SO THE PARAMEDICS IN THE FIELD
CAN RECEIVE INFORMATION FROM THE
PATIENT'S ELECTRONIC HEALTH
RECORD.
AND THE PRE HOSPITAL
INTERVENTIONS BECOME PART OF THE
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORD.
THIS ALSO IMPROVES CARE DURING
THE DISASTER.
BY MAKING CRITICAL PATIENT
INFORMATION AVAILABLE WHEN
PATIENTS ARE TREATED IN
DIFFERENT SETTINGS OUTSIDE THEIR
USUAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
OUR THIRD MAJOR AREA OF
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO COORDINATE
THE MEDICAL RESPONSE TO DISASTER.
IN COOPERATION WITH THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES AND FOR
THIS WE PARTNER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
BUILD A PUBLIC HEALTH AND
MEDICAL RESPONSE INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR ANY TYPE OF DISASTER.
WE SUPPORTED LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
IN THE PAST YEAR WITH OUR
DISASTER FIELD RESOURCES. TO
EVACUATE PATIENTS FROM PATH OF
WHILE AND TO MOBILIZE OUR
DISASTER HEALTH CARE VOLUNTEER
NETWORK TO SUPPORT PATIENT CARE.
FOR THE CAMPFIRE IN BUTTE COUNTY
WE MOBILIZED --
RESOURCES THAT INCLUDED FIVE
AMBULANCE STRIKE TEAMS EACH OF
WHICH HAS FIVE AMBULANCES PASTA --
WE'D VEHICLE.
AND PROVIDED CARE FOR THE
SHELTER POPULATION --
BY COORDINATING MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED VOLUNTEERS FROM OUR
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSISTANCE
TEAMS DISASTER HEALTHCARE
VOLUNTEERS.
CALIFORNIA ERIN ARMY NATIONAL
GUARD AND NATIONAL DISASTER
MEDICAL SYSTEM TASK FORCE
MEMBERS.
WE ALSO MOBILIZED MORE THAN FOUR
HUNDRED VETERINARY VOLUNTEERS
AND SET UP AND MANAGE TWENTY
EIGHT MOBILE MEDICAL SHELTER
STRUCTURES FOR PATIENT ISEL FOR
PATIENTS ISOLATIONS --
I'LL STOP THERE IN TERMS THE
OVERVIEW ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
RELATED TO OUR USUAL SERVICES
AND AUTHORITIES.
THANK YOU THANKS RIGHT JENNY
COMMENTS FROM LA --
FINANCE QUESTIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS NOW.
OKAY I JUST A BRIEF QUESTION
JUST REGARDING --
SERVE YOUR OVERALL BUDGETS --
I MAKE NOTE THAT AND FOR
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE
REIMBURSEMENTS --
WAS BUDGET WE EXPECTED ABOUT
SEVENTEEN MILLION IS UP.
TO TWENTY OF SUCH ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE MILLION WERE PROPOSING DOWN
THE FIFTEEN MILLION CAN YOU JUST
PERHAPS ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT
AS THAT.
BUT I CAN SPECULATE AS TO WHY
THAT CASE.
YET YES WELL WHAT THE UP AND
THEN THE DAY AND THEN OF COURSE
WE HAVE A BUDGET IT DOWN AGAIN
SO WHAT WAS A SPIKE UP --
WOULD RESULT OF THIS IS A THIS
IS AS A RESULT OF THE HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGE GRANTS AL
QAEDA MOVEMENT OF OF DOLLARS IN
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY TO MEET
THOSE --
FEDERAL GRANT REQUIREMENTS OKAY
SO SO THIS IS FOR THE H. I. E.
THAT HEALTH INFORMATION EXCHANGE
THEN THAT'S CORRECT AND WE'LL OF
FOR THIS NEXT YEAR WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO GO BACK AND TRYING DO
A BUDGET ADJUSTMENT AS AS FUNDS
BECOME IDENTIFIED --
SPECIFICALLY FROM CMS WHICH WE
ARE EXPECTING THAT FLOW SO SO
JUST SO.
BECAUSE YOU HAD SEVENTY MILLION
BUDGET LAST YEAR WE ACTUALLY A
TWENTY FIVE MILLION THAT'S THE
H. I. GRAND IT'S NOW BUDGETED
FOR FIFTEEN MILLION SO WE'RE
EXPECTING THIS IS A ONE YEAR
GRANT TO OURS DO YOU EXPECT TO
TRY TO GET MORE MONEY YOU SAVE --
SO THE GRANT --
IS UP TO FORTY MILLION DOLLARS.
THROUGH SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH OF
TWENTY TWO FINANCE.
TO DO THE RIGHT PROCESSING ON ON
THE BUDGET YEAR AND THE OUT
YEARS.
THIS GRANT HAS A NINE TO ONE
MATCH SO --
WERE AUTHORIZED UP TO FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS WE WE IF WE FIND
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
THEY'LL TURN IT INTO FORTY
MILLION DAY WHICH IS SOMETHING
WE LOVE THE STATE TO LEARN HOW
TO DO TO SIR WELL AND THAT YES
EXACTLY.
SO JUST SO JUST THE AND THE THE
CLARIFIED AND AS FAR AS THIS
COMING YEAR WHICH IS BACKED DOWN
THE FIFTEEN MILLION THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY BUT BECAUSE IT HAS
BEEN REALIZED YET TO ACTUALLY
GET DRAW DOWN MORE MONEY. FOR
THE HIV GRANT I'M LOOKING
FINANCE NOW YOU'RE NOT IN YOUR
HEAD.
BILLION ARE ALMOST YEAH THAT'S
CORRECTIVE OF THE DEPARTMENT
RECEIVED AN AWARD WE WOULD
ADJUSTED.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO YOU JUST DON'T
WANT TO BECAUSE YOU HAVEN'T
GOTTEN IT YET PUT IN THE NUMBER
I'D SO I UNDERSTAND HOW THAT
SORT AND BY THE WAY AND I KNOW
YOU'VE MADE MENTION OF IT IN
YOUR OPENING.
REMARKS --
BUT HOW HOW'S THAT GOING NOW
THAT YOU KNOW SO IT SOUNDS LIKE
IT'S A GOOD ONE LOVES LOVES THAT
IDEA BUT HOW HOW'S THE
IMPLEMENTATION GOING I MEAN WE'D
BE ABLE TO CONNECT.
CONNECT WITH ALL THE H. OURS HOW
HOW'S THAT PROCESS YOU HAVE
SUCCEEDED ON THE DISASTER SIDE
WE'VE ALREADY CREATED IN THE
NETWORK WHERE PEOPLE IN THE
FIELD IT WHETHER THEY'RE IN --
SHELTERS ALTERNATE CARE SITES OR
OTHER HOSPITALS CAN'T.
LOG ON TO LOOK AT THE FOR
EMERGENCIES.
AND AND FUN AND I AM DEFINED
DRAWDOWN PATIENT RECORDS --
IN TERMS OF THE ACTUAL AIR AND
WE HAVE EMS --
SYSTEMS PROVIDERS IN CERTAIN
JURISDICTIONS WHO ARE RIGHT NOW
ABLE TO PULL UP PATIENT
INFORMATION ON IPADS.
IN THE FIELD --
WE HAVE NOT YET FULLY SUCCEEDED
IN IN X. DO HAVING THE
INFORMATION GO --
FROM THE FIELD INTO THE
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORD YET AND
GET OUTCOME DATA BACK BUT IT IS
MOVING A QUITE WELL AND THAT'S
ACTUALLY.
I'LL GIVE THE CREDIT TO DAN HERE
BECAUSE THAT'S BEEN HIS PET
PROJECT.
SO HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET MORE
FEDERAL NINETY CONTINUED FOR
DEVELOP THIS ABSOLUTELY AND SO
CURRENTLY --
SAN DIEGO AND ORANGE COUNTY AND
THOSE TWO JURISDICTIONS NATIONAL
COORDINATOR FOR HEALTH
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY WE WERE
ABLE O SUCCEED IN THOSE AREAS.
AND WERE ABLE --
TO TO SEARCH --
SEND THE INFORMATION TO THE
HOSPITAL --
AND THEN EMBEDDED IN THE HEALTH
THE HEALTH RECORD IN SAN DIEGO
IN PARTICULAR --
WE CAN ALSO IN SAN DIEGO PULL UP
UP POST FORMS WHICH ARE
POSITIONS ORDER FOR LIFE
SUSTAINING TREATMENT --
KIND AND LIVE LIFE DECISIONS AND
THE PARAMEDICS CAN THEN TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT INFORMATION IN THE
FIELD TO HELP THEM MAKE BETTER
CLINICAL DECISIONS ALL RIGHT.
AND THEN JUST OTHER I'D MAKE
NOTE THAT --
WE LOOK AT FEDERAL FUNDS HERE --
SO YOU KNOW WE BUDGET SIX
MILLION AND WE GOT SIX MILLION
PROVIDES APPROXIMATELY BUT THEN
THE BUDGET FOR IT.
WENT DOWN THE FOUR MILLION SO
WHAT'S THE REASON FOR THE FOR
THE CENTURY THIRD DROP IN
FEDERAL FUNDS WERE EXPECTING
THAT'S HERE.
IN THIS PARTICULAR INSTANCE I
BELIEVE IT'S A A I THINK IT'S A
REIMBURSEMENT ADJUSTMENT --
BASED UPON THE UPCOMING --
A FEDERAL FUND PERIOD AND I
THINK THAT --
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE WHAT
WE'RE SEEING IS SOME OF THIS IS
IS IMPACTED FROM OTHER HEALTH
INFORMATION EXCHANGE ALSO OKAY
SO I GUESS I'LL DEFERRED A
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON THE
EXACT DETAILS ON DOWN THAT IS
WHAT I WHAT I HAVE HERE AND YET
AND ON THE YOU KNOW.
WE HAVE ON THE TOP LINE WE HAVE
GENERAL FUND FEDERAL FUNDS OTHER
FUNDS DETAIL BELOW.
SO FEDERAL FUNDS SIX MILLION AND
AND THAT WAS UNDER OTHER FUNDS
I'M JUST TRYING TO CLARIFY LIKE
OKAY WHAT WHICH ONES ARE COMING
FROM WHICH POT AND SO --
SO TO THIS SO I'M LOOKING AT THE
LINES AS FEDERAL FUNDS --
EIGHT NINE OO.
AND SO THAT ALSO INVOLVED WITH
THE H. A YEAR NOW.
IF FOR BETTER WHAT FUNDS
SPECIFICALLY YES YEAH MILLION
DROP IS JUST A REDUCTION IN THE
FEDERAL GRANT THERE WAS A ONE
TIME GRANT THAT WAS RECEIVED.
FOR PULLS UP A POST TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SO WE JUST ADJUST
VIDEO OKAY SO BASICALLY THERE'S
A THERE'S INCLUSION OF THE PULSE
GRANTS AND SO THEREFORE THAT ARE
FUNDS HOURS RECEIVED IT ENDED IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SO WHICH IS A
JUST OK SO OKAY SO THAT.
OKAY SO IT'S A DIFFERENT PART
MONEY IN FEDERAL MONEY ALL RIGHT --
AND THE WORK FOR THAT GRANT I
MEAN IS IT CONCLUDED IS WAS THAT
OUR IS THAT GOING TO BE A ISSUE
FOR EMS IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
GRANT WAS FUNDING BEFORE.
SO -- THE
THE PREVIOUS GRANT WAS THE ONE
TIME -- IN
OFFICE THE NATIONAL COORDINATOR
FOR HEALTH INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY GRANT THAT WAS
INCLUDED AND SO --
THAT WORK HAS CONCLUDED AT THIS
POINT AND SO THAT THE NEW GRANT --
AS WE GO THROUGH THE PROCESS TO
DO A SECTION TWENTY EIGHT POINT
FIVE IN --
IN IN THE NEXT YEAR PROCESS WILL
BE INCLUDING THOSE PARTICULAR --
POSITIONS --
AND AS THIS GRANT AND SO IS
THEIR DESTRUCTION ARE OKAY SO
THAT'S GONNA BE PICKED UP WITH
ANOTHER.
RIGHT AND SO THERE'S A
CONTINUATION OF THE WORK RIGHT
OKAY ALL RIGHT THAT'S GOOD TO
KNOW ALRIGHT.
SORRY JUST DIED THE INTO THE
NUMBERS HERE IS THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL
THANK THANK YOU SORRY MUCH SO
THAT'S THAT THERE'S NO OTHER
QUESTIONS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO CONVERSIONS
LIKE IT POSITIONS DEPARTMENT --
ARE PENDING BUDGET PROPOSALS
REALLY FALL INTO THREE
CATEGORIES THE FIRST IS
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS IN ISSUE.
TWO IS ONE OF THOSE WHERE WE
WANT.
WE ARE ASKING TO CONVERT FOR
BLANKET POSITIONS TO PERMANENT
POSITIONS.
THAT ARE SUPPORTED BY EXISTING
FEDERAL FUNDING ALREADY IN THE
BUDGET.
AND WITH AN ON GOING WORK LOAD
THESE POSITIONS SUPPORT DATA
PROJECTS AN ANALYSIS THE TRAUMA
SYSTEM CORPS NADER AND AN OFFICE
TECHNICIAN.
WITHOUT PERMANENT POSITIONS HAS
BEEN DIFFICULT TO COMPLETE THE
NECESSARY PROGRAM ACTIVITIES DUE
TO PERSONNEL TURNOVER.
ALL RIGHT COMES FROM LA L.
[inaudible]
FINANCE QUESTIONS OKAY LET'S
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO TO
THREE ANOTHER TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT APPROVES --
AND WE'RE REQUESTING APPROVAL OF
THE USE OF THE MS PERSONNEL
FUNDS TO CONVERT TO POSITIONS
AUTHORIZED WITH LIMITED TERM
FUNDING TO PERMANENT. TO ADDRESS
THE LEGAL WORK LOAD OF PARAMEDIC
LICENSE DISCIPLINE --
WELL OUR DISCIPLINARY CASELOAD
IS INCREASED MODESTLY THERE'S
BEEN A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS AND
OTHER LEGAL CHALLENGES THAT
CONTINUE THE WORKLOAD PROJECTED
TWO YEARS AGO.
OKAY --
AVAIL COMMENTS FINANCE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OKAY THANK YOU --
AND THEN ON THE NEXT FOUR ISSUES
ARE IN THE LAST LEGISLATIVE
SESSION ISSUE --
FOR AB TWENTY TWO NINETY THREE
REQUIRES ALL EMT CERTIFYING
AGENCIES TO REPORT TO NILES OF
THE EMPTY APPLICANTS TO MS A
NUMBER THE EMS AUTHORITY AND THE
EMS AUTHORITY TO REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND TO OUR
COMMISSION --
THE EMS AUTHORITIES REQUESTING
ONE PERMANENT POSITION AND A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE THOUSAND
FROM THE GENERAL FUND SINCE THE
DATA NEEDS. TO BE COLLECTED FROM
SIXTY NINE DIFFERENT CERTIFYING
AGENCIES AND REPORTS GENERATED.
GATHERING THE INFORMATION IS
IMPORTANT TO INFORM THE USE OF
EMS TRAINING.
AS A MEANS OF REHABILITATION AND
ELIGIBILITY FOR FIRE SERVICE
EMPLOYMENT.
TALENTS MILIEU.
FINANCE QUESTIONS.
I GUESS THE I WOULD JUST MAKE
NOTE -- FOR
THIS CAME FROM A BILL THAT DOES --
PASSED BY THE LEGISLATURE --
THIS DATA IF I THE AUTHOR AND
OTHER AND AND HER COLLEAGUES
INCLUDING MYSELF WOULD BE
INTERESTED AND ACTUALLY BEING
ABLE TO SEE THE STATE OF WHEN.
THIS PERSON WHO WERE PUSHING FOR
DATA SO --
THIS IS GONNA BE IMPORTANT TO
INFORM SOME POLICY.
PROPOSALS IN THE FUTURE AND SO I
HOPE THAT --
HAS WILL TALK ABOUT THE POSITION
THAT -- THAT
ALSO RESULT IN SOME THAT DATA
THAT CAN BE SURE OF THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT ON THE THAT
THE ISSUES.
ABSOLUTELY AND WE HOPE TO BE
ABLE TO GET ACCURATE --
OR DATA --
ON THIS DID IT WE HAVE TO GET
ALL THE AGENCIES ARE REPORTING
THAT CONSISTENTLY AND AND ACTOR
EARLY.
IS ALWAYS WE WE LOOK FOR WE LOOK
FOR TO RECOGNIZE IT LET'S WHY
WOULD THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HEARING
TESTS OKAY SO WE HAVE THE PEOPLE
THAT THE PERSON TO DO IT.
OKAY ISSUE NUMBER.
FIVE ISSUE NUMBER FIVE IS THE
RESULT OF AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY
ONE THE REQUIRED ALL LOCAL.
EMS AGENCIES REPORT DATE ON A
REPORTS IT'S ACTUALLY BUILDING
ON PREVIOUS LEGISLATION FROM A.
B. TWELVE TWENTY THREE THE
REQUIRED IN THE EMS AUTHORITY TO
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS. TO
DEVELOP STANDARDS FOR REPORTING
THIS DATA.
ABOUT LEFT INVOLUNTARY FOR THE
LOCAL AGENCIES.
SO THE EMS AUTHORITY IS
REQUESTING ONE PERMANENT
POSITION AND A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS. TO
AND FOR SOMEONE TO ANALYZE THE
EXTENSIVE DATA DEVELOP A PUBLIC
REPORT AND IDENTIFY AN AUTOMATED
METHOD TO MANAGE DATA.
THAT'S CURRENTLY DONE MANUALLY
ON EXPELS EXCEL SPREADSHEET.
AND JUST SO YOU UNDERSTAND
EMANCIPATION OFFLOAD TIME IS THE
TIME THAT FROM WHAT IT WAS FROM
THE TIME AN AMBULANCE ARRIVES AT
AN EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT WITH A
PATIENT.
UNTIL THAT PATIENT IS ACCEPTED --
BY THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
STAFF AND WHERE AS IN MINUTE
MOST PLACES THAT IS VERY SHORT
TIME PERIOD.
IN OTHERS IT CAN GO LITERALLY
HOURS AND SO THAT AMBULANCE IS
STUCK AT THE HOSPITAL WAITING
FOR THE PATIENT TO BE ACCEPTED
BEFORE THEY CAN GO BACK INTO
SERVICE IN THE COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU ALEJO [inaudible]
FINANCE [inaudible]
THE MEMBERS.
OKAY SO AGAIN ONCE AGAIN --
YEAH -- I
MEAN THIS IS ACTUALLY ISN'T A
VERY IMPORTANT --
BUDGETARY ISSUE FOR OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND SURE YOU KNOW IT
WAS --
MISTER ACTOR --
WHEN WE HAVE OUR --
ESSENTIALLY ARE --
AMBULANCE PERSONNEL TIED UP
THANK YOU CUT OFF THE TIME AS
FOR THE OTHER SIDE SO IS
REFERRED TO AS WALL TIME.
THAT MEANS ARE NOT AVAILABLE TO
HELP ANYONE ELSE RIGHT AND SO
WAS OUR CITY AND I AM OTHER
GOVERNMENTS OR WHO HAVE OUR
OPERATING FIRE IN THIS THE AND
ON SERVICES.
THAT MEANS THEY HAVE TO DO IN
ORDER TO BE SURE THAT PEOPLE
VALUABLE THEY MAY HAVE TO BRING
MORE PEOPLE --
HIRE MORE PEOPLE MORE HAVE MORE
PEOPLE AVAILABLE SO THIS AGAIN
IMPORTANT THAT SO THE SMALL
BUDGET EXPENDITURE CAN HOPEFULLY
LEAD TO SAVINGS AND GREATER
SAVINGS FOR PARTICULAR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS APPRECIATE THAT --
WE'RE GONNA BE DOING THIS AND WE
DO HAVE SOME INTERESTING RESULTS
FROM THE FIRST DAY YEAR OF DATA
COLLECTION OF THAT FROM ONLY
ABOUT TEN OR ELEVEN OF OUR LOCAL
EMS AGENCIES --
BUT WE DON'T KNOW HOW
REPRESENTATIVE THAT DATE IS BUT
WE'VE -- PUT
OUT SOME --
INTERESTING REPORTS AND ACTUALLY
PUBLISH THE RESULTS ON THIS
EXCELLENT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THANKS ISSUE ISSUE
NUMBER --
SIX SEVENTY IS THAT REQUIRES A
MODULE.
ON LEAD EXPOSURE FOR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS WITHIN THE EXISTING
AID OUR PREVENTIVE HEALTH
PRACTICES COURSE.
THE TRAINING CURRICULUM FOR THIS
COURSE WAS DEVELOPED AND
APPROVED BY M. SAID ONE OF OUR
LITTLE KNOWN.
RESPONSIBILITIES AND ALSO IN TO
REQUEST A ONE TIME AND A SINGLE
GENERAL FUND OF A HUNDRED
SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO ADD THE TOPIC OF LEAD
POISONING TO THE CHILD CARE
PROVIDER.
PREVENTIVE HEALTH COURSE
ALTHOUGH MC CHARGES A FEE FOR
COURSE REVIEWS IN FOR COMPLETION
STICKERS THE FEES DO NOT PROVIDE
ENOUGH FUNDS FOR THIS NEW
MANDATE.
SO THIS IS NOT A POSITION THIS
IS A ONE TIME.
A COMES FROM L. L. [inaudible]
FINANCE [inaudible]
ME MEMBERS.
IT'S IT'S INTERESTING THAT MS A
WITH THIS IS PART OF THE ANSWER
BUDGET THAT HAS TO DO WITH CHILD
CARE IT HAS TO DO PUBLIC HEALTH.
BUT OKAY NEXT ITEM --
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SEVEN THE
RESULTS FROM SB SIX NINE FIVE
THAT ALLOWS M. SOON LOCAL
ENTITIES TO ACCEPT AN INDIVIDUAL
TAX ID NUMBER FOR EMT
CERTIFICATION --
THE EMS AUTHORITY REQUEST A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
IMPLEMENT THIS LEGISLATION
THROUGHOUT REACH TRAINING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
AND TO EVALUATE MODIFICATION TO
OUR LICENSING DATABASE.
LA OF COMMONS FINANCE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
ARE IS MOVE ON ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT ROS THE ISSUE IS.
RELATED TO INCREASED
ADMINISTRATIVE REQUIREMENTS AND
FEES -- IN
THE MSO THIRTIES REQUESTING A
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THE NEXT TWO BUDGET
YEARS AND A HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN.
BEGINNING TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY
TWO TO SUPPORT INCREASED COSTS
FROM OUR IT DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES CONTRACTED
SERVICES.
AND FACILITIES EXPENSES REST IN
THE PAST BY REDIRECTING PROGRAM
RESOURCES THAT IMPACT OTHER EMS
ACTIVITIES.
A. L. L. COMMENTS NOW FINANCE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
OKAY ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT SO I THINK THAT --
SO WE'LL GO AHEAD TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENTS THEN --
IS THERE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ISSUES ONE THROUGH EIGHT FOR THE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY.
SEEN KNOWN AT THE MICROPHONE
THAN WHAT WE WILL DO IS WE WILL
HOLD OPEN ISSUES NUMBER TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE SIX SEVEN AND
EIGHT AND THIS ITEM.
NICE TO SEE NO OTHER QUESTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION WEEKS ANTICIPATE
WILL PROBABLY TAKE THESE THINGS
UP AFTER THE MAY REVISE.
THE VIDAK THANKS SO MUCH
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
NEXT INTO SEE UP IS THE OFFICE
OF STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT [inaudible]
CELLS.
AND SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH --
THE OFFICE --
AND WHAT LA ON FINANCE AND THEN
WE DO HAVE --
SEVERAL STAKEHOLDER PROPOSAL
CELESTA STAKEHOLDERS TO COME UP --
AFTER CONCLUSION OF THE OVERVIEW --
FOR ISSUE NUMBER ONE AND WITH
THAT THE OVERVIEW AND BEFORE WE
BEGIN -- TOO
AGAIN FOR THE RECORD IF EVERYONE
CAN INTRODUCE THEMSELVES A START
WITH THE AGENCY AFTER CENTERS.
A ROBERT DAVID DIRECTOR FOR
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT THANK YOU.
I SCOTT CHRISTMANN A W. DIRECTOR
IN CHAU OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING.
GOOD MORNING NORRLAND I
SPRINKLED WITH THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONS EDUCATION FOUNDATION
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WITH AN
ATTACHMENT.
J. HOWARD DEPUTY DIRECTOR AUSTIN
THANK YOU VALUE AND JOHNSON
DEALIO.
FINANCE.
ORANGE AND FINANCE JACOB LAMB
FINANCE OKAY WELCOME SO LET'S GO
AHEAD BEGIN WITH --
THE OVERVIEW WELCOME I THANK YOU
SENATORS.
AND GOOD MORNING AT THE OFFICE
OF STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT ADVANCES
CALIFORNIANS ACCESS TO SAFE
QUALITY HEALTHCARE ENVIRONMENTS.
BY FOCUSING IN THREE PRIMARY
AREAS.
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
HEALTHCARE DATA COLLECTION AND
REPORTING.
AND HEALTH CARE CONSTRUCTION AND
FINANCING.
AJ PAGE. TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
PROPOSED BUDGET.
IS ONE HUNDRED NINETY NINE POINT
SEVEN MILLION.
AT ABOUT 42% OF OUR BUDGET IS
GENERAL FUND.
THE REST IS VERY SPECIAL FUNDS
OF MANY OF THEM WERE FEE
SUPPORTED.
WE HAVE A SMALL AMOUNT OF
FEDERAL FUNDING.
ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE MILLION A
FOR WORKFORCE PROGRAMS.
OUR HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT DIVISION --
AND HEALTH PROFESSIONS EDUCATION
FOUNDATION FOCUS ON WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT.
OUR HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE --
PROGRAMS SEEK TO INCREASE ACCESS
TO HEALTHCARE FOR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES.
AND POPULATIONS BY INCENTIVIZING
A DIVERSE AND CULTURALLY.
AND LINGUISTICALLY COMPETENT
HEALTH CARE WERE.
WE FOCUS ON RECRUITING AND
RETAINING VARIOUS HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS IN AREAS OF AN
UNMET NEED.
WE INCREASE THE GEOGRAPHIC
DISTRIBUTION OF CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH CARE WORK FORCE.
AND WE EXPLORED NEW SERVICE
DELIVERY MODELS. ONE OF OUR
PRIMARY HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS IS THE SONG BROWN
PROGRAM.
AND SO GRANT AWARDS FUNDING TO
HEALTHCARE TRAINING AND
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
AND UNDERSERVED AREAS.
THIS IS DONE THROUGH THE
RECRUITMENT OF UNDER REPRESENTED
MINORITIES.
CLINICAL TRAINING IN AREAS OF
UNMET NEED.
GRADUATE PLACEMENT OF HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONALS IN THOSE
AREAS OF UNMET NEED.
I'M OUR STREETS IN THE THIRD
YEAR OF A SERIES OF ONE TIME
THIRTY THREE POINT THREE MILLION.
GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATIONS FOR
THE SONG BROWN PROGRAM.
I MIGHT NOTE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES TO CONTINUE THIS
FUNDING PERMANENTLY.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES AT FIFTY MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT CURRENT.
HEAD MENTAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS.
WHICH OF FOCUSED ON
STRENGTHENING THE PUBLIC MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM.
AJ BUT IS ALSO TESTED
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PLANNING
COUNCIL WITH DEVELOPMENT OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
WORKFORCE EDUCATION AND TRAINING.
FIVE YEAR PLAN.
FOR TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE THAT PLAN IS NOW
POSTED ON OUR WEBSITE.
MOVING ON THE HEALTH CARE DATA
COLLECTION AND REPORTING OUR
INFORMATION SERVICES DIVISION
SERVICES HEALTHCARE DATA
COLLECTION AND REPORTING HUB.
WE COLLECT HEALTHCARE DATA FROM
NEARLY SIX THOUSAND HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES WHICH ARE LICENSED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
WE MAKE MUCH MORE DATA AVAILABLE
TO THE PUBLIC RESEARCHERS
POLICYMAKERS THE MEDIA AND
OTHERS.
WE ALSO PRODUCE MEASURES AND
ALICE SEIZE AND REPORTS.
ON HEALTH CARE OUTCOMES AND
QUALITY.
AN OTHER RELATED HELP TOPICS.
I WE'VE BEEN IMPLEMENTING A COST
TRANSPARENCY R. X. PROGRAM THIS
IS PURSUANT TO A LAW AUTHORED BY
THE FORMER CHAIR OF THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE SENATOR HERNANDEZ.
SINCE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
EIGHTEEN PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANIES HAVE BEEN PROVIDING
SIXTY DAY NOTIFICATIONS.
DIRECTLY TO SPECIFIED REGISTERED
PURCHASERS WHEN A DRUG THIS COST
INCREASES ABOVE A CERTAIN
THRESHOLD.
IN EARLY MARCH --
WILL BEGIN PROVIDING MONTHLY
REPORTS FROM MANUFACTURERS.
IDENTIFY NEW DRUGS THAT WERE
INTRODUCED TO MARKET ABOVE A
CERTAIN COST [inaudible]
IN JUNE.
ASPERA PROVIDE QUARTERLY REPORTS
FROM FROM MANUFACTURERS THAT
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
ABOUT THE INCREASES TO EXISTING
DRUGS THAT HAVE BEEN SUBJECT TO
THE NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENT TO
PURCHASERS.
DODGE BUT WE'VE ALSO BEEN
IMPLEMENTING ANOTHER COST
TRANSPARENCY PROGRAM THE HEALTH
CARE PAYMENTS DATA PROGRAM. FOR
THE BUDGET ACT.
I SUPPOSE RESPONSIBLE FOR
CONVENING A REVIEW COMMITTEE TO
ADVISE US ON THE ESTABLISHMENT
IMPLEMENTATION SUSTAINABILITY AN
ON GOING ADMINISTRATION OF THE
HEALTH CARE PAYMENTS DATABASE.
THE FIRST MEETING OF THE REVIEW
COMMITTEE WILL CONVENE IN MARCH.-AND WILL CONTINUE TO KEEP THE
LEGISLATURE INFORMED ON OUR
PROGRESS.
MOVING ON HEALTHCARE
CONSTRUCTION FINANCING --
WHERE THE BUILDING DEPARTMENT
FOR CALIFORNIA'S HOSPITALS AND
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES?
I'VE BEEN ADMINISTERS THE
SEISMIC SAFETY PROGRAM WHICH IS
FOCUSED ON STRENGTHENING
CALIFORNIA'S HOSPITAL BUILDINGS.
SO THEY CAN REMAIN OPERATIONAL
IN THE EVENT OF AN EARTHQUAKE OR
OTHER DISASTER.
TODAY MORE THAN 95% OF ACUTE
CARE HOSPITAL BUILDINGS IN THE
STATE.
NOW COMPLY WITH THE SEISMIC
SAFETY ACTS TWENTY TWENTY
EARTHQUAKE COLLAPSE STANDARD.
MEANING THEY'RE RATED TO REMAIN
STANDING AFTER STRONG EARTHQUAKE.
BY TWENTY THIRTY THE STANDARDS
WILL BEAT THAT ALL ACUTE CARE
BUILDINGS MUST BE CAPABLE OF
CONTINUOUS OPERATIONS AFTER A
STRONG EARTHQUAKE.
AND WITH RESPECT TO THE TWENTY
TWENTY STANDARD LAST YEAR'S AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES.
PROVIDES FOR AN EXTENSION.
OF UP TO THREE YEARS FOR
RETROFITTING OR RIVER OR
REMOVING SERVICES AND UP TO FIVE
YEARS FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION. FOR
THOSE HANDFUL OF HOSPITALS THAT
WILL HAVE TO DEADLINE.
ELIGIBLE HOSPITALS HAVE UNTIL
APRIL FIRST TWENTY NINETEEN TO
SUBMIT AN APPLICATION FOR AN
EXTENSION. TO THE JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY DEADLINE.
WE CONTINUE TO EMPLOY NEW
TECHNOLOGIES THAT FACILITATE
FASTER AND MORE COLLABORATIVE
PLAN REVIEW AND REDUCE DELAYS
AND DISRUPTIONS CAUSED BY
CONSTRUCTION CHANGES.
ELECTRONIC PLAN SUBMISSION IS
APPROACHING OUR GOAL OF A 100%
OF ALL SUBMISSIONS.
AND THEN FINALLY THE CAL
MORTGAGE PROGRAM PROVIDES HEALTH
FACILITY CONSTRUCTION LOAN
INSURANCE TO NONPROFIT.
AND GOVERNMENT FACILITIES AT NO
COST TO TAXPAYERS.
OTHER PROGRAM ASSIST
CALIFORNIA'S NONPROFIT AND
PUBLIC HEALTH FACILITIES TO GAIN
ACCESS TO LOW COST FINANCING.
FOR THE CAPITAL CONSTRUCTION
NEEDS.
AS OF DECEMBER THE PROGRAM'S
INSURANCE PORTFOLIO CONSISTED OF
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION IN LOANS
FOR EIGHTY FACILITY PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY
PRESENTATION IF THERE ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU --
KALLIO COMMENTS [inaudible]
FINANCE.
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS NO.
OKAY --
ACTUALLY SO I JUST --
IN TERMS OF YOUR OVERALL FUNDING --
I MAKE NOTE THAT --
LAST YEAR --
BOX BUT WAS BUDGETED ABOUT
ACTUALLY THE REVISED STATES A
WHITE -- WAS
A HUNDRED AND FIVE AND THEN THE
PROPOSED IS --
EIGHTY THREE MILLION SO
BASICALLY DOWN ABOUT WELL TEN
MILLION FROM LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
REQUESTS AND A LITTLE MORE THAN
THAT REVISED --
SO WHAT'S WOULD SELL CAN --
WHAT'S --
THE TEN MILLION DECREASE FROM.
FOR SO JUST TO A TABLE SET AND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN OFTEN RECEIVE
THE FIRST PORTION OF A THREE
YEAR THIRTY THREE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLAR AUGMENTATION THAT
ALLOWED.
US BUT TO CARRY OVER DOLLARS IF
THEY DID NOT SPEND IT ALL --
IN SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN THERE WAS
ABOUT TWELVE MILLION WORTH OF
SAVINGS THAT HAVE BEEN CARRIED
OVER IN THIS BUDGET FROM
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN INTO EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN SO THAT'S WHAT THAT
TOLD BY AN INCREASE FROM
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO EAT.
FROM THE BUDGET TO PROPOSED IS.
AN FROM EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO
NINETEEN TWENTY AND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THEIR SIXTY MILLION FOR
THE HEALTH CARE --
DATA PORTAL THAT OFFERS PLAYING
TOGETHER AS ONE REPEAT THAT
SORRY I MISSED THAT YOU SAID FOR
THE DATA PORTAL YESLER SIXTY
MILLION IN EIGHTEEN NINETY AND
THAT'S A ONE TIME OKAY THREATEN
THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET.
IN NINETEEN TWENTY THAT SIXTY
MILLION FALLS AWAY.
BUT THERE'S AN FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR AUGMENTATION FOR MENTAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE PROGRAMS.
THAT IS APPEARING IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY OKAY SO JUST TO
CLEAR FIVE FIND HEAR YOU SAYING
IS IS THAT HERE'S SOME
CARRYOVER MONEY THAT'S THE
DEPTHS BUT THE DIFFERENCES THE
OUT MILLION SO. ONE AUSTIN IS%
RECEIVE THESE TELEPHONE
AUGMENTATIONS THESE RATHER LARGE
TELEPHONE AUGMENTATIONS OF WE
HAVE PRO INCLUDED CARRYOVER
PROVISIONS THAT ALLOW OUGHT TO
SPEND THIS MONEY OVER A PERIOD
OF TIME --
THAT'S ALSO --
INCLUDED FOR THERE'S THAT THEY
RECEIVE AN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
WHICH THEY WILL LIKELY HAVE TO
CARRY OVER INTO NINETEEN TWENTY
OKAY BUT AT THIS TIME WE'RE
ASSUMING THEY'RE GOING TO SPEND
THE ENTIRE APPROPRIATION IN.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO MAKE SURE
THEY HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO SPEND
THAT MONEY IF THEY NEED TO SPEND
IT.
IN EIGHTEEN NINETY OKAY SO SO
BASICALLY THIS TEN MILLION
DECREASED DOES NOT REPRESENTS A
TEN MILLION.
COTTON PERSON --
ACTIVITY AND SO FORTH.
OKAY BECAUSE WHO AM I IT'S
CARRIED OVER.
THAT WILL THEN JUST SUSTAIN THAT
ACTIVITY GALA I THINK IT'S A
LITTLE MORE BECAUSE IT'S A
LITTLE COMPLEX BECAUSE THERE'S A
LOT OF ONE TIME LOG ENSURE RATE.
IN AND THAT'S WHY IT SOMETIMES
WHEN LOOKING AT THE REINVENT SO
I'M ASKING FOR THE EXPLANATION
BECAUSE I KNOW WE DO YEAH WE DID.
PROP SEVEN THE ON THAT THE THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THE DRY YOU
THEY'LL YOU THE CIVIL.
THE EVER LAST TWO YEARS AND SO
THAT'S I'M JUST TRYING TO SORT
OUT LIKE WHERE'S THAT MONEY
COMING FROM RIGHT SO.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THAT'S A IT'S
VERY HELPFUL TO TO NOW OKAY AND
I THINK EVERYTHING ELSE.
ALL RIGHT OKAY.
I'D SENIOR NO OTHER --
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
WE'RE DOING OCCUPIED OVERVIEW.
OKAY BUT THIS IS THAT THE IF YOU
WISH THAT OF THE CENTER STONE
THANK YOU I'M SORRY I'M I'M LATE
AND AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE A A
SILVER TSUNAMI THAT'S GOING ON
RIGHT NOW AND WE'VE HAD SOME
ISSUES IN OUR DISTRICT AS FAR AS
GETTING DELAYED INSPECTIONS
ESPECIALLY.
FINAL INSPECTIONS FOR OPERATING
ASSISTED LIVING FACILITIES IN
PARTICULAR ONE IN MERRY AT US I
I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
DOING TO ADDRESS THESE DELAYS
THIS THIS --
PARTICULAR FACILITY HAS BEEN.
SITTING FOR ABOUT SIX MONTHS
READY TO GO READY TO TAKE ON NEW
CLIENTS AND YOU CAN GET THE
FINAL INSPECTION.
IF IF IT'S A SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY WE TYPICALLY DON'T DO
THE INSPECTIONS WE SAID WE SET
THE CONSTRUCTION STANDARDS BUT
IT'S UP TO THE LOCAL --
TO DO THE CONSTRUCTION
INSPECTION --
BY UNDERSTANDING SLUSH FATHERS
DURING THE INSPECTION OF THIS
PARTICULAR FACILITY AND I'M JUST
A JUSTBRING IT UP BECAUSE OF
SOME FIRST TIME I HEARD THAT
THERE IS A DELAY USING AND
GETTING THINGS MOVING FORWARD
AND I HOPE THAT YOU'VE GOT SOME.
STREAMLINING GOING ON WITHIN
YOUR DEPARTMENT BECAUSE WE NEED
THESE FACILITIES ONLINE ISSUE
NOW.
I CONCUR AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH YOUR STAFF ON THAT
SPECIFIC FACILITY.
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ENGAGED THANKS FOR BRINGING
UP CENTER.
OKAY ST NOT OKAY SO WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO NOW IS AT THIS PARTY A
REVIEW WE ACTUALLY THREE
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSAL SO WHY.
ARE YOU ASK PEOPLE TO DO THIS
PART THE WATERS OF MOVE AROUND
THE TABLE TO SELECT HAVE THE
AGENCY OF THE TABLES.
THAT LEAVES THE DIRECTOR OR
WHATEVER --
YOUR STAFF YOU WANT TO HAVE TO
HEAR THE PROPOSAL CHAIRS UP TO
THE FRONT HERE.
AND SO WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO FIRST
IS -- AND
WHAT WE'LL DO IS JUST --
FOR THE AUDIENCE THAT --
WILL GO AHEAD SO WE HAD TO EACH
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSAL IN TURN.
SO AS TO START OFF WITH --
MIRAMAR AND FINANCIAL CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
FIRST --
EACH STAKEHOLDER PROS WE GOT
THREE MINUTES TO PRESENT I KNOW
YOU'VE HAD A CHANCE TO TALK TO
MY STAFF AND OTHERS SO.
BASICALLY --
OF THE THREE MINUTES YOU CAN
COVER IT AND THEN ALSO WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS WE'RE GONNA
HEAR TO THREE STAKEHOLDER
PROPOSALS THAT WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE OVERVIEW AND THE
THE STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS AT THE
MICROPHONE --
FOR SO FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
INTERESTED MAKING PUBLIC
COMMENTS --
WILL BE TAKING PART COP OF
ACCOUNT OVERVIEW IN THREE
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS AS HIS
RECLUSIVE THESE THREE
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS.
SO LET'S GO AHEAD BEGIN --
WITH THAT MERE MORTENSEN THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOUSE
MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO REQUEST AN
AUGMENTATION TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO FUND PRIMARY CARE
RESIDENCY SLOTS THROUGH THE SONG
BROWN PROGRAM AT THIRTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR ON AN
ONGOING BASIS.
CCHA RESPECTFULLY REQUEST OF
THIS APPROPRIATION BE INCREASED
TO THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
PER YEAR INCLUDING AND THIS ONE
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET YEAR.
AND THAT AT LEAST THREE MILLION
DOLLARS BE SET ASIDE EACH YEAR
FOR PEDIATRIC RESIDENCY PROGRAMS.
AND THE SONG BROWN PROGRAM
PEDIATRIC PROGRAMS ARE CURRENTLY
NOT BEING FUNDED EQUITABLY
COMPARE TO THE OTHER PROGRAM
TYPES.
DUE TO RECENT CHANGES TO THE
APPLICATION CRITERIA.
IF YOU LOOK OF FENDER HANDED YOU
MY HAND OUT.
A HAND TO HAND OUT THAT WILL
SHOW YOU ADAM AND CHART
[inaudible] ONE FIVE THAT IN
EARLIER YEARS PEDIATRIC PROGRAMS
ACTUALLY RECEIVED OVER 30% OF
ALL AVAILABLE FUNDING AND S
OWN AND IN THE MOST RECENT TWO
ALLOCATIONS IN WHICH THAT FROM
FUNDING OVERALL FUNDING FOR SOME
AROUND DRAMATICALLY INCREASED.
PEDIATRIC PROGRAMS ONLY RECEIVED
ABOUT 4% OF AVAILABLE FUNDING
AND SAW NO ACTUAL REAL DOLLAR
INCREASES IN THEIR FUNDING --
AND SO WE'RE SEEKING TO RECTIFY
THIS BY ASKING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE APPROPRIATED SET
ASIDE APPROXIMATELY 10% OF THE
AVAILABLE FUNDING.
THE SECOND CHART THAT WE
PROVIDED SHOWS YOU HOW THE
PROPOSAL WOULD WORK BASED ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO FINISH
OUT THE THREE YEARS FOR AS
PROPOSED BY GOVERNOR BROWN.
AND ALSO TO DO THIS ON AN
ONGOING BASIS WERE ACTUALLY
ASKING THAT AN EXTRA TWO MILLION
DOLLARS BE ALLOCATED TO THE
PROGRAM EACH YEAR SO THAT THE
10% WE ARE ASKING --
FOR IS MADE UP OF THE MONEY
PEDIATRIC PROGRAMS HAVE
TRADITIONALLY RECEIVED FROM
Sí
FUNDING AND BY DOING IT THAT WE
WERE MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
PULLING MONEY AWAY FROM ANY
OTHER PROGRAM TYPES WHO MAY HAVE
BENEFITTED FROM THE CHANGE TO
THE RULES.
SO I JUST WANNA AND BY SHARING A
TWO REASONS WHY I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT THIS THE
BEST A ADEQUATELY FUND PEDIATRIC
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS THE FIRST TO
AS YOU KNOW MISTER CHAIR
PEDIATRIC ACT PEDIATRICIANS
RECEIVE SIGNIFICANTLY MORE.
ACUTE CARE TRAINING WITH
CHILDREN ADOLESCENTS AND ALLOWS
THEM TO HANDLE A LOT OF
CONDITIONS IN THE COMMUNITY
WITHOUT HAVING TO REFER A CHILD
TO URGENT CARE OR TO A
SPECIALIST.
MRS MORE HELPFUL FOR FAMILY
MEMBERS AND ALSO CAN BE A COST
SAVINGS TO PAY YEARS INCLUDING
THE STATE --
AND SO WE THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT THERE BE ADEQUATE
NUMBERS OF PEDIATRICIANS IN THE
COMMUNITY.
SECONDLY PEDIATRIC RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS STEVE DRAMATICALLY LES
FEDERAL FUNDING THAN OTHER
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS TO OVER 50%
OF PEDIATRIC RESIDENCY PROGRAMS
ARE FUNDED BY CHILDREN'S
HOSPITALS TO RECEIVE NO.
LITTLE TO NO MEDICARE GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION FUNDING --
AND AS A RESULT AND THE FUNDING
THAT THEY DO RECEIVE FROM THE
FEDERAL LEVEL DOESN'T COVER
THEIR ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS OF
THE CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS MAKE UP
THE DIFFERENCE --
AND AS A RESULT THEY CAN OFFER
FEWER SLOTS TO PEDIATRICIANS SO
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR BOTH OF
THESE REASONS AT THE STATE MAKE
SURE THAT PEDIATRIC PROGRAMS ARE
RECEIVING A FAIR SHARE OF THE
FUNDING THAT'S AVAILABLE AND WE
HOPE THAT YOU WILL INCLUDE OUR
PROPOSAL IN FINAL BUDGET.
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU.
BYE SURPRISE --
PRESSES CLOSE I WAS A FORMER
PEDIATRIC RESIDENCY DIRECTORS
AND SOME FAMILIARITY WITH
FINANCING --
PRESIDENCY EDUCATION --%
FIRST ACTUALLY AND ANY COMMENTS
FROM ASHKHABAD --
IN THOSE THOSE SAID THAT --
THERE'S ACTUALLY EVEN THE KLEIN
IN FUNNY PEDIATRIC RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS AND YOU CRITERIA SO
PERHAPS CAN YOU TRUST THAT --
WE OBVIOUSLY DON'T TAKE A
POSITION AT THIS TIME BUT S
OWN IS TRADITIONALLY BEEN A
COMPETITIVELY.
FUNDED PROGRAM COMPETITIVELY
BASED PROGRAM AND THE CHIPS KIND
OF FALL WHERE THEY MAY --
I I DO KNOW THAT I'VE PERSONALLY.
PRESENTED A CHECK TO THE OAKLAND
CHILDREN'S OF PEDIATRIC
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS I KNOW THAT
SOME PROGRAMS ARE GETTING SOME
FUNDS [inaudible]
BUT TO SO WHY SHE MAY BE --
WELL ACTUALLY LOOKS LIKE MANY
QUESTIONS MEGLIO.
FINANCE.
WE DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE A
POSITION AT THIS TIME SINCE YOU
HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO REVIEW
BUT WE WANT TO KNOW THAT'S NOT
PART OF THAT GOVERNOR SPENDING
PLAN --
HAPPY TO PARTICIPATE IN FURTHER
DISCUSSION OKAY.
WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS FROM AS
FAR NOT THAT WERE NOT PART OF
THE INITIAL --
GOVERNOR SPENDING PLAN I WOULD
MENTION CENTER IS THAT --
IF YOU DO START CARVING OUT
SPECIFIC FUNDING FOR CPAS BOX
BECAUSE AGAIN IT'S BEEN A
COMPETITIVE PROGRAM BUT WE'RE
CERTAINLY WILLING TO WORK WITH
THE STAKEHOLDERS LEGISLATURE ON
THIS OKAY.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
A GUEST CENTER SEVEN THANK YOU
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND YEP BUT YOU
KNOW.
WHEN YOU PRESENT A BILL IN THE
LEGISLATURE USUALLY WHICH ARE
PRESENT IT'S NOT WHAT USUALLY
ENDS UP BEING AND THE THE FINAL
PRODUCT?
OF THE GOVERNOR'S DESK THINGS
ARE AMENDED AND I'M SURE THAT
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE.
OPEN TO ENLIGHTENMENT SEND AND
YOU YOU CERTAINLY HAVE BEEN
LYING TO US WITH THE THE NEED
FOR MORE MONEY FOR PEDIATRIC
RESIDENCY IS IN A MUCH YOU KNOW
THAT I SUPPORT THAT --
MOST OF THE ADMISSIONS THAT WE
HAVE IT EMERGENCY ROOMS ARE FOR
PEDIATRIC PATIENTS IS DOCTOR PAN
BRADLEY KNOWS.
AND WE HAVE A PHYSICIAN SHORTAGE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
WE WORK HARD WHEN I WAS ON THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTIES.
JUMP START IF YOU WILL YOU SEE
ARMED MEDICAL SCHOOL --
TOOK A TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION FROM OUR BOARD.
TO GET THE STATE.
TO BASICALLY CHRIS ON THE THE
NEW NEW NEW NEW MEDICAL SCHOOL
[inaudible]
SO -- AND I
APPRECIATE THE THE GOVERNOR'S
EXTENSION TO THE MONEY THAT
ALREADY HAS BEEN ALLOCATED BY
THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION
WHICH IS COVERING FOR THE NEXT
TWO YEARS I THINK THIS IS
STARTING IN --
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE THE THE ON
GOING COMMITMENT --
BUT I STILL DON'T KNOW IF THAT
WE CAN SAY WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE APPRECIATE
THE THE GOVERNOR'S ENTHUSIASTS
ABOUT THIS BUT I HAVE A QUESTION
THAT MAYBE THE LA --
AND AND THE OFFICE FINANCE CAN.
KNOWING THAT WE HAVE A PHYSICIAN
SHORTAGE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND KNOWING THAT.
MANY OF THE PHYSICIANS THAT TAKE
RESIDENCIES OFTEN STATE WHERE
THE RESIDENCY IS.
WHAT IS OUR CAPACITY?
WHAT IS THE NUMBER NOT I'M
MISSING WAS OUR CAPACITY TO FIND
BUT HOW MANY RESIDENCIES CAM THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ACCOMMODATE?
IN THAT WE CAN CERTAINLY LOOK
AND SAY OKAY WHAT KIND OF MONEY
WE TALKING ABOUT BECAUSE WELL I
THINK THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS AS
A A VERY.
GOOD INVESTMENT --
I AM CONCERNED MADE WERE NOT
DOING ENOUGH TO TO TO FACILITATE
THIS -- THE
SHORTAGE OF PHYSICIANS THAT WE
HAVEN'T STATE CALIFORNIA I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
YOU HAVE AVAILABLE TO YOURSELVES
OR NOT BUT IF NOT I'D LIKE.
TO MAYBE GET THAT NUMBERS NUMBER
FROM YOU.
HI THEIR BEN JOHNSON THE LA OUT --
WE DO HAVE DATA ON THE EXISTING
RESIDENCY SLOTS THAT ARE --
THAT THAT ARE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE OVERALL
CAPACITY IS --
I IMAGINE WOULD BE A MORE
CHALLENGING QUESTION AS IT WOULD.
INVOLVE SURVEYING HOSPITALS FOR
THE RESIDENTS SEE SLOTS THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE BUT THEY MIGHT
HAVE YOU KNOW CAPACITY IN TERMS
OF PATIENT FLOWS TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE -- BUT
WE CAN CERTAINLY WORK WITH YOUR
STAFF TO SORT OF SEE WHAT KINDS
OF INFORMATION WE CAN PROVIDE
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL OKAY.
TONIGHT BUT JUST ADD REALLY
QUICK YES.
AND I ALSO HAVE SOME DATA SO
THERE'S ANOTHER SOURCE OF
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
FUNDING FROM POP FIFTY SIX LAST
YEAR THERE WAS FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS ABOUT THIRTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS AVAILABLE FOR
HOSPITALS.
AND BASED ON THE APPLICATIONS
RECEIVED AND THAT HAD TO BE FOR
OUR SLOTS THAT WERE GONNA BE NEW
SLOTS SO EXPANDED PROGRAMS --
THEY WERE OVERSUBSCRIBED THEY'VE
HAD A TOTAL REQUEST OF A HUNDRED
AND FORTY SEVEN POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION TO FOR THAT
PROGRAM.
SO.
WITH BOTH OF THESE PROGRAMS
TOGETHER WERE STILL ONLY FUNDING
ABOUT HALF THE REQUEST FOR NEW
PROGRAMS LOTS SO THERE'S QUITE A
LARGE CAPACITY THAT'S NOT BE.
WELL THANK YOU FOR THAT ANSWER
AND IT KIND OF THE LANES BE THAT.
THERE'S THERE'S A LOT MORE THAT
WE CAN DO --
I KNOW FOR TALKING ABOUT MONEY
WE'RE TALKING APART ORTIZ THAT'S
WHAT THE PURPOSE OF THE BUDGET
SUB THE THREE IS TO MAKE THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND SO I LOOK.
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH MY
COLLEAGUES TO SEE IF THERE'S A
WAY THAT WE CAN ENHANCE --
SLOTS FUNNY SLIDE THE THE
PHYSICIAN SHORTAGE IN THE STATE
AND APPRECIATE THE TROYER
PROCEED PRESENTATION THANK YOU
FOR THE FIGURES [inaudible]
QUESTION.
US SELF AFTER SPONSORS A FEW SHE
YOUR INTERESTS TO SOMEONE WHO IN
MY PRIOR LIFE BEFORE YOU ON THE
LEGISLATURE ACTUALLY --
DID QUITE A BIT OF RESEARCH WORK --
AND PHYSICIAN AND HEALTH
PROFESSIONS WORK FORCE --
CERTAINLY I THINK IT'S THAT'S
SOMETHING WE'LL CONTINUE
EXPLORED OBVIOUSLY NOT ONLY IN
THIS PART OF YOUR WITH US BUT WE
GET TO PROP FIFTY SIX WILL BE
TALKING A LOT MORE ABOUT SORT OF
FUNDING AND FINANCING --
FOR RESIDENCY TRAINING PROGRAMS
BUT I DID WANT TO JUST --
BORN JUST GET BACK O YOU SO YOU
SAID IN YOUR TESTIMONY THAT
THERE.
SO I SUFFERS OF I WANT TO SAY
THAT -- I
APPRECIATE --
WHAT I SPOT IS SAYING THAT YOU
KNOW S
N'T DO IT SPECIAL TO BY
SPECIALTY AND MINUTES FOR
PRIMARY CARE BUT WE DON'T DO
SPECIAL A SPECIALTY AND THERE'S
CERTAIN AND I THINK YOU RECENT
CONCERNS --
AND I I AND I I WOULD SURE SOME
OF THAT THAT WE START SLICING IT
BY SPECIALTY THAT CREATES THAT
MAY CREATE SOME INHERENT ISSUES --
SO BUT YOU ALSO SEND YOUR TEST
CRITERIA THAT YOU SAID THAT YOU
THINK IS DRIVING THIS FUNDING
AWAY FROM PEDIATRIC THAT YOU
THINK WOULD BE.
AN APPROPRIATE ARE HAVE AS WELL
THAT THAT MEANT THAT YOU WOULD
MIGHT CONSIDER TO BE OUT ON
FAIRS TIED UP RIGHT WORD BUT BUT
MAYBE LEADING TO VISITS. TO
OUTCOMES THAT.
ARE NOT SUPPORTIVE OF PEDIATRIC
TRAINING GATHERS TWO CRITERIA
THAT WERE ADDED ONLY ONE OF
WHICH IS COMING TO MY MIND RIGHT
NOW -- BUT
IT WAS THAT ONE WAS THE CRITERIA
FOR AT LEAST EIGHT HOURS IN A
CONTINUITY CARE CLINIC AND
PEDIATRIC PROGRAMS BECAUSE OF
ALL OF THE OTHER REQUIREMENTS
ARE PART OF THEM THEY NEVER
EXCEED MORE THAN.
FOUR SO AND IT WAS --
TEN POINTS THAT WAS ZERO OR TEN
WHETHER YOU MET THAT CRITERIA
AND NOT BECAUSE ALL THE
PEDIATRIC PROGRAMS TO JUST
AUTOMATICALLY SCORED TEN POINTS
LOWER.
THERE WAS ONE OTHER ONE THAT I'M
DRAWING A BLANK ON THAT ALSO
IMPACTED PEDIATRIC PROGRAMS AND
WHEN WE REACHED OUT.
TO OUR SPOT STAFF LAST YEAR THE
INDICATION THAT WE GOT WAS THAT
THIS WAS DONE INTENTIONALLY. TO
PULL MONEY AWAY FROM PEDIATRIC
PROGRAMS TOWARDS THE OTHER TYPES
AND THE RATIONALE WAS THAT 1100%
LIKE FAMILY MEDICINE PROGRAMS
RECEIVED MOST OF THE BENEFIT OF
THAT.
SHIFT BUT THOSE PROGRAMS LIKE
1100% OF THEM GOING TO PRIMARY
CARE WHERE IT'S IN ANY GIVEN
YEAR IT'S ABOUT 50% OF PEDIATRIC
PROGRAM OF PEDIATRICIANS WILL GO
INTO PRIMARY CARE SO THEY SAW
THAT IS A BETTER BANG FOR THEIR
BUCK.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT AS YOU KNOW
PEDIATRICIANS AND THAT WE FOR
NOT TRAINING THEM WE WILL SLOWLY
LOSE THE NUMBER THAT WE HAVE IN
THE COMMUNITY --
SO WE THINK THERE ARE OTHER WAYS
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOUR FUNDING A
PRIMARY CARE SLOT. FOR EXAMPLE
POSITIONS FOR HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
THAT'S DISTRIBUTING BUT PROP
FIFTY SIX MONEY LOOKS AT HOW
MANY PLACEMENTS YOU HAVE IN A
PRIMARY KATIE CARE SETTING FIVE
YEARS OUT AND THEY ALSO AWARD
EXTRA POINTS.
FOR IF YOU HAVE A PRIMARY CARE
TRACKING YOUR RESIDENCY PROGRAM
SO THERE'S WAYS TO CREATE POINT
SYSTEMS THAT REWARD HOSPITALS
THAT TRAIN PRIMARY CARE
PEDIATRICIANS WITHOUT DISRUPTING
THE MONEY TO ANOTHER TYPE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WELL AND HOPEFULLY
MAYBE THAT'S SOMETHING WE CAN
LOOK AT NOW I MAYBE I'LL MAKE A
PERSONAL COMMENTS ON WHO
ACTUALLY SERVED ON THE CREATION
COUNSEL FOR GRADUATE MEDICAL
EDUCATION THAT --
PERHAPS ACTUALLY PEDIATRICS
CONSIDER INCREASING OUTPATIENT
TRAINING --
ESPECIALLY SINCE YOU'RE CREATE
FELLOWSHIP IN HOSPITALS TRAINING
IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE A DETACHED
SINCE -- BUT
THAT'S A WHOLE NOTHER BUT THAT'S
SOMETHING THE PEDIATRIC ME AS A
FIGURE OUT --
BUT YOU KNOW I I THINK THAT --
THEM WE SERVE JIMMY DOLLARS --
TO ALSO BE SURE PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO PRACTICE IN THE AREAS OF NEED
THAT'S PRIMARY CARE.
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES SO FORTH
SO -- SO --
BILL WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
TAKING UP A THE STAKEHOLDER
PROPOSAL IN TERMS VOTING TODAY --
SO I I APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION I THINK YOU KNOW
SOMETHING WE SHOULD LOOK AT I I
DO SHARE THE CONCERNS OF OUR
SPOT ABOUT.
AND DAY I'M A PEDIATRICIAN AND
HEY WHY LET'S SEE MORE BEACH
YEAH WE I I UNDERSTAND THE NEED
FOR TEACHERS AND IN TERMS OF
DESIGNATING FOR PARTICULAR
SPECIALTIES AND WHAT THAT MEANS
AND WHETHER.
FUNDING --
MOTHER TO THE ISSUES THAT YOU
RAISED --
THAT AROUND --
PEDIATRICS RAINY WEATHER THIS IS
WHAT IT THIS IS THE RIGHT PLACE
TO ADDRESS IT IN TERMS OF WHY
SAID WHETHER THROUGH SONG BROWN
OR MAYBE SOME OTHER ME APPROACH --
SO --
HOPEFULLY WE CAN HAVE THAT DONE
AND SO BETWEEN NOW AND MAY
REVISE HEALTH LEADERS TO BE SOME
CONVERSATIONS AND THINKING ABOUT
WHICH DIRECTION WE'RE GOING WITH
THEIR VARIOUS WORKFORCE
INCLUDING SONG BROWN.
AND AND AND THE FUNDING --
THERE AND CERTAINLY APPRECIATE --
THE GOVERNOR'S --
PROPOSAL TO A CONTINGENCY FUND
AS THE SOMETHING LEGISLATURE'S
BEEN FIGHTING FOR AND SAID DOING
IT TO CONFUSE THE FUNDS ON BROWN
BECAUSE WHEN YOU RUN A RESIDENCY
PROGRAM ANY TYPE.
YOU NEED YEAH YOU DON'T WANT TO
BRING ON A RESIDENT AND THEN
HAVE THE MONEY RIGHT NOW AND AND
AND TELL RESIDENT THAT WE CAN'T
YOU CAN COMPLETE YOUR TRAINING
BECAUSE WITHOUT THE MONEY TO DO
THAT SO THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
I WANT RECOGNIZE THE
ADMINISTRATION. FOR FOR BEING
SURE THAT THEY ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE CELL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OKAY -- THE
NEXT STAKEHOLDER PROPOSAL IS
ACTUALLY BEGIN.
THAT THAT IS ACTUALLY A CRISTINA
HICKS FROM CALIFORNIA HEALTH
ADVOCATES --
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA HEX DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT AND
EVALUATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
PRIMARY CARE ASSOCIATION OR SEE
PCA.
IF YOU SEE A IN THEIR ADVOCACY
AFFILIATE CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS
ADVOCATES REPRESENT CALIFORNIA'S
OVER THIRTEEN HUNDRED NOT FOR
PROFIT COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
WHICH EMPLOY OVER FORTY THOUSAND
STAFF STATEWIDE.
AND PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE
QUALITY HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO
NEARLY SEVEN MILLION PEOPLE EACH
YEAR.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT OUR STAKEHOLDER BUDGET
REQUEST TO YOU TODAY WHICH AIMS
TO BOLSTER PROVIDER RECRUITMENT
EFFORTS AND SAGE AND HEALTH CARE
SETTINGS.
I WOULD LIKE TO START WITH A FEW
RECENT STATISTICS WE HAVE A
TREMENDOUS NEED.
THE HEALTH RESOURCES AND
SERVICES ADMINISTRATION RECENTLY
REPORTED THAT MORE THAN SEVEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION CALIFORNIANS
LEVIN HEALTH PROFESSIONAL
SHORTAGE AREAS ARE HAVE SAYS.
WHICH IS A FEDERAL DESIGNATION
FOR COUNTIES X. CARE DENTAL CARE
OR MENTAL HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS.
WE ARE HAVING DIFFICULTY MEETING
THAT NEED.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT STUDY
CONDUCTED BY THE HEALTH FOR
CENTER T UCSF CALIFORNIA IS
PROJECTED TO HAVE A SHORTFALL OF
MORE THAN FORTY ONE HUNDRED
PRIMARY CLEAR COMMISSION.
PRIMARY CARE CLINICIANS BY
TWENTY THIRTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROFESSION SHORTAGES ARE ALSO
CONCERNING WITH AN EXISTING 11%
SHORTAGE OF PSYCHOLOGISTS
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPISTS
CLINICAL COUNSELORS AND SOCIAL
WORKERS.
THIS IS WHAT BRINGS ME HERE
TODAY ASKING FOR YOUR HELP.
DESPITE MOUNTING PRESSURE AND
DEMAND TO EXPAND THE STATION AT
HEALTH CARE WORK FORCE IN NEARLY
ALL PARTS OF THE STATE.
MANY SAFETY NET PROVIDERS LIKE
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS ARE
UNABLE TO RECRUIT THE NECESSARY
WORKFORCE TO MEET THE NEED.
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS
REPORTED THAT THE INABILITY TO
OFFER COMPETITIVE SALARIES AND
BENEFIT PACKAGES ARE AMONG THE
PRIMARY REASONS FOR THE
SEEMINGLY INSURMOUNTABLE
CHALLENGE OF RECORDING THE
NECESSARY WORKFORCE.
KNACK FOR THE REPORTS THAT
NEARLY 95% OF ALL HEALTH CENTERS
NATIONWIDE ARE EXPERIENCING AT
LEAST ONE CLINICAL VACANCY AND
AT TIMES AVERAGE NEARLY ONE YEAR
TO FILL A PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER
POSITION. TO MEET THIS NEED
ADVOCATES RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT YOU CONSIDER A ONE TIME
FUNDING ALLOCATION OF FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR GRANTS. TO
BE ADMINISTERED BY US BAD TO
EXPAND THE PRIMARY CARE AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES.
THESE DOLLAR SHOULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO ELIGIBLE SAGE AND
ORGANIZATIONS FOR PROVIDER
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS SUCH AS
RECRUITMENT OR SIGNING
INCENTIVES OR HOUSING AND
RELOCATION COSTS.
WE ALSO RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
THERE EXIST FLEXIBILITY WITHIN
THE ALLOCATION OF THESE DOLLARS
THAT ALLOWS FOR REGIONALIZED
APPROACH AS WELL HOUSING
SUBSIDIES MAY BE VITAL TO
RECRUITING PROVIDERS TO URBAN
AREAS OF THE STATE FOR EXAMPLE.
IT MAY BE THAT RELOCATION
ASSISTANCE IS THE ONLY WAY TO
ENTICE A NEWLY CERTIFIED AND
HEAVILY INDEBTED PROVIDER TO
TAKE A POSITION IN A ROLE OR
MORE PART OF THE STATE.
UNDER THIS PROPOSAL WE ENCOURAGE
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA
CONSIDERATIONS SIMILAR TO THOSE
IN EXISTING WORKFORCE SUPPORT
PROGRAMS.
PARTICULARLY WE SUGGEST GRANTS
BE MADE CLINICS IN PUBLIC
HOSPITALS TO A PATIENT
POPULATIONS EQUAL TO OR GREATER
THAN 50% MEDI CAL.
ARE UNINSURED HAVE INCOMES UNDER
2100% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL OR A COMBINATION THERE
I'VE.
WE ALSO PROPOSE THAT ELIGIBLE
PROVIDER TYPES INCLUDE BOARD
CERTIFIED PRIMARY CARE POVIDERS
SUCH AS ANDY'S INDIOS NURSE
PRACTITIONERS CERTIFIED MIDWIVES
AND A PHYSICIAN ASSISTANCE.
AS WELL AS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS SUCH AS PSYCHIATRISTS
PSYCHOLOGISTS MARRIAGE AND
FAMILY THERAPIST AND LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKERS. FOR
THESE REASONS WE URGE THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE TO
APPROPRIATE THIS ONE TIME FIFTY
MILLION ALLOCATION AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING CLOSELY WITH
LEGISLATOR ON THIS REQUEST WE
THANK YOU IN ADVANCE FOR
CONSIDERING THE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU --
ANY COMMENTS FROM A SPOT ON THIS
OKAY LA --
FINANCE.
ALL RIGHT QUESTIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SO THANKS MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION --
SO THE IT IS WRITTEN AT SOME
ESTIMATES OF THE CITY MILLION
IT'S GOING TO WRITE A DIFFERENT
ACTIVITIES HAD RECRUITED SIGNING
HOUSING RELOCATION AS MENTIONED
SELLER BENEFITS OF THESE I MEAN
HOW MANY PEOPLE DO YOU THINK.
WERE.
EXPECTING THE HOPEFULLY RECRUIT
WITH THAT THE FIFTY MILLION AND
IT'S A ONE TIME SO THAT MAKES IT
A LITTLE TRICKY.
TO YEAH IT DOES YES --
I THINK WE WOULD WANT TO LEAVE
IT TO THE EXPERTISE OF OUR SPOT
IN TERMS OF THE GRANT A
PARTICULAR SIZE WHICH OF COURSE
WOULD IMPACT THE NUMBERS THAT WE
COULD --
BRING INTO THE SAFETY NET --
AND RECOGNIZE THAT THIS WOULD BE
A ONE TIME --
SUBSIDY --
IT COULD BE FOR OTHER KINDS OF
INCENTIVES THAT AGAIN JUST HELP
BRING THAT THE PROVIDERS INTO
THE SAFETY NET --
RECOGNIZING THAT THE LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS DON'T HAVE ANY
ESTIMATE AS TO SELL FOR FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF PUBLIC MONEY
HOW MANY.
PEOPLE WERE HOPING TO GET FOR
THIS EVENT AS ANY ANALYSIS OF
ANY SORT IN TERMS OF I MEAN SO
[inaudible]
YEAH.
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN CONSUMERS ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS
ADVOCATES --
I THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT POINT
THAT YOU RAISE I WOULD JUST
MENTION THAT WE'RE REALLY JUST
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT I THINK I'M
FIRST WHAT THE NEED IS.
AND SO JUST WE DID OF LIKE A
BACK OF THE ENVELOPE NUMBERS
ASSUMPTION AND IF EVERY HEALTH
CENTRE APPLIED FOR A GRANT AND
GOT OF ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR GRANT NOT SAYING THAT
SHOULD BE THE NUMBER --
THAT WOULD BE ABOUT. FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY H. PROVIDERS
STATEWIDE.
SO I I AGAIN I THINK IT DEPEND
THAT AND THOSE ARE JUST HEALTH
CENTERS AND THIS WOULD BE UP
THIS TO BE APPLICABLE TO PUBLIC
HOSPITALS AND OTHER FACILITIES
TO SO THAT'S JUST THE KIND OF
AROUND NUMBER.
TO GIVE YOU --
TICKETS FOR YOUR ESTIMATES RIGHT
NOW BUT WE ARE INTERESTED IN AND
THROUGH TRYING TO SURVEY WHAT
THE NEED IS AND SEEING IF THE
STOLLER AMOUNT WOULD HAVE THE
IMPACT THAT WE HOPE IT WOULD.
OKAY NO I MADE A PRE SHEET THAT
CERTAINLY --
EIGHTY ENDING MADE AN EXCELLENT
CASE ABOUT THE NEED AND BUT I
THINK ALSO AS A BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE GALLON SOMEONE SAYS
I WANT EX NUMBER OF DOLLARS IS
ALSO EXPECTED TO HAPPEN WITH
THAT RIGHT WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT
KIND OF DIFFERENCE DO SO AND I
REALIZED THERE'S THERE'S GOING.
TO ALL THE BILL THE BACK OF AN
AFGHAN ARE BACK THE ENVELOPE THE
TIMES --
BECAUSE UNTIL YOU ACTUALLY DO
THE ONE TIME BUT SOME OF THE
HOUSE.
RECRUITMENT SIGNEE INCENTIVE.
FOR HOW THE OTHER RELOCATION
PERCENT BUT LIKE A I MEAN.
I GUESS THE THING IS IS A SO YOU
LOOK LIKE BASICALLY ONE TIME
INCENTIVES FOR PEOPLE --
TO COME ON BOARD THE THAT AND
FROM YOUR EXPERIENCE RECRUITING
PEOPLE.
THIS DAY IS THAT GOING TO BE
SUFFICIENT OR PEOPLE THAT SAY
WELL YOU KNOW THEN TERMS OF DON
GOING SALARY OR WHATEVER
BENEFITS THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
GET ARE YOU ABLE TO IF YOU SEE
ME THAT.
OKAY WE GIVE YOU SOME HELP TO
GET.
SOME PLACE TO LIVE ONE TIME
THAT'S GOING TO BE SUFFICIENT
FOR THE RETENTION I I'M ALSO
THINKING BUT NOT A RECRUITMENT
BUT SUSTAINABILITY IN TERMS OF
RETENTION.
WELL WE RECOGNIZE ACTUALLY THAT
ARE THERE ARE QUITE A FEW
RETENTION STRATEGIES LOWER
PAYMENT BEING AMONG THEM AND I
THINK THIS IS WOULD BE A
COMPATIBLE STRATEGY WITH A
LONGER PAYMENT --
PROGRAM BUT LOAN PAYMENT IS AND
IT IS IS INCOMING UPON HAVING A
PROVIDER AT YOUR FACILITY THAT
YOU CAN PROVIDE THAT BENEFIT.
TO WE'RE STARTING TO SEE
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS ACROSS THE
STATE OF FOR THAT THEY'RE VERY
REGIONALIZED THERE'S A FEW
HEALTH PLANS I THINK THREE THAT
WE CAN NO I HAVE.
THAT ARE STARTING TO DO THIS
THAT ARE SEEING SUCCESSES BUT IT
IS RELATIVELY NEW AND THOSE ARE
PROGRAMS AND WE'D LIKE TO SEE
THE KIND OF THAT STATISTICS IN
THE OUTCOMES OF THAT.
BUT WE SEE THAT IT IS MAKING A
DIFFERENCE RENTS OF APPROACH.
I THINK WHAT WOULD BE HELPFUL IN.
THIS YOU KNOW SAID MORE --
HAS BEEN BETWEEN NOW AND MAY.
IS ALSO SIR FLUSHING OUT MORE OF
THE BACK OF THE NAPKIN BACK OF
THE ENVELOPE CALCULATION BUT
ALSO THINKING ABOUT HOW WITH
THIS.
EFFORT IN ON THIS MONEY --
THEN LEVERAGE OTHER FUNDS OR
OTHER EFFORTS IT PARTICULARLY
YOU KNOW I THINK I SEE THIS AT
LEAST --
SINCE YOU SAID ONE TIME I'
THINKING THIS IS MORE SO IT WAS
LIKE THIS IS THE RECRUITMENT
BONUS ARE THE INCENTIVE TO GET
PEOPLE END BUT WHAT YOU HAVE
AVAILABLE THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE A
SAY WE CAN LEVERAGE FOR
ATTENTION SO THAT WANT TO BRING
SOMEONE IN.
THE GUIDE STAY RATE THAT WE HAVE
OTHER TYPES OF FUNDS THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO TAP INTO OR OTHER TYPES
OF RESOURCES ARE STRATEGIES WE
HAVE. TO KEEP THEM.
THEY'RE RIGHT BECAUSE THE TURN
ISN'T GOOD EITHER SO --
SO IT DOES DEPRECIATE THE
REQUEST FOR THE RECRUITMENT
STUFF THAT ALSO HOUSES FIT INTO
THE LARGER PICTURE SO THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY BUILD THAT HEALTH
OF THAT --
WORKFORCE THAT YOU'RE LOOKING --
FOR IN BEHAVIOR HEALTH AND
CLINICS.
RIGHT.
OKAY ALL.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED.
OKAY AND FINALLY WE HAVE --
THE ANDHRA CLARK HARVEY FROM THE
CARRIER FOR A COUNCIL FOR
COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR HEALTH
AGENCIES SO MY IN THE HIGHER
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
MET MARRIAGE AND FAMILY
THERAPISTS AND JANE.
AT **** BIG BROWN'S CORRECTLY
FROM CALIFORNIA HERE HEALTH
PLANNING COUNCIL.
PROPOSING --
ESTABLISHING A WHAT TRUST FUND.
A SO -- I
THINK THE RULE IS YOU GOT. THREE
MINUTES TOGETHER SO YOU GUYS
HAVE FIGURED OUT HOW TO DIVVY UP
THAT TIME BETWEEN THE THREE OF
YOU AND OF COURSE WE ASK
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE MORE TIME TO
TALK.
OKAY THANK YOU BROKE UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON ENERGY BEFORE
BRAVE FOR THE RECORD SINCE
THERE'S THREE OF YOU CAN YOU
EACH OF YOU INTRODUCED US OUT
AGAINST YOUR TIME AND THEN WILL
BE AND HOW GOOD AN EXTRA TEN
SECONDS.
GOOD AFTERNOON HERE BUT I THINK
WE'RE STILL IN THE MORNING
CORRECT IT IS STILL THE MORNING.
GOOD AFTER A GOOD MORNING CHAIR
PAN AND THAT STEAM SENATORS I'M
DOCTOR LEE UNDER CLARK HARVEY
THE DIRECTOR OF POLICY AND
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS AT THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL COMMUNITY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES.
WE REPRESENT BEHAVIOR HOLLOW
ACTIONS ARE COUNTY IS THAT EACH
OF THE PEOPLE THAT --
EVERYBODY INTRODUCE AND THEN YOU
CAN BEGIN YOUR TESTIFYING. TO MY
AND HEART HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPIST Q..
NINE JANE ADCOCK EXECUTIVE
OFFICER THE CALIFORNIA
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PLANNING
COUNCIL OKAY NAY OF TEN EXTRA
SECONDS BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO DO
INTRODUCTIONS ADDING SERVICES TO
MANY OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
ODD TOGETHER WITH OUR CO
SPONSORS HAVE INTRODUCED
THEMSELVES --
WE REQUEST A SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS. TO SUPPORT THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE WORK FORCE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING TRUST
FUND WHICH WOULD FIND MANY OF
THE ACTIVITIES AND COST BEDS
FIVE YOUR WORK FORCE PLAN WHICH
YOU'VE HEARD A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
ALREADY.
SO WE'RE ALL AWARE OF THE
BEHAVIOR HEALTH WORKFORCE CRISIS
ON THAT IMPACTING OUR STATE AND
WE KNOW THAT AUSPICE PLAN REALLY
LAYS THE FRAMEWORK TO SOLVING
THIS CRISIS BUT THERE'S NO ON
GOING DEDICATED FUNDING FOR THE
PLAN.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT OUR FUNDING
REQUEST WOULD ALLOW FOR
STRENGTHENING THE PIPELINE
PROVIDING INCENTIVES TO
PROFESSIONALS AND ENSURING
CONTINUITY OF CARE FOR YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE MEMBERS
PROVIDE NEEDED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO YOU.
I CAN PERSONALLY ATTEST TO THE
IMPACT OF THE PROGRAMS AND ALSO
PUT THE PLAN AS I WAS THE
RECIPIENT OF BOTH STATEMENT AND
LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAMS ONCE I
COMPLETED MY DOCTORATE IN
PSYCHOLOGY ABOUT TEN YEARS AGO.
SO MY COLLEAGUES WHEN US NEXT
DISCUSS --
THE OVERSIGHT OF THE FIVE YEAR
PLAN AND CAMPUS WILL FURTHER
DISCUSS THE WORK FORCE CRISIS
FOR LICENSED PROFESSIONALS.
WE'D LIKE TO SPECIFICALLY THANK
SENATOR ANA CABALLERO FOR
CHAMPION AND CHAMPIONING THIS
CALL SHE CIRCULATING A LETTER
SUPPORT --
FOR THIS PROPOSAL TORE SENATE
COLLEAGUES AND WE THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING A REQUEST.
AS MENTIONED I'M WITH THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PLANNING
COUNCIL THE COUNCIL IS MANDATED
IN STATE LAW TO SERVE AS AN
ADVISORY ROLE TO THE LEGISLATURE.
ON THE ISSUES POLICIES AND
PRIORITIES FOR CALIFORNIA'S
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM.
WE ALSO HAVE THE RULE OF
OVERSIGHT IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
EACH OF THE WORK FORCE FIVE YEAR
PLANS.
IN THERE ARE INVITED THREE
ROLLED THE COUNCIL STRONGLY
URGES YOUR COMMITTEE SUPPORT
ULTIMATELY OF THIS ONE TIME
REQUEST OF SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS. TO INSURE THAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEXT FIVE
YEAR PLAN.
THIS REQUEST IS JUST PART OF A
BROADER STRATEGY TO SECURE
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING FOR THE
PLANS AS THEY ARE AN ONGOING
REQUIREMENT.
THE COUNCIL HAS BEEN DOCUMENTING
THE WORK FOR SHORTED SINCE THE
LATE NINETIES BUT YOU DON'T HAVE
TO TAKE OUR WORD FOR IT.
THE CALIFORNIA FUTURE HEALTH
WORKFORCE COMMISSION RELEASED
ITS RECOMMENDATIONS THREE OF ITS
TOP TEN RECOMMENDATIONS ADDRESS
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE.
ALSO THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION ALONG WITH KAISER
FAMILY FOUNDATION RELEASED THE
RESULTS OF THE RECENT POLL 52%
OF CALIFORNIANS STATE THAT THEY
DO NOT FEEL THAT THERE ARE
ENOUGH MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES TO MEET THE
NEEDS.
WE WERE TOLD THAT TWENTY THREE
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA HAVE NO
PSYCHIATRIST.
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS IS A
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE AND WE ALL
KNOW THAT THERE IS NO HEALTH
WITHOUT PUBLIC WITHOUT MENTAL
HEALTH.
SO THIS IS AN URGENT NEED AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION OF THIS REQUEST.
I THINK SHE JUST LEFT EIGHT
SECONDS.
HI I'M A CAMPUS PROP TO CO
SPONSOR THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE SEVENTY MILLION TO
SUPPORT THE WORK FORCE EDUCATION
AND TRAINING TRUST FUND OVER THE
NEXT TWO YEARS.
I'M AND THIS FUNDING IS
NECESSARY BECAUSE IT WILL HELP
TO ENSURE THAT MORE QUALIFIED
AND CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE
PROVIDERS ARE AVAILABLE FOR
PATIENTS I'M AND WILL HELP TO
EXPAND THE PUBLIC MENTAL HELTH
SYSTEM.
THIS FUNDING WILL HELP TO
ADDRESS A SHORTAGE OF BILINGUAL
AND DIVE FIRST TIME
PROFESSIONALS BY PROVIDING
INCENTIVE FOR STUDENTS --
WITH DIFFERENT CULTURAL
BACKGROUND TO PURSUE A CAREER IN
THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROFESSION.
SO WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
YOU'RE CONSIDERING.
ANY COMMENTS OR OBSERVATIONS
FROM MUCH FUND OKAY LA --
FINANCE NOW OKAY QUESTIONS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS A CENTER.
SEVEN I APPRECIATE THE THE
REQUEST --
WHAT WHY AREAS --
REQUESTING THIS TO COME FROM THE
GENERAL FUND RATHER THAN MENTAL
HEALTH AND SO WE HAVE AND STATE.
PROP [inaudible]
SIXTY THREE I'M.
ARE YOU STALKING ADMIN DOLLARS
OR THE IMAGE TO SEE
LOCALIZATIONS REVENUES OR THE 5%
ADMIN DOLLARS THE STATE BY.
AGAIN STATEWIDE.
FUNDS THE LOCAL ISSUES TENTH --
SO AS I MENTIONED THAT THIS
REQUEST AS PART OF A BROADER
STRATEGY FOR SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
WITH THE SUSTAINABLE FINDING THE
PROPOSAL IN SENATOR COUPLE YEAR
WAS BILL IS.
TO UTILIZED 25% OF GROSS FUNDS
INTO THE IMAGE TO SAY FUND TO GO
IN THE INTO THE TRUST FUND FOR
WORKFORCE THAT WE'RE ASKING TO
BE ESTABLISHED HERE.
COUNTIES WOULD ALSO BE ABLE TO
TRANSPONDERS TRANSFER UNUSED
MHSAA DOLLARS INTO THE FUND. FOR
USE FOR WORK FORCE SO ON THE ON
GOING WE ARE EXPECTING TO
UTILIZE AND AND MAY TO SAY FUNDS
AS A SUSTAINABLE SOURCE OKAY
THANK YOU.
IF I MAY SENATOR SO I I THINK
WHAT WITHOUT CON IS ALSO A
TWENTY TWO IS THAT WE HAVE A UP
A STRATEGY THAT'S COUPLE
TOGETHER WITH A LEGISLATIVE A
VEHICLE GET THE EFFORT.
YOU KNOW JUMP STARTED FOR THE
FIRST TWO YEARS AND WE HVE A
BILL THAT ADDRESSES THE ONGOING
FUNDING --
ISSUE AND LOOKS AT ME TO SAY
FUNDS WHICH I THINK YOU ARE
RIGHTLY POINTING.
TO GREAT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT --
SO ACTUALLY --
AND OVER THERE PERHAPS LA OF
FINANCE AND SO YOU KNOW WE HAD.
FUNDING FOR WET THROUGH --
PROP SIXTY THREE AND THEY DON'T
PLAN FOR GETTING LAST YEAR THE
PROBLEM WAS THE MONEY WAS READY
OUT BEFORE THE PLAN.
AND AND SO --
MAYBE CAN THEY BE FINANCE
COLLABORATORS TO LAST YEAR LIKE
WHAT FINALLY HAPPENED THAT MEANS
IS -- WITH
THAT.
JAIL AND UPON A FINANCE ALASTOR
THERE IS A TEN MILLION MHSAA
AUGMENTATION.
TO PROVIDE BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
FINISH OUT THE FINAL YEAR OF THE
SECOND FIVE YEAR PLAN --
CORNER STATUTE THERE IS NO
DEDICATED FUNDING SOURCE FOR THE
THIRD AN ONGOING ITERATIONS OF
THE PLAN --
I THINK THE ONLY THING I CAN ADD
IS THE OBJECTIVES OUTLINED BY
THE STICKLE APPROVALS ARE
BROADLY SIMILAR TO WHAT WE'LL BE
DISCUSSING AN ISSUE FOR SO.
WE CAN.
SPEAK MORE OR PROPOSAL WHAT THAT
TIME OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO I REALIZE WE
HAVEN'T PRESENTED THAT THESE
FOREIGN THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING --
AS A FIFTY MILLION --
SO HOW HOW DO YOU SEE YOUR
PROPOSAL.
YEAH FITTING IN WITH THE ARE
LINING UP WITH ARE SO AND ARE
ACT IN RELATION TO THE TO THAT
FIFTY MILLION PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION OF FOR BEHAVIORAL.
HEALTH I REALIZE WE HAVEN'T
HEARD IT YET HERE BUT HOPEFULLY
YOU.
YES I DON'T WANT TO SPEAK FOR A
SPIN --
HOWEVER IS FIFTY MILLION IS NOT.
ALLOCATED OR EXPECTED TO BE
pIN THE FIVE YEAR PLANS --
THE LOAN ASSUMPTION PROGRAM
MAYES SHARES SOME OVERLP BUT
THERE OR SIGNIFICANT OTHER
ACTIVITIES IN THE FIVE YEAR PLAN
TO ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE.
IT OR NOT FUNDED.
ALL RIGHT AND ACTUALLY MAYBE
QUESTION FOR FINANCE ELEMENTS OF
THIS THAT IT'S A YOU TO DEVELOP
ANOTHER FIVE YEAR PLAN RIGHT
WITH US BY RAISE THE COUNCIL
APPROVED IN JANUARY RIGHT OKAY
AND WAS THAT PART OF WAS BUT IT
WAS THAT PLAN.
PART OF THE DISCUSSION WITHIN
THE ADMINISTRATION AND
DEVELOPING THE DEMONSTRATIONS
PROPOSAL --
THE FIFTY MILLION FOR WORK --
MENTAL HEALTH CARE WORKING
ELEMENT IS NOT PART OF OF WHAT
FUNDING IT'S CHAIR AT SEPARATE.
ON AND ON SINCE THE PLAN WAS NOT
FINALIZED UNTIL JANUARY IT WAS
NO PREMATURE TO INCLUDE FUNDING
FOR IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
OKAY SO SO BASICALLY THE PLAN
HAD COME OUT YET AT TIME YOU'RE
DEVELOPING VEGETABLES THAT.
BETWEEN NOW AND MAY IS THIRD
DEED AS THERE'S GONNA BE SOME
DISCUSSION ABOUT WE HAVE THIS
PLAN THAT WAS DEVELOPED AND HOW
THAT MIGHT FIT IN INTO --
INTO WHATEVER OUR ULTIMATE --
BUDGET WILL BE AROUND --
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE.
DO YOU SEE THAT HAPPENING.
BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND STAKEHOLDERS REGARDING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND THE
THIRD FIVE YEAR PLAN.
OKAY ALL RIGHT.
OKAY ACTUALLY COMES FROM LA
ABOUT THAT NOW ALL RIGHT OKAY.
ALRIGHT WELL WE'RE IS IT WILL BE
HOLDING EVERYTHING OPEN SO --
BUT A FEW SHEET THAT
PRESENTATION AND YOU KNOW THE
THE THE WORK THAT WAS DONE ON
THE PLAN AND I THINK WE DO I
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITMENT TOWARD BEHAVIOR
HEALTH WORK FOR SO HOPEFULLY IS
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD WE CAN.
PUT ALL THE PIECES TOGETHER AND
THINK ABOUT THAT AND CERTAINLY I
KNOW THAT THE COALITION WORKED
VERY HARD AND DEVELOPING THE
ELEMENTS YOU THINK ARE NECESSARY
FOR THE FOR THE FOR THE WHAT
PLANNED SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN
FIGURE OUT WHAT WE HAVE
SUFFICIENT SUPPORT AND THAT WILL.
INCREASE OUR WORKFORCE.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL RIGHT SO NOW WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENTS ON THE REVIEW ANDALSO
THE STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS AND
AGAIN I ASK THAT --
WILL TRY TO KEEP YOUR PUBLIC
COMMENT TO WITHIN A MINUTE --
WELCOME INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND
WHICH ORGANIZATION FROM IF
YOU'RE FROM AN ORGANIZATION --
AND OF THE FEW TESTIMONY OKAY
THANK YOU.
YOU KELLY BY.
PHONE KELLY BE MY BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL PERMANENTLY EXTEND THE
CURRENT THIRTY THREE POINT THREE
MILLION ANNUAL GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE FOR SONG BROWN AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
COMMITTEE IN ADMINISTRATION.
ON HOW TO BEST ADDRESS PROVIDER
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES.
THE NEED IS GREAT AS THE FIRST
YEAR OF AWARDS WAS RECENTLY
ANNOUNCED FOR THE FORTY MILLION
UNDER PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX
ADMINISTERED THROUGH THE UC WE
MENTIONED EARLIER. FOR THE FORTY
MILLION IN FUNDING THE PROGRAM
RECEIVED OVER A HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION REQUESTS FOR MUCH NEEDED
GRADUATE MEDICAL EDUCATION
RESIDENCY SLOTS.
CENTER STONE YOUR QUESTION ABOUT --
HOW MANY SLOTS THAT THAT FUNDS
AND WE FUNDED A HUNDRED FIFTY
SIX LOTS OF THE TWENTY NINE
HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX SLOTS THAT
ARE EXISTING IN PRIMARY CARE AND
EMERGENCY MEDICINE?
WE LOOK FOR TO MORE DETAILS ON
THE VARIOUS TACKLE PROPOSALS AND
TO ADDRESS WORKFORCE SHORTAGES
PRESENTED TODAY THANK YOU.
HELLO MICHELLE COMMITTED I WITH
A CA YOU CALIFORNIA AND ON
BEHALF OF OUR HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE WHOSE SPANS THE
CONTINUUM EVERYONE FROM --
SURGICAL TECHNICIANS NURSE ALL
THE WAY THROUGH --
TO PHYSICIAN INTERNS AND
RESIDENTS WE OF COURSE BELIEVE
IN INVESTING IN OUR STATE'S
WORKFORCE MAY JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT LAST BIT IS STATUTORILY
MANDATED TO REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE EVERY YEAR.
ON WHAT ARE --
WORK FOR SHOULD BAG TRENDS ARE
GAPS AND EVEN TO PROVIDE POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS AND I THINK THE
STATE COULD DO MORE TO A USE THE
THAT THE CAPACITY WE HAVE AN
ARCH PET AROUND THOSE SORTS OF
ANALYSES. TO REALLY INFORM AND
DRIVE OUR POLICY MAKING AND SO --
WE OF COURSE ONE OF PARTNER IN
IN THAT MOVING FORWARD --
I WANT TO COMPLIMENT ARCH FITS
WORK RECENTLY ON THE SB.
SEVENTEEN REPORTS THAT HAVE TO
DO WITH PRESCRIPTION DRUG.
COSTS AND THANK THEM FOR IT FOR
THAT AND ALSO THINK THEM FOR THE
OUTRAGE THAT THEY'VE DONE ON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE ALL PAYER
CLAIMS DATABASE --
TO MOVE US TOWARD A MORE ROBUST
COST COST AND QUALITY DATA --
VEHICLE AND AT WHICH WILL HELP
US AND FORMER TO ENSURE THAT
RECENT UPDATES TO THEIR DTA
PLATFORMS AND POLICY
INTERPRETATIONS.
BALANCE THE INTERESTS OF THEIR
VERY STAKEHOLDERS AND ALSO
ENSURE THAT THEIR DATA CONTINUES
TO BE TIMELY AS WELL AS RELIABLE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRTH
MEGAN SUPER SOME AFTER
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATES
A COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS I
JUST WANTED TO THANK.
THE GOVERNOR AND THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE ON GOING
FUNDING FOR SONG BROWN AS A THAT
IS A VERY IMPORTANT REVENUE
SOURCE FOR THE TEACHING HEALTH
CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA OF WHICH
THERE ARE.
SIX AND WE'RE SEEING AT THE
TREMENDOUS NEED AND ALSO --
THE THE PROGRAM'S REALLY GETTING
OFF THE GROUND TO BE ABLE TO
FILL THE NEED OF RESIDENCIES US
LOTS IN CALIFORNIA AND ALSO.
FORCE A SUPPORT OUR FOR SUPPORT
FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH WORK FORCE --
PROPOSAL AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
FOR SEE NO ONE ELSE AT THE
MICROPHONE I JUST WANT --
TO ACTUALLY OF FIRST BY --
ONE OFFICIATE --
BECAUSE THE ARTISTIC OR
PROPOSALS BUT WHAT --
SCA YOU SAID TONIGHT ONE ECHO
THAT IS WELL THE WORK ON BOTH
THE THE DATABASE ON TRANSPARENCY
FOR PRESCRIPTION DRUGS I KNOW
THAT COMING OUT SOMETIME IN
MARCH RIGHT ARE.
RACHAEL ACTUALLY START TO
PUTTING OUT NEW DRUG REPORTS
WHICH OKAY ON AND THEN --
QUARTERLY REPORTS STARTING SO
OKAY AND THEN OF COURSE --
THE THE ALL PAYERS CLAIM
DATABASE AND ACTUALLY HAD A
HEARING HEALTH COMMITTEE TALK
ABOUT HOW DO WE PUT THE DATA
TOGETHER BUT I THINK THAT'S
GONNA BE REALLY IMPORTANT AS WE
TRY TO LOOK AT HOW WE BETTER.
A LINE --
THINGS AND GETS A AND I HAVE THE
KIND OF DATA WE NEED TO MONITOR
LIKE.
A WHAT IMPACT WE REALLY HAVING
ON ON ON ON PATIENTS AND DIRECTS
THE CARE AND QUALITY CARE
THEY'RE GETTING SO IF AT THE END.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT WORK
THAT SAID RECENTLY IMPORTANT
WORK FOR FOR ALL OF US.
WERE TO CONTINUE DIALOGUE WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE AS
WELL AS WITH LEGISLATURES AS
MOVES FORWARD SO CELL LET ME
KNOW IF YOU NEED MORE MONEY FOR
THAT.
THE POOR OKAY.
FOR FINANCES LOOKING ALL RIGHT
OKAY.
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO LET'S MOVE ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO SO THAT'S
INCREASED EXPENDITURE THIRTY FOR
MENTAL HEALTH PRACTITIONER
EDUCATION FUNDS WE'RE GONNA DO
IS GO TAKE THE NEXT THREE ISSUES
AND THEN WE'LL TAKE UP PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THEM ALL TOGETHER.
SO.
KEEP ON MISTER SHARON CENTER
STONE --
THIS PROPOSAL I REQUEST IN
EDUCATION FIND --
DUE -- TO AB
ON ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT FOR A
TOTAL EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF
EIGHT HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND ON
THE CURRENT EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY --
IN THIS FIND IS THREE HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE THOUSAND AND THIS
DOES NOT REFLECT THAT NEW
REVENUE --
AB I LIVE IN --
EIGHTY EIGHT INCREASE THAT BY IN
A LICENSE RENEWAL FEE FOR
LICENSE MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
FROM TEN DOLLARS.
TO TWENTY ON THIS INCREASED
REVENUE WOULD BE USED FOR OUR
LICENSE MENTAL SERVICES PROVIDER
EDUCATION PROGRAM TOWARD UP TO
FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN LOAN
OR PAYMENT IN EXCHANGE FOR TWO
YEARS OF SERVICE --
THIS INCREASE REVENUE WILL FIND
AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY EIGHT
AWARDS FOR A TOTAL OF FIFTY TWO
LONGER PAYMENT WORDS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LU COMMENTS FINANCE.
MANY MEMBERS ALL RIGHT.
OKAY WELL --
SHE DEBTS AND AGAIN --
AND I THINK WE'LL BE TOUCHING
TALK A LITTLE MORE ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH --
ALSO LATER FLOW ALRIGHT TO LET'S
MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER.
THREE STEPS DISCLOSURE
INTERESTED IN BUSINESS PROVIDING
SERVICES A. B. NINETEEN FIFTY
THREE NINETY THREE SO AB NINETY
THREE REQUIRES --
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
LICENSED BY THE STATE. TO
DISCLOSE SPECIFIC INFORMATION TO
WASH COULD REGARDING OWNERSHIP
OR OR FINANCIAL INTEREST IN A
RELATED PARTY --
THE PROVIDE ANY SERVICE TO A A
SNAP -- THE
REQUIREMENTS ACTUALLY ALSO SPEAK
TO OF RESTARTED FINDINGS --
WITH REGARD FACILITIES
CALIFORNIA.
FROM THE B. C. B. SPECIFICALLY
IDENTIFIES THE NEED FOR ONE
POSITION I HEALTH PROGRAM
MONITOR --
TO ACTUALLY ABOUT A WEEK
ADDITIONAL DATA ELEMENTS --
REGARDING RELATED PARTY
TRANSACTIONS --
AND A ONE TIME --
TO HAVE TWO THOUSAND DOLLAR
INVESTMENT IN IN I. T. WHICH
BASICALLY IS A CONFIGURATION TO
AN EXISTING SYSTEM --
TO ADD ADDITIONAL DATA ELEMENTS
IN THIS REGARD.
WHEN IT COMES MILLENNIAL?
WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THE
ROUTE REQUEST FOR PERSONNEL OR
FOR DID THE CHANGES TO THE I. T.
SYSTEM --
SPECIFICALLY --
BUT WE WOULD WANT TO NOTE THAT
FOR THIS PROPOSAL AND FOR
SEVERAL OTHER PROPOSALS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET --
THERE IS REFINING REQUESTED FOR
IT SYSTEMS THAT HAVE NOT ALL
GONE THE ENTIRELY THROUGH THE
FOR STAGE PROJECT APPROVAL
PROCESS --
THAT IS INTENDED --
YOU OVERSIGHT FOR UP FOR NEW BY
T. PROJECTS AND SO FORTH --
THIS PROJECT IS NOT ALL THE WAY
THROUGH --
AND WHILE IT DOES INCLUDE
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE THAT THE
RELEASE OF THE FUNDING WOULD BE
CONTINGENT UPON THE PROJECT
GOING THROUGH THE FULL FULL FOR
STAGE APPROVAL PROCESS IT
DOESN'T INCLUDE A NOTIFICATION
FOR THE LEGISLATURE SO.
SHOULD THERE BE ANY CHANGES TO
THE THE FUNDING OR THE PROJECT
SCOPE OR ANYTHING WE JUST THINK
IT WOULD BE --
WORTHWHILE TO MAKES SLIGHT
REVISIONS TO THAT LANGUAGE TO
PROVIDE FOR NOTIFICATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
OKAY SO --
AT THIS SOMEONE WHOSE --
AS SEEN VARIOUS IT PROJECTS --
MANY OF WHICH WERE SUCCESSFUL AT
SOME WHICH WERE NOT AND TO GET
AYE HEADLINES.
I HOPE THAT WE I I WOULD HOPE WE
CAN TAKE THE LA AS
RECOMMENDATION ARDEN JUST BE
SURE WE HAVE NOTIFICATIONS IS.
pSO THAT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL
AND A NO THIS IS A VERY LARGE IS
ONLY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
SO I KNOW I MAKE A BIG HUGE DEAL
ABOUT IT BUT BUT THIS THIS WAY
UNFORTUNATELY.
ALMOST ALL --
ASSUME THAT OUR IT PROJECTS
DON'T GO WELL AND THAT'S NOT
TRUE ACTUALLY BUT BUT WHEN THEY
DON'T DID UC'S PROBLEMATIC SO
IT'S IT'S WE'VE WE'VE GONE
THROUGH THE FIRST AGE AS FRUGAL
AND AND ACTUALLY WORKING WITH
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY ON A
DELEGATION REPORT RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE OF THIS.
THE ADDITIONAL STAGES WOULD NOT
BE REQUIRED.
BECAUSE OF THE SMALL SIDE OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WHAT GOOD I'D THOUGHTS
AND APPRECIATE HAVE SAID THAT
YOU'RE WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY ON THIS
OKAY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
THERE'S A DEAD OF OVER THERE ALL
RIGHT ISSUE NUMBER FOUR AND THEN
WE ALSO A STAKEHOLDER PROPOSAL'S
GONNA FOLLOW AFTERWARDS --
MENTAL HEALTH WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT WE AND WE TOUCHED ON
THE FIFTY MILLION A LITTLE
EARLIER BUT WHEN PROMOTING.
OUR SHOULD REQUEST GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO BE AVAILABLE
FOR EXPENDITURE UNTIL JUNE
THIRTIETH OF TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
THIS MONEY WOULD SUPPORT MENTAL
HEALTH --
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT THROUGH
EXISTING LOAN REPAYMENT AND
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS --
MANY THESE PROGRAMS --
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE STATE
LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM ARE IN
THE HEALTH PROFESSIONS EDUCATION
FUND ALL THESE --
AND ARE OVERSEEN BY I SHOULD.
I SHOULD WOULD BEGIN THE MANY
THE APPLICATION CYCLES FOR THESE
DECEMBER NINETEEN IN MAY OF
TWENTY TWENTY THIS WOULD FUND
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY LOAN REPAYMENTS PER YEAR
AND FIFTY SCHOLARSHIPS PER YEAR --
AND THE FUNDING WOULD BE AWARDED
BASED ON ELIGIBLE APPLICATIONS
ENVIED.
GREAT.
VALUE IMMENSE FINANCE
[inaudible]
ME MEMBERS.
OKAY.
SO UP APROPOS OUR PREVIOUS
DISCUSSION I MEAN.
GIVEN WHAT YOU'RE PLANNING TO DO
NOW -- DO
YOU SEE WHAT YOU SEE THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO SELF THEM YOU
MENTIONED --
LOAN PAYMENTS SCHOLARSHIPS --
NOW FOR PRICING RANGE OF
DIFFERENT MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS TO HOW HOW DO YOU
SEE WHAT YOU'RE PROPOSING HERE
POTENTIALLY BE ABLE TO LINE UP
WITH SOME OF THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE WITH --
THE COALITION AROUND WET AND SO
FORTH AND SO ON HOW DO THESE
THINGS MIGHT COME TOETHER ARE
NOT COME TOGETHER AND AS WE MOVE
FORWARD PUT TOGETHER BEFORE THE
REPORT TO THE ON WORKFORCE
EDUCATION TRAINING WAS RELEASED.
IT'S IT'S CERTAINLY A THAT THERE
pI THINK THE GOVERNOR WANTED TO
SIGNAL HIS STRONG SUPPORT FOR
MENTAL HEALTH EDUCATION AND
TRAINING --
THIS IS HIS PROPOSAL --
I'M SURE IS THE PROCESS WORKS AT
THE CAN CAN CONTINUE TO BE
CONVERSATIONS ON HOW MIGHT BE
WAYS TO WORK TOGETHER.
OKAY NO I ENDED THAT SAID WE
WERE RECOGNIZE THAT THE REPORT
CAME OUT AFTERWARDS BUT AT THE
SAID.
OBVIOUSLY WE WILL APPROVE A
BUDGET IN JUNE SO WE HAVE SOME
MONTHS AND I'M JUST THINKING
THAT -- NOW
THAT WE KNOW THERE'S A REPORT
AND WHICH WAS ACTUALLY AS WE ARE
THEY WORKED WITH YOUR AGENCY
RIGHT AND THAT WE HAVE THIS
PROPOSAL AND AGAIN I APPRECIATE.
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S --
DESIRE TO TO ACTUALLY ADDRESS
THE MENTAL HEALTH WORK FOR SO
THAT'S GREAT SO WE I MEAN WHEN
IT'S NOT THAT WE'RE FIGHTING FOR
NO DOLLARS TO GET SOMETHING WE
WE HALF DOLLARS HERE --
THOSE WE SERVE FURTHER DEVELOPED --
THIS FIGHT THE FINAL PROPOSAL IS
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE BRING IN
THE VARIOUS SOURCES OF
INFORMATION.
TOGETHER SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE
ONE PROPOSAL HERE ANOTHER
PROPOSAL HERE IN BETWEEN OUR
MEETING AND OF COURSE CERTAINLY
SINCE THIS IS BOTH THREE AGENCY
HOPEFULLY THAT MAKES IT EASIER
TO SO I'M JUST HOPING THAT.
BETWEEN NOW AND MAY WE ACTUALLY
HAVE SOME COMING TOGETHER AND
AND CAN COORDINATION SO WE CAN
MAKE AGAIN MAXIMUM USE OF THE
THE DOLLARS WE ARE PUTTING INTO
THIS AND GETTING THE MAXIMUM
IMPACT SO.
RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OKAY
SO -- WILL
PART THE WATERS BRIEFLY AGAIN --
FOR WE DO HAVE A STAKEHOLDER
PROPOSAL THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR.
AND THEN --
WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ALL
THESE ITEMS SO --
WE HAVE --
REPRESENTATIVE REPRESENTS A
JOURNEY HOUSE --
LOAN REPAYMENT OKAY.
SO IF YOU CAN COME UP.
TAKE A SEAT UP HERE --
YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES BUT THE
FIRST PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF.
AND WELCOME.
MY NAME IS --
JESSE IDEA AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF THE OFFICE SECURE JOURNEY
HOUSE.
WE ARE A DIRECT SERVICE
[inaudible]
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS WITH
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH IN
CALIFORNIA.
DURING THE HIGHER EDUCATION.
WE APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR'S
LEADERSHIP INCLUDING HIS FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT.
AND EXPANSION OF CALIFORNIA'S
CRUCIAL MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
MENTAL HEALTH MULTIPLE STUDIES
HAVE FOUND.
THAT LOAN FORGIVENESS PROGRAMS
ARE EFFECTIVE A RECRUITING AND
RETAINING PROFESSIONALS WITH
PARTICIPANTS MORE LIKELY TO WORK
IN UNDERSERVED AREAS IN THE LONG
RUN.
CURRENTLY THE LICENSE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICE WRITER DUCATION
FUND PROVIDES LONELY PAYMENTS OF
FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS. FOR
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS WHO
COMMIT TO SERVING A SHORTAGE
AREA RELEASED TWENTY FOUR MONTHS.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB TWENTY
SIX OH EIGHT AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK STONE LAST
YEAR.
THERE'S NOW AN ACCOUNT WITHIN
THE FUND --
YOUR MARK FUHRMAN TO HOLD
WORKFORCE OF ONE APPROPRIATION
OF THE LEGISLATURE.
OUR REQUESTED A LINE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S INTENT TO SHRINK IN
THE STATE'S MENTAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE BY SPECIFICALLY
PROVIDING FORMER FOSTER YOUTH
MEETING FOR OPPORTUNITIES. TO
JOIN THE FEEL OF SOCIAL WORK AND
MENTAL HEALTH AND TO GET BACK TO
THE COMMUNITY THAT THEY COME
FROM.
SOCIAL WORKERS WERE IN FOR WHO
WERE FUSSY THEMSELVES ARE LIKELY
TO BE HIGHLY PATHETIC AND HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE IN SERVING THE
POPULATION THEY ONCE WERE.
IN FACT A REPORT BY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF BEANS
AND DIRECTORS THE SCHOOL OF
SOCIAL WORK STATED THAT.
CULTURAL COMPETENCY IN IS AN
ESSENTIAL SKILL. TO INCREASE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF SERVICE
DELIVERY.
THE MASTER PLAN FOR SOCIAL WORK
EDUCATION THE STATE TELEPHONE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA LISTA
CULTURAL SENSITIVITY.
AS A NECESSARY SKILL SET.
DUTCH THAT IS SHOWN TO IMPROVE
THE LONG TERM SUCCESS OF YOUTH
SERVED.
WHAT MANY CALIFORNIA FOSTER THIS
BAR TO GO TO COLLEGE JUST MORE
THAN 50% GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL?
APPROXIMATELY FOUR GRADUATE WITH
A COLLEGE.
GRADUATE COLLEGE WITH EVEN A
SMALLER PERCENTAGE COMPLETED A
MASTER'S OUR PEACH THE PROGRAMS
SUCH AS THESE PROVIDE HOPE
INCENTIVE.
AND A PIPELINE OF SUPPORT TO
FORMER FOSS YOUTH INTO
MEANINGFUL CAREERS IN A LIFE OF
SELF SUFFICIENCY.
IN GENERAL --
WAGES AND HIGH DEGREE COSTS
DISCOURAGE MANY PEOPLE FROM
ENTERING SOCIAL WORK WITH
TURNOVER RATES FOR SOCIAL
WORKERS LOOKED.
UP 75% IN SOME CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES IT'S IN A COMMITTED
PROVIDERS TO MEET THE GROWING
NEEDS.
WE URGE THE SUPPORT OF THE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR LOCATION INTO THE SUB
FUND ESTABLISHED TO SUPPORT
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH IN CAREERS.
AS SOCIAL WORKERS AND MENTAL
PROVIDERS.
IN ORDER FOR THIS FUND TO BE
FULLY UTILIZED.
WE MUST INFORM FORMER FOSTER THE
RUN THE STATE OF THEIR
LEGIBILITY TO DELIVER IT AND
MEANING FOR OUTRAGE.
GIVEN THAT THERE WILL BE REAL
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS INCURRED
DUE TO DEVELOPING MATERIALS AND
CONDUCTING OUTREACH TO ENSURE
FAUCET --
WHERE THIS PROGRAM WE SUGGEST
CONSIDERATION OF AN INCREASE OF
THE LEVEL OF THE PROPOSAL OF ONE
MILLION DOLLARS TO ENSURE THE
ADMINISTRATION?
AND THE UTILIZATION OF THIS
PROGRAM BE SUCCESSFUL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR MUCH ANY
COMPANY OBSERVATION COMES FROM
MUCH FUN OKAY LA L..
FINANCE RIGHT QUESTIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
RIGHT I A PRE APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION I GUESS I'M GOING
TO ASK SOME QUESTIONS I DID ASK
FOR THE REGIONAL BILL CAME
THROUGH --
AND I RECOGNIZE THAT.
IS A FIRST OF ALL CERTAINLY I
AGREE WITH WHAT YOU SAID THAT --
THAT FORMER FOSSE'S UNION BRING
DOLLY UNIQUE BUT A VERY
IMPORTANT PERSPECTIVES TO THE
WORK.
AS BEING SOCIAL WORKER SO WE
WANT TO GIVE --
OF THE KIND OF SUPPORTS TO
FOSTER USED TO BE ABLE TO DO
THIS WORK --
AND THEY'VE CERTAINLY BRING
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE EFFECTIVE --
AS IN THOSE AND THAT ROLE --
AND A ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT PART
OF WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS IS THAT
WELL -- AS
THIS IS A REAL LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM THAT PERHAPS --
FOSTER USE ARE GOING AND
PARTIALLY BECAUSE THEY DON'T
KNOW THERE'S PROGRAMS AVAILABLE
TO HELP PERHAPS HELP THEM PAY
FOR THE TRAINING BUT I DO HAVE
TO START OFF WITH SAYING LIKE
HOW MANY FOSTER USE OUT THERE
WHO ARE BECAUSE THIS IS A REAL
LOAN PAYMENT WHO ARE ENTERING
SOCIAL.
AS WELL AS THE UNIVERSE OF OF OF
PEOPLE WERE TALKING ABOUT THESE
RIGHT NOW.
WHO ARE OUT THERE AS SAID THAT --
WHO WHO DO WHO COULD BENEFIT
FROM THE FUNDS AT LEAST AT THIS
THAT AT THIS CURRENT TIME?
YES SO --
INITIALLY IN IN OUR QUEST TO TRY
TO TRACK DATA AND FIND REPORTS
ON THE OUTCOMES OF FOSTER IN
HIGHER EDUCATION --
WITH REGARDS TO IS --
GRADUATE SCHOOL THERE'S
VIRTUALLY NO DATA --
WE WERE ABLE TO FIND THE PROGRAM
AT UC DAVIS WHICH THE GARDENS
PROFESSIONS PROGRAM --
THAT WAS A PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY
TALK YOUTH WHO WERE TRANSFERRING
INTO GRADUATE PROGRAMS AND WE
WERE ABLE TO PULL THE DATA ABOUT
THE USE THAT THE OF THE STUDENTS
THAT THEY SERVE --
FROM FROM THE GUARDS PROFESSIONS
PROGRAM --
AND SO WE ESTIMATED THE A SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR REQUEST.
A BASED ON THE AMOUNT OF
STUDENTS AT THE PROGRAM SERVED --
AND IN PARTICULAR THOSE A WE'RE
GOING INTO SOCIAL WORK DEGREES
WHICH BELIEVE WAS OF ROUGHLY
OVER FORTY FIVE STUDENTS --
AND SO WE YOU KNOW BASED OUR
ESTIMATE OF SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND TOOT TOOT TO ME FIFTY
UP POTENTIAL WORK OKAY ALL RIGHT
SO THAT'S HELPFUL TO KNOW.
AND I GUESS THE OTHER QUESTION I
HAVE THOUGH IS THAT I MEAN.
LAMBS IS RECREATE A SEPARATE
FUND RIGHT BUT WE ALSO WE'RE
PROPOSING VARIOUS FUNDS FOR
MENTAL HEALTH WORKFORCE TRAINING.
AND SO FORTH AND I AGREE WITH
YOU THAT FAST YOU SPRING UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE.
BUT ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT THE NUMBER
RIGHT AND ACTUALLY WE WANT TO
INCREASE THOSE NUMBERS --
WOULD IT BE A BETTER STRATEGY TO
SAY THAT ACTUALLY YOU --
IN THE LARGER FUNDS TO ACTUALLY
GIVE PREFERENTIAL --
YOU KNOW --
IN STREET LAYOUT FOR BASICALLY
PREFERENTIAL WHAT.
DOES FOR FOSTER USE INSTEAD OF
SCREENING A SEPARATE FUND WHERE
WE'RE NOT SURE OF WHETHER IT'S
CAN BE BIG ENOUGH FOR TWO BIG OR
TOO SMALL AND CENTER AND SAY.
YOU KNOW IN THE LARGER UNIVERSE
OF MONEY WE'RE GONNA GIVE TOWARD
MENTAL HEALTH WORK FOR SOME
PEOPLE GOING INTO BEING YELP
SOCIAL WORKERS OR OTHER TYPES OF
POSITIONS.
THAT WE IF YOU SAY THAT I WAS A
FOSTER YOUTH YOU ACTUALLY GET
THAT GIVES YOU A DEAL A
PREFERENCE IN TERMS OF GETTING
LOAN REPAYMENT OR SCHOLARSHIPS
WATER ELSE --
AND THAT --
IS A WAY TO TRY TO ACHIEVE THE
SAME AIM THAT YOUR THAT YOU'RE
SEEKING.
WELL I I JUST WANT TO REITERATE
THAT -- YOU
KNOW ASSEMBLY BILL --
TWENTY SIX WE DID ESTABLISH THE
FUNDS WHAT IS IS THE STATE LAW --
END UP WITH REGARDS TO
ADMINISTRATION HOW --
YOU KNOW THE ADMINISTRATORS OF
THE PROGRAM'S WOULD ADMINISTERED
DISTRIBUTING OR MAKING AWARDS I
THINK THAT MIGHT BE A QUESTION
MARK MORE APPROPRIATE FOR FOR
COLLEGE OR ASPECTS.
OF OKAY IN IS THAT POSSIBILITY --
DAMASCUS PERSPECTIVE THAT WE
GIVE SOME PREFERENCE IN THE
SCORING OR SOMETHING.
TO PEOPLE FORMER FOSTER USE THAT
MAKES SENSE --
IT'S IT'S WORTH A DISCUSSION I
MEAN AFTER FIVE TO CONTINUE WITH
THE OKAY SO SO.
I'D SO I MADE IT IT'SFUN I'M
SHARING IS IS THAT ONE IS IS
THAT WE WANT TO GET.
BY HELP FOSTER USE BECAUSE THAT
FOR LOTS OF REASONS RIGHT NOW WE
DO THE SPECIAL KNOWLEDGE THEY
BRING AN EXPERIENCE.
ALSO AS FAR ST THEY REALLY HAVE
AS MAY RESOURCES RIGHT AND SO
FORTH.
AND ALSO WE ALSO WANT TO GET THE
WORD OUT TO THE FAUCET YOU THAT
THEY HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY IF
THAT'S SOMETHING YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN SO THAT TAKES SOME
RESOURCES AS WELL SO WE CAN LAND
SOMETHING AROUND THAT.
OKAY WE HAVE WE HAVE SOME TIME
TO WORK ON THAT.
PERHAPS WE SHOULD THINK ABOUT
THAT OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU OKAY WELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS NOW OKAY THANK YOU.
SO -- WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENTS IS --
TWO THREE FOUR AND THE I'M.
AND THE S. STAKEHOLDER PROPOSAL --
SO IF PEOPLE WANT TO COME UP TO
THE MICROPHONE HERE [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ON A REAL
MEMBER --
DANNY OFFER FROM PLATEN ADVISORS
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL ILLNESS
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL THINK.
OKAY ANYONE ELSE OKAY.
A SCENE OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT I
WANTED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
AND PRESENTING --
BUDGET PROPOSALS I KNOW THERE'S
A LOT OF GREAT WORK BEING DONE
AT ASCOT AND WE CERTAINLY HERE
LIVE INTEREST IN THE WORK FORCE
COMPONENT HELPING PEOPLE AS WELL
SONG BROWN MENTAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S --
PUTTING --
THE MONEY IN THE BUDGET FOR MORE
FEARFULHEALTH WORKFORCE.
AND SO --
APPRECIATE INTO WOULD LOOK FOR
PROPOSALS --
MOVING FORWARD SO THANKS VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE AND WE WILL
BE OUR GUEST PUTTING ON FARMING
AND THREE ON HOLD.
HOLDING OPEN --
ITEMS -- THE
THE THREE STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS
THAT WE HEARD AS PART OF THE
OVERVIEW AND THEN ALSO --
ISSUES TO THREE FOR AND ALSO THE
STATE CALLED PROPOSAL WE HEARD
AND ISSUE.
FOR OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO THANK YOU THANKS
FOR MUCH.
RIGHT --
NEXT UP IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
WELCOME SO WE'RE GOING.
TO SO WHAT WILL.
TO STICK WITH US FOR THAT RIGHT
YEAH AT THE END OKAY SO --
RIGHT SO THERE'S SERVICE
DEPARTMENT RIGHT OKAY SO WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO --
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH --
THE STATE OF THE STATE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THEN MAYBE WE'LL DO
IS TAKE SOME PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THAT IF THERE'S PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND THEN WE'LL MOVE THROUGH
ISSUES TO THROUGH --
THIRTEEN A AND THEN WE'LL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER THAT AND
AND AND ISSUE FOURTEEN WE HAVE
SEVERAL STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS
WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER
THAT SO FOR THE AUDIENCE. TO
FOLLOW ALONG ALL RIGHT SO WHAT
COMES SO FIRST WILL BEGIN WITH
INTRODUCTIONS SO WHY SOARING
WITH THE AGENCY.
WELCOME.
SMITH I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH.
THE MORNING BRED IN UNISON THE
CHIEF DEPUTY FOR OPERATIONS AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
L. ANY PARTICULARLY --
FINANCE.
ONLY BECAUSE HE FINANCE IT WE
ARE ALMOST FINANCE OKAY SO WE'LL
BE ABLE HE OVERVIEW AND THE
STATE OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS STONE --
THE LA --
HAS REQUESTED THAT INSTEAD OF
OUR DO THE PROVIDE A STATE OF
THE STATE'S PUBLIC HEALTH --
REPORT.
HEARING FOR THIS HEARING I
THOUGHT ABOUT THE MANY DIFFERENT
WAYS THAT WE IN PUBLIC HEALTH
CONSIDER WHAT IS IMPORTANT --
PRIORITY HEALTH ISSUE AND SO I
ASK STAFF FROM A VARIETY OF
PROGRAMSTO GET TOGETHER AND
PROVIDE YOU THIS THE HANDOUT
THAT YOU WILL WHICH WHERE YOU
WILL SEE THAT.
THIS IS NOT BY ANY MEANS A
COMPREHENSIVE REPORT ON THE
STATE OF PUBLIC HEALTH BUT
RATHER AN EXEMPLAR OF THE WAYS
THAT WE CAN CONSIDER THAT FROM --
HOW MUCH MORTALITY IS CAUSED BY
GIVING CONDITION TO HOW MUCH
PROMISE SURE OF IT EARLY DOUBTS
THAT IT CAUSES --
THOSE THINGS THAT CAUSE GREATEST
LEVELS OF DISABILITY OR NUMBER
OF YEARS WITH DISABILITY.
AND ALSO --
TO FOR US OF PARTICULAR
IMPORTANCE FOR THOSE CONDITIONS
WHICH SHOW THE GREATEST
DISPARITIES IN HEALTHDOT COMS.
AND THEN FINALLY.
SHEER NUMBERS OF CASES AS WE DO
FROM FACTIONS DISEASES.
TOM THEN AND ALSO WE CONSIDER
EMERGING AND RE EMERGING
DISEASES WHICH I'M GOING TO TALK
ABOUT --
CONDITIONS I AM IN A MOMENT TO
COLLECTING AND ANALYZING DATA
LIKE THIS AND TURNING IT INTO
INFORMATION THAT CAN INFORM
POLICY IN ACTION IS A
FOUNDATIONAL PUBLIC HEALTH'S.
ACTIVITY PARTICULARLY AT THE
STATE LEVEL.
AND WITH CITY PH COLLECT MONITOR
AND REPORT ON INCLUDING --
LEGISLATIVE REPORTS AND OTHER
REPORTS THREE I WANT TO MENTION
OF OF IMPORTANCE ARE THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH STATUS
PROFILES WHICH CONTAIN.
A STATE AND COUNTY LEVEL DATA ON
SPECIFIC INDICATORS RECOMMENDED
BY THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE
CONTROL AND THE NATIONAL --
HEALTH THIS STATE IS THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR HEALTH
STATISTICS AND THIS REPORT
PROVIDES BOTH PERCENTAGES BUT
THEN RANKINGS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE -- FOR
THOSE INDICATORS THAT ALSO HAVE
HEALTHY PEOPLE --
TWENTY TWENTY OUTCOMES TO SHOW
HOW THE STATE IS DOING AND IN
REACHING THOSE DESIRED OUTCOMES
WE ALSO DIRECTED MANAGE THEY
LET'S GET HEALTHY CALIFORNIA THE
STATE HEALTH IMPROVEMENT PLAN.
WHICH REPORTS ON SPECIFIC
INDICATORS THAT ALIGN WITH
HEALTH OUTCOME GOALS FOR
COLLECTIVE IMPACT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE -- AND
THEN FINALLY THE SECOND EDITION
OF OUR BURDEN OF CHRONIC DISEASE
REPORT WILL BE COMING OUT
SHORTLY.
BUT WE DON'T JUST GATHER DATA
FOR DATA SAKE.
THEY SAID WE REALLY WANT TO HELP
SET PRIORITIES AND WE WANT TO
DRIVE EFFECTIVE ACTION WE ALSO
HAVE A FOCUS ON PREVENTION.
AND THAT MEANS THAT WE DON'T
JUST COLLECT THE INSTANCES OF
CONDITIONS OR DISEASES BUT WE'RE
REALLY INTERESTED IN KNOWING WHO
IS AFFECTED --
WHAT ARE THE THE THE THE BOTH A
PHYSICAL BUT OFFICE ALSO TO THE
INDIVIDUAL SOCIAL AND COMMUNITY
FACTORS THAT EITHER PUT SOMEONE
AT RISK OR PROTECT THEM --
AND THAT SAME DATA THAT WE
GATHER CAN ALSO BE USED TO
EVALUATE THAT INTERVENTIONS THAT
YOU PUT IN PLACE TO TRY TO
PREVENT THESE DISEASES AND
CONDITIONS. FOR THE PURPOSES OF
THIS HEARING AND ALL THE LIMITED
TIME FRAME OF WHAT I'M GONNA DO
IS JUST --
PROVIDE A FEW EXAMPLES OF WHERE
CALIFORNIA'S REALLY DOING WELL
IN IMPROVING WHERE WE SING GOOD
IMPROVEMENT BUT ALSO SEVERAL
AREAS WHERE THERE ARE STILL
SIGNIFICANT THREATS TO
POPULATION HEALTH IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WHAT I THINK IT MIGHT TAKE
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
CHALLENGES --
ON THE VERY BROAD SCALE IT IN
TERMS OF LIFE EXPECTANCY
CALIFORNIA'S ACTUALLY SEEN
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT IN LIFE
EXPECTANCY.
IN NINETEEN NINETY WE RANK
TWENTY FOURTH AMONG STATES WITH
A AVERAGE LIFE EXPECTANCY OF
SEVENTY FIVE POINT NINE YEARS.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT STUDY IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA RANKS
SECOND ONLY TO HAWAII WITH AN
AVERAGE LIFE EXPECTANCY OF
ALMOST EIGHTY ONE YEARS SO
SUBSTANTIAL IMPROVEMENT IN FACT
THIS WAS THE GREATEST GAIN IN
LIFE EXPENSES HE OF ANY STATE
DURING THAT SAME TIME PERIOD.
AND FOR CHRONIC DISEASES WE'VE
SEEN -- FOR
MANY OTHER CHRONIC DISEASES ARE
THE DEATH RATES HAVE IMPROVED
OVER TIME ID NUMBERS OF DEATHS
ARE DECREASING BUT THEY DO
REMAIN SOME OF THE MOST COMMON
AND COSTLY --
CONDITIONS IN CALIFORNIA IN FACT
75% OF ALL DEATHS ARE ULTIMATELY
DUE TO CHRONIC DISEASES.
I'M HEART DISEASE AND CANCER
ALONE BECAUSE NEARLY 50% OF ALL
DEATHS IN IN CALIFORNIA.
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY WORRISOME
FOR THE FUTURE IS THE FACT THAT
ONE OUT OF EVERY SIX CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN AND ONE IN EVERY THREE
TEENS IS ALREADY OVER WEIGHT OR
OBESE WHICH IS I SENT A STRONG
RISK FACTOR FOR FUTURE
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE CANCER
AND OTHER CHRONIC DISEASES.
INCLUDING DIABETES IN FACT THE
PREVALENCE OF DIABETES IN
CALIFORNIA'S INCREASED 34%
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND THREE IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND AS OF 2069%
OF ALL CALIFORNIA ADULTS WHICH
IS TWO POINT SIX MILLION PEOPLE
HAVE ALREADY BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH
DIABETES.
AND AN ALARMING 46% OF ALL
ADULTS ARE THIRTEEN MILLION HAVE
BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH THAT WITH
PRE DIABETES WITHOUT
INTERVENTION ON AVERAGE ONE OUT
OF FOUR OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WILL GO ON TO DEVELOP DIABETES.
RATES OF DIABETES ALSO DIFFER
SIGNIFICANTLY GEOGRAPHICALLY IN
CALIFORNIA AS DO MANY OF THESE
IMPORTANT TO CONDITIONS THE RATE
IN IMPERIAL COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE
IS THE HIGHEST AT FOURTEEN POINT
8% O ADULTS.
AND ITS LOWEST IN MARIN COUNTY
WITH WO POINT 6% QUITE A QUITE
A SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE.
AND DIABETES IS ALSO DISEASE
WHERE WE CAN CLEARLY SEE THE
IMPACT OF SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH.
DIABETES RATES AMONG WHITES IS
ART 7% AMONG AFRICAN AMERICANS
9% AND AMONG LATINOS IT'S 11%.
AND RICHARD THREE TIMES HIGHER
AMONG PEOPLE FROM HIGH SCHOOL
THAN THOSE THAT HAVE A COLLEGE
DEGREE AND TWICE AS HIGH IN
FAMILIES THAT ARE LIVING UNDER
THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL ALL OF
WHICH OF FACT THE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT PEOPLE HAVE TO BE HEALTHY.
WE'VE SEEN SOME SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENTS --
IN MANY CHRONIC DISEASES
INCLUDING CANCER HEART DISEASE
HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE AND STROKE
EACH OF WHICH RATES HAVE
DECREASED --
AND THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF
FACTORS THAT HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO
THIS THING AND NOT THE LEAST OF
WHICH WOULD BE THE EXPANSION OF
HIGH QUALITY.
HEALTH CARE AND ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE THROUGHOUT THE STATE AS
WELL AS PREVENTIVE SERVICES BUT
CALIFORNIA'S ALSO MADE IMPORTANT
POLICY CHANGES THAT HAVE HAD A
PROFOUND EFFECT.
AND A GOOD EXAMPLE IS SMOKING
SMOKING REMAINS A LEADING CAUSE
OF PREMATURE DEATH DISEASE AND
DISABILITY EVEN THOUGH DEATHS
FROM LUNG CANCER BEEN DECREASING
FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS --
THAT BUT CHANGES IN POLICY THAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN AN ACTIVE IN
CALIFORNIA BOTH AT THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVEL AS WELL AS PRIVATE
HEALTH PREVENTION WORK HAVE HAD
A HUGE IMPACT.
CALIFORNIA SMOKING RATES HAVE
DECREASED 54% --
IN ADULTS DOWN TO TEN POINT 1%
AND FOUR POINT 3% IN SCHOOL
YOUTH.
AND BY TWENTY FOURTEEN LUNG
CANCER MORTALITY IN CALIFORNIA
HAD DROPPED 43% AND WAS 30%
LOWER THAN THE REST OF THE
NATION HIS ARE SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENTS.
WHEN I TURN TO SOME EMERGING
ISSUES THAT I THINK DESERVE
ATTENTION OPIATES AS YOU KNOW
ESPECIALLY DOCTOR PAN ARE --
DRUGS TYPICALLY USED FOR PAIN
RELIEF SUCH AS CODEINE
HYDROCODONE IN FRONT NOW.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT
CALIFORNIA'S OVERALL RATE OF
OPIOID DISSOCIATED OVERDOSING
DUST IS SUBSTANTIALLY LOWER THAN
THAT NATIONAL RATE WE STILL HAVE
NEARLY TWO THOUSAND OVER OPIATE
OVERDOSE DEATHS EVERY YEAR AND
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT THOUSAND
HOSPITAL EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT
VISITS.
AS WELL AS OVER TWENTY FOUR
MILLION FIRST IN CALIFORNIA TO
EAST CONTINUE TO HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
LIKE THE NATION AND WE HAVE BEEN
BATTLING OPIOID.
INCREASED YEAR PERIOD YOU SAID
MISUSE FOR OVER A DECADE THE
RECENT SHARP INCREASE THAT IS
YET GARNERED SO MUCH ATTENTION
IS LARGELY A FUNCTION OF
UNCHECKED AND POORLY UNDERSTOOD
PER PRESCRIPTION PAIN MANAGEMENT.
AND WE HAD EARLY SUCCESSES IN
DEATH RATES TO PER PRESCRIPTION
ASSOCIATED OF THE OVERDOSES.
HOWEVER IN RECENT YEARS DESPITE
THOSE EFFECTIVE INTERVENTIONS --
WE HAVE SEEN THE EPIDEMIC SHIFT
INCREASINGLY TO BE ASSOCIATED
WITH ILLICIT DRUG USE INCLUDING
HEROIN AND FUNCTIONAL.
BUT WE DID WE HAVE HAD SUCCESS --
RISING RATES DO YOU HAVE
DECREASED SHARPLY SINCE TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND PRESCRIPTION OPIOID
ASSOCIATED DEATHS RACHED THEIR
LOWEST LEVEL IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN HOWEVER HEROIN
RELATED OVERDOSED US OF
INCREASED 97% SINCE TWENTY
TWELVE AND FENNEL RELATED DEATHS
HAVE INCREASED FOUR HUNDRED AND
23%.
THERE IS ALSO WHY GEOGRAPHIC
VARIATION IN THE IMPACT OF OF
OPIOID CRISIS WITH OUR NORTHERN
RURAL COUNTIES BY HAVING
SUBSTANTIALLY HIGHER RATES.
OF ADVERSE OUTCOMES AND OF
COURSE ARE ARE A POPULOUS
SOUTHERN COUNTIES HAVE THIS THE
LARGEST NUMBERS.
SUICIDE IS ANOTHER SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE THAT WE'RE FACING
CIRCLE SUICIDE RATES HAVE
DECLINED IN THE NINETEEN
NINETIES BUT HAVE INCREASED IN
THE MOST RECENT DECADES.
AND ARE NOW DOUBLE THE HOMICIDE
RATES TO SITE ACCOUNTS FOR
NEARLY TWICE THE NUMBER OF
DEATHS STATEWIDE AS OPIOIDS OR
HOMICIDES.
AND IS ONE OF THE TOP TEN CAUSES
OF PREMATURE DEATH IN CALIFORNIA.
MAN COMMITS SUICIDE AT THREE
TIMES THE RATE OF WOMEN THAT ARE
TEN TIMES MORE LIKELY TO USE A
FIREARM.
AND WHILE THE HIGHEST RATES ARE
AMONG MALES OVER EIGHTY SUICIDE
IS THE SECOND LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH.
AMONG ADOLESCENTS AND YOUNG
ADULTS AGED.
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR MANY OF
THE SAME COMMUNITIES THAT SEE
HIGH RATES OF OPIOID OVERDOSE
THE NORTHERN COUNTIES FOR
EXAMPLE ALSO EXPERIENCE SUICIDE
RATES SUBSTANTIALLY HIGHER THAN
THE STATE WIDE RATE.
AND THEN FINALLY I WANT TO TALK
A BIT ABOUT THE RAPID RISE AND
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED DISEASES
ACROSS THE STATE.
OVER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CASES OF STDS WERE REPORTED IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN UP 45% FROM
JUST FIVE YEARS AGO.
AND OF GREATEST CONCERN TO MANY
IS THE RESURGENCE OF THE
ENTIRELY PREVENTABLE CONDITION
OF CONGENITAL SYPHILIS.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT WE WERE
SUCCESSFUL IN PREVENTING AT
LEAST 70% OF POTENTIAL
CONGENITAL SYPHILIS CASES
THROUGH DETECTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION AND TREATMENT.
THERE WERE STILL TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THREE CASES SYPHILIS AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND THIRTY
CIVIL DISASSOCIATED STILLBIRTH
THAT'S THE HIGHEST IN TWENTY
YEARS.
MOST OF THE WOMEN WHO GAVE BIRTH
TO BABIES WITH CONGENITAL
SYPHILIS AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN
DID NOT RECEIVE ADEQUATE OR
TIMELY PRENATAL CARE WHICH COULD
HAVE PREVENTED TRANSMISSION.
THE MOST COMMON MATERNAL RISK
FACTORS WERE SUBSTANCE USE
HOMELESSNESS EXCHANGE OF SEX FOR
MONEY OR DRUGS AND CONTACT WITH
THE JAIL SYSTEM.
STRANGE AS IT MAY SEEM AT FIRST
BLUSH FATAL UNKNOWN NONFATAL
OPIOID DOSES SUICIDE AND
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED DISEASES
SHARE MANY OF THE SAME ROOT
CAUSES.
AND THEY ARE INCREASING DESPITE
OUR PROGRESS IN HAVING ME
EXPANDING ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND IN LARGE PART THIS IS
BECAUSE THESE AREN'T JUST
DISEASES OF PEOPLE BUT THERE
DISEASES OF COMMUNITIES AND
SOCIETY.
AND THERE ARE RISING IN A TIME
WHEN INCREASING NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE SIMPLY DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO AFFORD THE BASIC
COST OF LIVING LIKE HEALTHY.
FOOD AND STABLE HOUSING.
HOPELESSNESS AND DESPAIR ARE
COMMON SYMPTOMS ACROSS EACH OF
THESE CONDITIONS.
AND THEY ARE ALSO RISE THEY HAVE
ALSO HAVE THE WRITTEN ADVERSE
EXPERIENCES IN CHILDHOOD SUCH AS
POVERTY VIOLENCE AND TRAUMA.
AND STICK MY REMAINS A POWERFUL
BERRIER TO SEEKING CARE.
THESE CONDITIONS ALSO REFLECT AN
INCREASING RELIANCE ON
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM THAT'S IT
ALONE CAN'T FIX THE PROBLEM
BECAUSE IT CAN ONLY TREAT THE
SYMPTOMS AND NOT THE ROOT CAUSES.
TO ALTERNATELY FOR US TO ADDRESS
THESE AND OTHER DISEASES OF
DESPAIR WE WILL NEED TO HAVE A
SYSTEM OF PREVENTION THAT
ADDRESSES.
THOSE REAP ROOT CAUSES LIKE
POVERTY HOMELESSNESS AND
VIOLENCE AND A HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
THAT CAN PROVIDE TREATMENT FREE
OF BIAS AND STIGMA AND THAT
RECOGNIZES THE MENTAL AND
EMOTIONAL HEALTH ARE AS INTEGRAL
TO THE PERSON'S WELL BEING AS
PHYSICAL HEALTH.
MAKING SIGNIFICANT STATE
SUSTAINABLE IMPROVEMENTS IN THE
PUBLIC'S HEALTH IN CALIFORNIA IS
GOING TO REQUIRE THAT WE HAVE A
MUCH GREATER UNDERSTANDING.
HOW THESE SOCIAL PHYSICAL AND
BEHAVIORAL FACTORS INTERACT?
AND FIGURING OUT WHICH LEVERS WE
CAN USE EFFECTIVELY TO ACHIEVE
AND MAINTAIN A HEALTHY AND
RESILIENT CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS BE MEMBERS THURSTONE
WHILE ALL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION THAT WAS --
QUITE A QUITE AN EDUCATION FOR
ME AND WE CERTAINLY SEEN --
IN MY COUNTY RIVERSIDE COUNTY
WE'VE SEEN A SURGE OF OF
SYPHILIS AND GONORRHEA SO I I
JUST.
WE NEED TO OBVIOUSLY GET OUT
INTO THE COMMUNITY AND TO HEDGE
KATE -- OUR
POPULATION THAT THE OF THE USER.
TREATABLE DISEASES THEY CAN BE
PREVENTED WITH APPROPRIATE --
PROTECTIONS --
INSERTED THE CONGENITAL
SURPLUSES IS A MAJOR.
ISSUE FOR US TO DEAL WITH.
I ALSO --
SHARE YOUR CONCERN ABOUT
CHILDHOOD OBESITY IN THE IN THE
HIGHER INCIDENCE OF OF DIABETES
THAT WERE SAYING.
IT IS UNFORTUNATE THAT TODAY WE
DON'T SEE THE ATHLETIC PROGRAMS
THAT WE DID WHEN I WAS A KID YOU
KNOW TODAY KIDS ARE YOU KNOW.
PROPERTY BUT MAY BE A LOT OF
JUNK FOODS WHICH I DO AND
SHOULDN'T --
BUT YOU KNOW WE USED TO BURN IT
OFF YOU KNOW WE STEP P. PHYSICAL
EDUCATION CLASS AND WE USED TO
HAVE.
INTRAMURAL SPORTS AND WE USED.
TO PLAY IN.
WE GOT HOME AFTER DINNER WE WERE
TO GO TO THAT WE'RE TIRED AFTER
ALL THE PHYSICAL ACTIVITY WE
NEED SOMEHOW ANOTHER STRUCTURED
YOUR YOUR YOUR PERVIOUS.
WE NEED TO SOMEHOW ENCOURAGE
MORE --
CARDIOVASCULAR.
STIMULATION WITHIN OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEM IN AND BRING BACK --
MORE ACTIVE RECREATION AND
SPORTS --
AND I KNOW MANY IS ALWAYS AN
ISSUE BUT YEAH WE JUST AND HAVE
A CHILDHOOD OBESITY PROBLEMS
THAT WE DID.
WHEN I WAS YOUNGER AND CERTAINLY
THE COMPUTER GENERATION IN THE
ONLINE GAMING IS ARE ALSO PLAYED
A ROLE IN THE THAT THE STATIC
ACTIVITY OF OF PEOPLE --
ANOTHER ISSUE PRODUCT THAT --
IS IS VERY IMPORTANT TO ME IS
THE THE SUICIDE RATE TO AND
YOUNG CHILDREN AND YOUNG ADULTS.
AND THAT YOU ALSO BROUGHT UP --
ON AN ALARMING STATISTIC TO WITH
THE THE NUMBER PH<c.cyan> N</c>
OVERDOSES OVERSEEING ANDIN THE
IN THE COMMUNITIES WHERE --
MAYBE SOMEBODY'S ARE CLASSIFIED
A SUICIDES BUT MANY OF THEM ARE
JUST MISTAKENLY INTERACTING WITH
A THINK IT'S HER WHEN AND IT IS
FOUNTAIN ALL.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT KIND OF A
PUBLIC EDUCATION PROGRAM WE CAN
HAVE TO THOSE THAT ARE
UNFORTUNATELY CAUGHT UP IN THIS
WILL BE A CRISIS.
THEY'RE ALL TRYING TO ADDRESS
THAT YOU KNOW BE WHERE WHICH ARE
INJECTING MEANING MAYBE MUCH
STRONGER THAN WHAT YOU THINK
YOU'RE INJECTING AND COULD CLAIM
YOUR LIFE AND WE JUST HAD A
FAMILY MEMBER --
MY SON WHO'S ONE OF HIS
CORPORATE FRIENDS CAME FROM.
YOU KNOW A VERY VERY GOOD
BEGINNINGS AND WENT TO SCHOOL.
GOT CAUGHT UP INTOXICATION SO
WAS VERY VERY DISTURBING.
SO -- ALSO --
IMAGINE A 50% OF THE DEATHS AND
CITY CALIFORNIA ARE DUE --
TO CARDIAC --
ISSUES AND AND CANCER ISSUES.
A CERTAINLY --
WE CAN EFFECTUATE --
YOU KNOW MUCH MORE --
HEALTHY LIVING --
WHICH WILL HELP A LOT NOT ONLY
WITH THE DIABETES THAT WE
MENTIONED BEFORE BUT ALSO
PREVENT HEART DISEASE BY BREAK --
TO MODERN BUT PRESSURES.
BECAUSE A PROMISE KEEPER SO BUSY
WITH OUR LIVES HELL TO GET
DIAGNOSED WITH NEXT THING YOU
KNOW THE THIRD HOUSE BUT WITH A
STROKE OR A HEART ATTACK AT A
VERY YOUNG AGE IN AMERICA NO
LEAD A VERY.
CHALLENGING LIFE --
AS WE KNOW THAT HEART MUSCLE
DOESN'T --
REALLY WE TO REGENERATE VERY
MUCH AFTER ITS DAMAGE SO --
I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW WE CAN
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THE LIVES
OF OF PEOPLE THAT.
ARE --
SUCCUMBING TO SOME OF THESE
ISSUES YOU KNOW AGAIN CHILD
SUICIDE TO CANCER --
WE CAN'T DO A WHOLE LOT ABOUT
OTHER THAN TO PROMOTE YOU KNOW
SELF BREAST EXAM AND THINGS LIKE
THAT THAT ARE.
OF COURSE --
EMBRACED BY MANY NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS BUT HOW DO WE GET
TO THE COULD THE COMMUNICABLE
DISEASE PART I MEAN AT THE THE
CONNERY AND A SURPLUS THAT IS
JUST OFF THE CHARTS.
IN MY COUNTY WHAT KIND OF A
BETTER EDUCATION PROGRAM --
DO WE NEED.
TO MAYBE NOT REINVENT I MEAN IT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE DID YOU
KNOW.
DECADES AGO BECAUSE YOU KNOW IT
WAS THIS SEEMS TO BECOMING AN
EPIDEMIC CAM IT IS AN EPIDEMIC
THAT IT'S ACTUALLY VERY
COMPLICATED AND IT WHICH IT'S
GOING TO REQUIRE SEVERAL
STRATEGIES.
THE SINGLE STRONGEST RISK FACTOR --
FOR FOR EXAMPLE FOR SYPHILIS IS
ACTUALLY METHAMPHETAMINE USE AND
SO THERE'S A WE HAVE CINDA MAKES
GOING ON AS WE LIKE TO CALL TWO
EPIDEMICS OF TWO DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT ARE ACTUALLY OR MORE
THAN TWO IN THIS CASE.
THAT ARE PERPETUATING EACH OTHER
AND SAY --
IT IN THERE AT THE SAME TIME
THERE ARE BARE AND WE'LL JUST
STICK WITH WOMEN WITH SYPHILIS
JUST IT THERE IT'S SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT DEPENDING ON WHICH
POPULATION BUT FOR EXAMPLE --
WOMEN WHO DO USE SUBSTANCES
METHAMPHETAMINE IN PARTICULAR IS
VERY COMMON IT REALLY REMOVES
INHIBITIONS WOMEN MAY --
USE SEX TO FOR PROVIDE HOUSING
TO BRIBE FOOD ETCETERA SAFETY
AND SO AT THE SAME TIME THERE
ARE --
BARRIERS TO SEEKING CARE AND IN
PARTICULAR SEEKING --
PRENATAL CARE --
THERE ARE MANY WOMEN WHO TOLD US
THAT THEY DON'T GO IN TO SEE THE
DOCTOR BECAUSE THEY'RE AFRAID OF
CHILD WELFARE SERVICES AND YOU
KNOW SO THERE'S A THERE'S A WE
NEED TO KIND OF THINK VERY
CAREFULLY ABOUT OUR APPROACH --
TO THESE WOMEN IN ORDER TO GET
THEM INTO CARE THAT IS SUPPORTED
SO THAT THEY CAN GET THE
TREATMENT WHAT'S SO FRUSTRATING
ABOUT THESE IS THAT THEY ARE
PREVENTABLE.
AND THEN OF YOU KNOW FINDING
OPPORTUNITY ONE OF THE OTHER --
REALLY SUCCESSFUL INTERVENTIONS
THEY PROVIDE CONDOMS THEY DO A
LOT OF INTERVENTION WITH FOLKS
WHERE THEY'RE OUT AND EXPLAINING
THE SITUATION TO THEM TOO SO.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS GOING
ON AND WE'RE WE'RE MODESTLY
OPTIMISTIC BUT AT HEART.
WE REALLY DO HAVE TO DEAL WITH
HOMELESSNESS SINCE THE SUBSTANCE
USE THAT THAT INCREASES
HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE SOCIAL
ISSUES ARE SO TIGHTLY TIED UP
WITH THESE --
THESE PHYSICAL HEALTH ISSUES
THAT IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT --
TO NOT ADDRESS THEM AT THE SAME
TIME AND BE SUCCESSFUL.
WELL YOU BRING UP A GOOD POINT --
YOU KNOW A WOMAN THE GOES IN
THAT TO BE TREATED AND WITH
METHAMPHETAMINE --
ISSUES SYPHILIS.
SHE'S AND SHE'S AFRAID ALL MY
GOSH I'M GOING THERE NO ONE OF
MY KIDS TAKEN AWAY BECAUSE THEY
SEE ME HAVING SOME.
RISKY LIFESTYLE ISSUES WITH --
AYE AYE WHICH WAS A WAY WE CAN.
HE'S THAT CONCERNED I DON'T KNOW
HOW WE GO ABOUT DOING THAT
BECAUSE CERTAIN MANDATED LAWS
THAT YOU HAVE TO REPORT CERTAIN
THINGS.
ALL THE OTHERS HAVE WHICH WORKS
ON OUR SIDE AS WELL SO I GRAVITY
IS.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WOMEN HAVE THE
FREEDOM TO GET IN TO GET CARE --
WITHOUT THE THE FEAR THAT
SOMEBODY'S GOING TO TAKE THEIR
KIDS AWAY AND AND AND COME AFTER
THEM SO HAPPY TO TALK FURTHER
ABOUT THAT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
GREAT PRESENTATION.
ALL THANK YOU --
AND DOES SOMEONE WITH A
BACKGROUND PUBLIC CULTIVOS
APPRECIATES --
THE PRESENTATION.
I'M ALSO THINKING THAT WHILE
YOU'RE PRESENTING THIS TO OUR
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE --
MAYBE THAT'S SOMETHING OUR
HEALTH COMMITTEE SHOULD HERE'S
WELL -- AND
SO -- THE
BUT FIRST OF ALL I JUST WANT TO
MAKE NOTE THAT --
IN A MONTH THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION OF THIS THIS
GETS DOWN TO THE SOCIAL TERMS
HEALTH IN MANY WAYS WE THINK
ABOUT THE SCOPE OF THIS BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE WHERE NOT ONLY
DEALING WITH.
PUBLIC HEALTH AND OUR HEALTHCARE
SERVICES THREE AMERICA ON SOME
OTHERS BUT WE ALSO OVERSEE THE
PARMA SOCIAL SERVICES AND SO WE
ARE AT LEAST --
FOUR WE'RE LOOKING A LOT OF THE
DIFFERENT SERVICES THE STATE
PROVIDES THAT ALSO IMPACT SOCIAL
TERM ITSELF NOW THERE'S A IT'S A
TWO CATION ENVIRONMENT SO FORTH
THAT MIKE GUY COLLEAGUES ARE
ALSO THERE ARE ALSO IMPORTANT
ELEMENTS --
YEAH WELL IT'S GREAT TO HEAR
THAT WERE ISSUE OF OF A BEING
HAS CONTINUED CONCERN IS
SOCIALLY SISTERS EVIDENCE
SHOWING THAT IT CAN BECOME A
GATEWAY.
TO SMOKING --
SO THERE'S BEEN SOME DEBATE
ABOUT.
THE BEING SEE FOR NOT SMOKING
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT WITH THE
SPECIALLY WITH USE WHO MAY BE
INTRODUCED --
TO NICOTINE BY BEATING THAT THE
MORE LIKELY TO PROGRESS AND TO
SMOKING ITSELF SO WHATEVER
COMMENTS TO MAKE ABOUT HOUSE A
FEEDING ITSELF IS IN SOME OF THE
BACK AND FORTH ON THAT --
AND THEN ACTUALLY ALSO EXPOSURE
TO MARIJUANA A THAT YOU KNOW THE
VOTERS SPOKE THERE WAS THE EAGLE
REGULATE FOR ADULTS.
BUT ALSO THERE'S BEEN
INDICATIONS THAT THE SAME BABY
DEVICES I INTRODUCED PEOPLE TH
TOBACCO CAN ALSO INTRODUCE THEM
TO CANCEL ITS.
AND THE IMPACT IT HAS ON THAT
WASN'T --
BRAINS AND SO THAT'S SOMETHING
WE'LL HAVE TO TO TO MODERN NOW
TALKING ABOUT SUBSTANCE USE
ACTUALLY WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
HEARING OF THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
SELF ALL THE SUBCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS --
AND ACTUALLY SIR STONE IS MY NOT
ONLY MY WING MAN HERE AND THIS --
SUBCOMMITTEE BUT ALSO ON THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE ACCESS TO
TREATMENT BECAUSE AS WAS
MENTIONED THAT.
YES THERE WAS A ROLL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS PLAYED IN TERMS OF
OF BIRTH POTENTIALLY OVER
PRESCRIBING --
OPIATES AND BUT IT'S NOW SHIFTED
MORE TO A THE LIST USE AND AND
FRANKLY.
WHAT WE CAN'T DO IS AS AS MUCH
AS FOR SO OF COURSE YOU WANT
FEWER PEOPLE TO TAKE BECOME
ADDICTED TO OPIOIDS AND TO TO
ENTER THAT PIPELINE --
BUT WE ALSO CAN'T A BAND THAT
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE FORTY ALREADY
THERE AND SO TO BE SURE THAT
HAVE GREATER ACCESS TO TREATMENT
AND WHAT ARE WE DOING IN THAT
REGARD SO WHY THAT'S ONLY GOING
TO BE A SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS AS LOOKING TO
ADDRESS AND IN.
THAT ISSUE AND THEN --
STDS WERE ACTUALLY HAVING A
HEARING NEXT WEEK --
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE ON THAT OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND I WOULD MAKE NO EVEN THOUGH
WE'RE NOT DEALING WITH IT TODAY
BUT I THINK THE LAST BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE I DID CHALLENGE --
YOUR DEPARTMENT TO TELL IT TO
COME BACK TO SAY WHAT KIND OF
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO REBUILD
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
IN MANY WAYS.
OUR IN OUR STATE AND COUNTIES
MADE BE SURE TO PROTECTS THAT
DIRECT SERVICES FOR MANY PEOPLE
AT GREAT NEEDS --
BUT WE HAVEN'T REALLY I THINK
RESTORED THAT INFRASTRUCTURE YET
AND THAT'S TO INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT'S NOT ONLY DEALING WITH
SOME OF THESE CHRONIC CONDITIONS
BUT ALSO WITH --
EMERGING --
DISEASES AS WELL AND WE TALK
ABOUT STDS.
I MEAN THEY'RE NOT.
BUT THE CELTIC ANY OF THEM ARE
NEW EMERGING DISEASES AT THE
MOMENT OR MULTI DRUG RESISTANT
GONORRHEA THAT'S TRUE MULTI DRUG
RESISTANT GOT AND NOT JUST THE
STANDARD GONORRHEA ANYMORE --
SO YOU KNOW WE WE NEED TO GET WE
NEED TO BE SURE WE GET THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE UP AND DEATH AND
SO CLEARLY --
THAT --
FATHER CERTAINLY MANY SOCIAL
DETERMINES ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
THE THE CLIENT AT INFRASTRUCTURE --
IS SOMETHING THAT --
CERTAINLY IS LEADING --
TO THIS GROWTH AND STDS.
THINKING ABOUT SURPLUS AND WE
THOUGHT WE BEAT THAT BACK IN THE
VICTORIAN ERA I KNOW THAT THAT'S
WHEN IT STOPPED ONLY FINALLY THE
PENICILLIN FROM THE EVENT HAS
SOMEONE THAT REALLY KILLED THOSE
BILLS PARAKEETS AND I THOUGHT WE
WERE DONE WITH THAT BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE THAT'S BACK.
LIKELY EVEN ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE WORD
THOSE THINGS AND GET CAUGHT SO
AS THERE'S THIS DEBATE ABOUT
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH ACCESS.
THAT DOES HAVE IMPLICATIONS A
SOMEONE IS ACTUALLY SPENT
SOMETIME WORKING AT STD CLINIC
AND AND TRIUMPH AND THEN --
THEY'LL INVOLVED WITH OKAY
CONTACT TRACING AND ALL THIS
OTHER ACTIVITIES PUBLIC HEALTH
ACTIVITIES.
THAT TAKE PLACE --
HILL SUICIDE MENTAL HEALTH AGAIN --
SOMETHING THAT --
WE'RE ALSO --
WE'RE HAVING ACTUALLY JUST HAD
AN OVERSIGHT HEARING ABOUT THAT
LAST WEEK WE'RE DOING PART TWO
NEXT WEEK SO --
THEIR JOINT HEALTH COMMITTEES
INCLUDE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
HEALTH COMMITTEE SO AGAIN
LOOKING AT THESE --
THESE ISSUES --
AND ALSO HOW TO IMPROVE ACCESS
TO MENTAL HEALTH FOR FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE BUT OF COURSE --
SITES NOT JUST YOUNG PEOPLE --
BUT ACROSS THE SPECTRUM I ALSO
MAKE NOTE THAT YOU MENTIONED 46%
OF CALIFORNIANS ARE PRE DIABETIC.
I I WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT
WHEN YOU'RE QUOTING SOME YEAH I
A SAID WHAT WE HAVE THE NUMBERS
I JUST DIDN'T WANT TO GET TO
KNOW I I GOT IT BUT YEAH YEAH
BUT I SAW A BIG NOTE FOR EXAMPLE --
THE SCREENING FOR ATI IT
ACTUALLY IT IS AT A LOW RUBIO BY.
THAN IT IS FOR THE GENERAL
POPULATION BECAUSE WE TEND TO
HIGH WE TEND TO HIGHER FAT
BETTER I GUESS.
AND SO BUT THE PEOPLE NEED TO
KNOW THAT RIGHT SO SOMETIMES
THAT GETS UNDERESTIMATE BECAUSE
CLINICIANS ARE USING DIFFERENT
BMI A LOWER BMI FOR THE API
COMMUNITY --
BUT AS YOU MENTIONED ONE FOURTH
OF THESE PRE DIABETICS WE DON'T
DO ANYTHING WILL ADVANCE THE
DIABETES AND THAT'S TREMENDOUS
WE WILL EVENTUALLY GET THAT THE
PART HEALTHCARE SERVICES AMERICA
I MEAN THAT'S A TREMENDOUS
FUTURE COST.
AND IN FACT LAST YEAR I THINK
WAS LAST YEAR WE STARTED PUSHING
FOR THE PILOT FUNDINGBUT I
THINK WE NEED TO THINK MORE
BROADLY ABOUT THE BRING IT TO
SCALE.
IT READ JUST LIKE THE DIABETES
PREVENTION PROGRAMS --
THAT'S AN INTERVENTION THAT'S
BEEN VERY WELL EVALUATED SO IT'S
NOT JUST LIKE I THINK THIS IS
GOING TO HELP IT'S BEEN
EVALUATED UP YEAH YO RANDOMIZED
CONTROL STUDIES.
SHOWS REDUCE THE MOVEMENT FROM
PRE DAVIES DIABETES ABOUT ALMOST
BY HALF ABOUT FORTY A THINK 47%
IS FOR SIX OBSERVERS THAT.
VERY SUCCESSFUL.
SO WE WERE TALKING ABOUT 46% A
QUARTER THOSE WE DON'T DO
ANYTHING SO THAT'S NOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW 1112% OF
THOSE PEOPLE BECOMING OF THE
WHOLE POPULATION BEGIN DIABETIC.
THE FACT THAT WE CAN CUT THAT
FROM THAT TO MAYBE DOWN THE FIVE
OR 6% YOU KNOW WITH WE DO THIS.
THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY TO SEE A
LOT OF NIGHTS OUT BUT IT DOES
REQUIRE SOME FUNNY UP FRONT SO
WE REALLY DO NEED TO THINK ABOUT
THOSE KIND OF VESTMENTS AS WE'RE
TALKING.
TO OTHER AGENCIES AS WELL AS
YOU'RE PRESENTING THE DATA
SAYING WHAT CAN WE DO.
THAT OBVIOUSLY IS NOT JUST THE
MONEY IT'S THE LIFE DIABETES IS
THAT WILL MANAGE TO THE THIS
EYESIGHT ILLUSION LIMBS.
ETCETERA --
AND THEN OF COURSE SO --
SO THERE CERTAINLY SO MUCH MORE
TO DO AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE THE PRESENTATION --
BUT ALSO YOU KNOW WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT WE NEED TO DO
TO STRENGTHEN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE --
SO AND ALSO DATA COLLECTION SO
WE ARE WHERE THAT'S HOW WE KNOW
WHERE WE'RE GOING AND ALSO
WHETHER MAKING A DIFFERENCE
RIGHT ANYTHING ANY TYPE OF AND
WE'LL PUT MONEY AND I'VE FOUND
SOME OTHER FOLKS ARE EARLIER
WILL GET THAT MONEY IN SOMETHING
WHAT WE CAN EXPECT THE RESULT.
FROM THAT.
THE WELL CELL.
OKAY SO WELL WE'LL JUST MOVE
MAYBE ON TO SELL ITS TERMS OF
THE OVERALL BUDGET PART --
I JUST -- I
ALWAYS LIKE TO KEEP ALWAYS LIKE
TO MAKE NOTE THAT --
THE BUDGET FOR THE PART PUBLIC
HEALTH IT'S IT'S ABOUT.
INOUTS THREE AT A FOUND THE
THREE BILLION DOLLARS RATE.
JUST ABOUT LITTLE BIT OF JUST
ABOUT.
THAT ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT THE
GENERAL FUND.
OF THE BUDGET BOTH PROPOSES ONLY
A HUNDRED EIGHTY THREE MILLION
CELLS VAST MAJORITY OF THIS
COMES FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FROM --
ALSO -- A
SPECIAL FUNDS AND THE SO --
AS WE LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENS IN DC
AND FUNDING FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
AGENCIES THAT HAS A DIRECT
IMPACT ON THE PUBLIC HEALTH HERE
IN CALIFORNIA SINCE THAT'S WHERE
MOST OF THOSE RESOURCESCOME
FROM.
BUT OF COURSE WE ALSO WON'T BE
SURE WE'RE PROVIDING SUFFICIENT
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT FOR THOSE
CORE FUNCTIONS THAT --
ARE NOT FUNDED BY ABOUT WHETHER
IT'S THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR
FROM OUR SPECIAL FUNDS AS WELL.
SO I JUST WANT.
TO MAKE ALWAYS MAKE MENTION OF
THAT BECAUSE PEOPLE LOOK AT THAT
THREE BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET --
SO -- WITH
THAT -- DO
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER SURF COMMENTS
ON THE SERVE THE OVERALL BUDGET
A REVIEW.
BAILEY OKAY LA --
COMMENTS ON THE OVER OF PUBLIC
HEALTH BUDGET FINANCE NOW.
MORE MONEY.
OKAY IT ALL RIGHT.
OKAY WE JUST THOUGHT IT WAS
GREAT ALL THESE PROBLEMS ALL
RIGHT --
OKAY --
RIGHT NOW I KNOW THAT --
YEAH WE HAVE IT AND WE DO HAVE
IN THE DESCRIPTION IN ADDITION
TO THE STATE OF PUBLIC HEALTH
THE OF THE SEVEN SEVEN MAJOR
PROGRAM AREAS SO FOR PEOPLE WANT
TO READ O THEIR OUT.
OKAY SO WITH THAT --
WILL GO AHEAD AND TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE STATE OF THE
STATE OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
OF REVIEW IF THERE'S PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THAT WELCOME.
HEY MICHELLE GIVENS AT THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND FIRST AND FOREMOST JUST
WANTED THINK DOCTOR SMITH FOR
HER AT FORMAT THAT IT WAS AND
HOW IT HIGHLIGHTED SOME OF THE
REALLY TROUBLING --
ISSUES THAT WE'RE FACING IN OUR
STATE I MEAN NOT TO BELABOR THE
POINT BUT DO WANNA ECHO YOUR
SENTIMENTS AROUND THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE AND THERE
HAVE BEEN A LOT OF STRIDES MADE --
IN TOBACCO FOR EXAMPLE BUT
THERE'S ALSO BEEN A LOT OF
FUNDING --
PROVIDED FOR TOBACCO AND WE KNOW
YOU KNOW FROM THE LOCAL LEVEL
WHAT TYPES OF INVESTMENTS ARE
HELPFUL WE KNOW HOW DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES.
AND TO ADDRESS THINGS LIKE
CHRONIC DISEASES AND STDS AND SO
FORTH BUT ALSO OFTEN AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THE FUNDING IS
REALLY CONSTRAINTS WE APPRECIATE
YOUR ATTENTION TO THAT --
AND THEN IN TERMS OF CHRONIC
DISEASES I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
WE DON'T REALLY HAVE A
SUSTAINABLE SOURCE OF FUNDING
FOR CHRONIC DISEASE IN OUR STATE.
AND SO OFTEN TIMES AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL ARE PIECING TOGETHER A LOT
OF THE GRANT FUNDING **** OR
DIFFERENT POCKETS OF THE FEDERAL
FUNDS -- BUT
THERE'S NOT A COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH TO THATAND WE MADE
HUGE STRIDES ON THE HEALTHCARE
SIDE -- BUT
WE REALLY THINK THAT NOW IS THE
TIME TO TO START FOCUSING ON
PREVENTION AND HOW WE CAN AVOID
SOME OF THE COSTS DOWN THE ROAD
TO THIS.
OKAY THANK YOU ANDI WOULD ALSO
JUST MAKE NOTE HOW IMPORTANT ARE
COUNTY --
HEALTH OFFICERS AND COUNTY
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE JUST NOT
SOMETHING THAT IS JUST DONE AT
THE STATE I MEAN WITHOUT THE
COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND
HEALTH OFFICERS SO WE WOULD NOT
BE ABLE --
TO MAKE ANY OF THIS HAPPEN I
WOULD ALSO JUST --
PERHAPS IF NEGLECTED TO MAKE
NOTE I NOTICED HERE THAT --
SO CERTAINLY THE OPIOID CRISIS
IS A THAT IS AND WE NEED TO
ADDRESS BUT ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT
MORE PEOPLE DIED LAST YEAR FROM
INFLUENZA.
THEN DIED OF OPIOID OVERDOSE
DOESN'T MEAN THAT OPIATE
OVERDOSE IS ANY LESS IMPORTANT --
BUT WEEKS OR SOME VERY BASIC
THINGS WE CAN DO LIKE IT PEOPLE
VACCINATED.
AND SAVE LIVES SO --
DOWN OF A THINK ABOUT THE NUMBER
PEOPLE DIED OF INFLUENZA LAST
YEAR -- AND
OTHER TYPES OF DISEASES AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN MAKE THEM A
DISTANT MEMORY SO WITH THAT --
LET'S GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO
ISSUES SO WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND GO THROUGH ISSUES TWO
THROUGH THIRTEEN AND THEN WE'LL
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS --%
AFTER THAT ON ON THOSE.
ALRIGHT SO SIR WITH ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO IF YOU CAN INTRODUCE
YOURSELF FOR THE RECORD.
CENTER FOR HEALTH STATISTICS
INFORMATICS CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH.
ISSUE TO IMPROVING VITAL RECORDS
INTER OPERABILITY IN DATA
QUALITY.
DPH REQUEST THREE POSITIONS AND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FROM THE
HEALTH STATISTICS SPECIAL FUN.
OF ONE POINT TWO MILLION IN
NINETEEN TWENTY AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ONE POINT THREE
MILLION IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION IN.
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AND
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER.
IF APPROVED THESE RESOURCES
ALLOW DPH TO RENEW AND MODIFYING
AGREEMENT WITH UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA DAVIS. FOR VITAL
RECORDS SYSTEM ENHANCEMENTS IN
OPERATIONS.
AND A SHIFT ACTIVITIES PERFORMED
BY THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SANTA BARBARA. TO DEPARTMENT
STAFF.
MAKE INCLUDES OUR OVERVIEW ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU M. [inaudible]
COLLEGE MILIEU.
FINANCE.
ALL RIGHT IN SINCE OF DELAWARE
SO IN TERMS OF THIS
CONSOLIDATION OF WE ALSO HOPE TO
EXPECT --
GREATER EFFICIENCIES AND BETTER
CUT AND CUSTOMER SENATE AS AN
EXAMPLE CONCRETE LANE --
AS YOU KNOW WE'VE MOVED FROM THE
LEGACY AUTOMATED VITAL
STATISTICS BIRTH REGISTRATION
SYSTEM.
CURRENTLY UNDER WAY TO THE
ELECTRONIC BIRTH REGISTRATION
SYSTEM.
AND WE HAVE REDUCE THE TIME FROM
BIRTH EVENTS TO STICK
REGISTRATION FROM APPROXIMATELY
SIX WEEKS.
APPROXIMATELY SIX DAYS EXCELLENT.
ALL RIGHT WONDERFUL OKAY.
I THINK WITH THAT --
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON THE ISSUE
NUMBER.
THREE GAMBLING DISORDER TRAINING
EDUCATION SERVICES AND WE JUST --
THIS MORNING AND OUR FLOOR
RECOGNIZED MARCHES A PROBLEM
GAMBLING MONTH.
THANK YOU AND PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELVES --
FOR THE RECORD [inaudible] THREE
MILLION.
GOOD MORNING --
MY NAME IS MONICA MORALIS I'M
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CENTER FOR HEALTHY COMMUNITIES.
OUR TEAM HERE IS ACTUALLY GOING
TO PRESENT TO YOU ON ITEMS THREE
THROUGH SEVEN SO YOU HAVE A
CELEB HERE OKAY ONE CHIU EACH
INTRODUCE YOURSELVES AND THEN
THAT AND THEN WILL.
WE WILL HAVE TO DO IT AGAIN WITH
EACH ITEM.
THAT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS TERRY
SEE CAN ALLEY DAHLE MAN I'M AN
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH
THE CENTER FOR HEALTHY
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING A DATE DENTICLE
MARSHAWN WITH THE A CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICE ORDER.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO
LET'S GO LET'S MOVE ON THE
ADDITION OF A THREE OKAY SO ED
CHAIR AND AM STAFF WHO EVERYBODY
WHO'S LEFT RIGHT.
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR RESOLUTION THIS MORNING
AND WE'RE VERY PROUD TO CONTINUE
THAT --
PROBLEM GAMBLING AWARENESS MONTH
AND THAT IN THE MONTH OF MARCH
REQUESTING THREE POSITIONS TO
CONDUCT A PUBLIC OUTREACH FOR
CAN'T GAMBLING DISORDER
PREVENTION.
THE POSITIONS WILL BE FUNDED BY
REDIRECTING INDIAN GAMING
SPECIAL DISTRIBUTION FIND
RESOURCES FROM AN EXPIRING
CONTRACT THE CURRENT CONTRACT IS
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY.
AND IS DUE TO EXPIRE JUNE
THIRTIETH.
TWENTY NINETEEN OUR OFFICE A
PROBLEM GAMING IS MANDATED TO
PROVIDE THEM [inaudible]
TRAINING.
ABOUT GAMBLING DISORDER
PREVENTION WHICH INCLUDES TWO
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS
EDUCATORS NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE
IDENTIFICATION OF PROBLEM
GAMBLING BEHAVIOR AND THE
KNOWLEDGE OF REFERRAL SERVICES
FOR PROBLEM GAMBLING DISORDER.
AND ALSO FOR TREATMENT PROGRAMS.
AT THE TOP TIME OF OPG TH AND
SAM SHANE OUR OFFICE A PROBLEM
GIVE ME THAT SECTION. TWO
THOUSAND THREE A LACK OF
RESOURCES AND SPECIALIZED
EXPERTISE WITHIN OUR STAFF.
HAD S. EXECUTE THAT TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CONTRACT TO
CARRY OUT OUR MANDATE.
THAT THREE POSITIONS WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR TRAINING AND
OUTREACH TO THE HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND EDUCATORS
EDUCATORS AN INCREASE TO ALSO
TRAINING LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THIS APPLE
PROVIDE ON SITE TRAINING AND
OUTREACH WITHIN COMMUNITY
AGENCIES AND AT COMMUNITY EVENTS.
IN ADDITION OUR STAFF WILL
DEVELOP AM NEW RESOURCES SUCH AS
WORK BOOKS VIDEOS ONLINE
RETRAINING OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE
TRAINING MORE AVAILABLE TO MORE
INDIVIDUALS.
WE'VE BUILT A STRONG STE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN OFFICE OF
PROBLEM GAMBLING WITH ACQUIRED
EXPERTISE OVER THE PAST FIFTEEN
YEARS AND WE'RE NOW CAPABLE OF
PROVIDING A HIGHER QUALITY
TRAINING AND EDUCATION SERVICES
THAN OUR CONTRACTOR IS.
WHAT CREATING SEE CIVIL SERVICE
POSITIONS TO CARRY OUT THAT
WORKLOAD WE PLAN TO RECRUIT
BILINGUAL STAFF WHO ARE WILLING
TO TRAVEL THROUGHOUT THE STATE
SO THAT WE CAN REACH THE MOST
RURAL AREAS THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE STATE?
TRANSFERRING THE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING PROGRAM TO COMBINE OUR
EFFORTS WITH OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH
PROGRAMS AND ALIGN WITH THE
CENTER FOR HEALTHY COMMUNITIES
VISION FOR HEALTHY COMMUNITIES
AND SAFE ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU A COMPASS FAMILIAL.
FINANCE.
RIGHT -- SO --
IT IN TERMS OF IT'S OF GREAT
DATE YOU BRING THIS IN HOUSE WE
CAN BETTER COORDINATE NAY
APPRECIATE THAT --
DESIGN FINANCIAL ACTUALLY
THERE'S THERE THIS MORNING WAS
THERE -- IN
TERMS OF THE API COMMUNITIES --
THE DEATH SIX ME THAT TAKE IS
THE PERHAPS --
DISPROPORTIONATELY SUFFERS FROM
PROBLEM GAMBLING --
THE DEEDS.
AND IN THIS THE PART IN YOUR
OFFICE DO YOU SEE SOME
PARTICULAR ACTIVITIES TO HELP
TARGET THE A EFFORT TO HELP THE
API COMMUNITY REGARD TO THIS
ISSUE.
YEAH ABSOLUTELY WE WE HAVE THEM
ALREADY THEM SEVER RESOURCES WE
M. PROVIDE ALL OF OUR RESOURCES
IN NUMEROUS DIFFERENT LANGUAGES
OUR FREEDOM FROM PROBLEM
GAMBLING HELP BOOK IS IN TWENTY
ONE DIFFERENT LANGUAGES.
AM VERY SPECIFIC TO THE API
OUTRAGE TO M. TO API AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS COMMUNITY
RESOURCES A. R. I. HERE IN
SACRAMENTO ECT. TO SET AT
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE
WE'VE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMUNITY BECAUSE WE'VE WE FEEL
THE SAME WAY EVEN THOUGH OUR
PREVALENCE STUDY DIDN'T SAY THAT
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIX ASIAN
POPULATION WAS UNDER REPRESENTED
IN THAT STUDY SO WE DO.
AND RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR
OUTREACH AND I AM RIGHT NOW WE
OFFER IT AND THE SECOND M.
HIGHEST NO THIRD HIGHEST
LANGUAGE FOR TRAINING SERVICES
IS --
CHINESE BOTH MANDARIN AND
CANTONESE.
THANK YOU YOU JUST LOOK AT THE
BILLBOARDS --
YOU YOU KNOW WHO THEY'RE GOING
AFTER.
HER.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT LET'S
GO HEAD TO MOVE THEN ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER.
FOUR ORAL HEALTH PROGRAM UPDATE
AND POSITION REQUEST.
THANK YOU SOME AND I'M GOINGTO
GIVE AN OVERVIEW OF THE OREGON
PROGRAM AND THEN --
ANSWERS SPECIFIC QUESTIONS --
THE THE ORAL HEALTH PROGRAM IS
IN THE PROCESS OF IMPLEMENTING A
STATE WIDE PROGRAM BASED ON THE
CHRONIC DISEASE PREVENTION
FRAMEWORK DEVELOPED BY ANY --
CCLI CHIU AND CHIA IMPLEMENT
DISTRICT STRATEGIES RECOMMENDED
IN THE PLAN.
THE PROGRAM PROVIDES STRATEGIC
ADVISOR LEADERSHIP TO
STAKEHOLDERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE BILLS OR ACCOUNT WORKFORCE
CAPACITY AND IMPLEMENTING A
VALUE IS BEST PRACTICES IN ORDER
DISEASE PREVENTION.
THE OUR HOUSE IN THE CENTER OF A
COMMUNITY.
HEALTH THE COMMUNITIES AS AN
OFFICE.
OF WE COLLABORATE WAY THROUGH
VARIOUS PROGRAMS INCLUDING THE
MEDICAID ALL DENTAL PROGRAM AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
AS WELL AS MEN.
THE PROGRAM SUPPORTS SEVERAL IN
THE TO INITIATE TENS.
OF ONE IS LOCAL ORAL HEALTH
PROGRAM SPORT --
FOR FIFTY NINE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS.
EMBEDDED WITHIN THE LOCAL OR
FUND PROGRAMS ON INITIATIVES TO
EXPAND INTERVENTIONS IN SCHOOLS.
INCLUDING THE PROMOTION OF THE
KINDERGARTEN ORAL HEALTH
ASSESSMENT REQUIREMENT POLICY.
OTHER PROGRAM INITIATIVES
INCLUDE SURVEILLANCE AND
EVALUATION HELP LEAD TO SEE
PENDING NATO IN PRINT FOR
ACCOUNT QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
PILOT PROJECT.
ORAL HEALTH WORKFORCE EXPANSION
TO EXPAND WHAT CHILDREN
TELEPHONE SYSTEM TO ADDITIONAL
SITES.
SELL SOME RICE HOW THE STATE IS
MEETING THE GOALS IDENTIFIED IN
ORDER HEALTH PLAN [inaudible]
THE PROP FIFTY SIX FUNDING IS
ALIGNED WITH THE ORAL HEALTH PRO
PLAN GOALS TO MAKE PROGRESS
TOWARDS ACHIEVING SEVERAL
OBJECTIVES.
LOCAL ORAL HEALTH LOCAL HOW
JURISDICTIONS ARE UTILIZING THE
FUNDS TO SUPPORT GOAL THE ONE BY
DEVELOPING ORAL HEALTH
IMPROVEMENT PLANS AND ENGAGING
THE COMMUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
DOMINANCE OF ORAL HEALTH AND
PROMOTE HEALTHY HABITS.
THERE ALSO EXPLORING WAYS TO
EXPAND POPULATION BASED
PREVENTION INTERVENTIONS LIKE
COMMUNITY WATER FLUORIDATION.
THE SECOND GOAL IS TO INCREASE
UTILIZATION OF DENTAL SERVICES.
WEARE WORKING WITH THE MEDI CAL
DENTAL PROGRAM ON THE DENTAL
TRANSFORMATION INITIATIVE AND
THE SMILE CALIFORNIA CAMPING.
WE HAVE INCLUDED THE PROMOTION
OF KINDERGARTEN ORAL HEALTH
ASSESSMENT AND ACTIVITIES OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S DENTAL
DISEASE PREVENTION PROGRAM.
AS KEY OBJECTIVES IN THE LOCAL
OR HELD JURISDICTION GRANT
PROGRAM [inaudible]
IN ADDITION.
WE WOULD LIKE TO INCREASE DENTAL
VISIT RATES AMONG OLDER ADULTS
PEOPLE WITH DIABETES PREGNANT
WOMEN.
AND OTHER VULNERABLE ADULT
POPULATION GROUPS.
THIS IS BY SUPPORTING
DEMONSTRATION PROGRAMS WE HAVE
NOT YET INITIATED THE
PROCUREMENTS --
TO INITIATE THESE PRODUCTS. TO
EXPAND THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CAPACITY TO PROMOTE PREVENTION
WHICH IS OUR THIRD GOAL.
WE ARE PROVIDING GRANTS SUPPORT
TO LOCAL HOW JURISDICTIONS.
FIFTY EIGHT LOCAL HOW
JURISDICTIONS AND ONE FIRST FIVE
ORGANIZATION OUT OF SIXTY ONE
HAVE SIGNED AGREEMENTS.
THEY ARE IN VARIOUS STAGES OF
HIDING STAFF AND CONSULTANTS
CONDUCTING NEEDS ASSESSMENT
DEVELOPING CLIENTS AND PINE
INTERVENTIONS.
IN ADDITION WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO IMPLEMENT THE LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAM FOR DENTISTS.
WITH RESPECT TO GOAL FOR WHICH
IS FOCUSED ON COMMUNICATION
STRATEGIES WE HAVE INITIATED A
CONTRACTOR ENHANCE COMMUNICATION
IN DENTAL SETTINGS.
THIS IS --
DESIGNED TO PROMOTE THE USE OF
PLAIN LANGUAGE OF VISUALS AND
DRAWINGS AND THE TEACH BACK
METHOD IN DENTAL SETTINGS.
THE FIFTY GOAL IS PUBLIC HEALTH
SURVEILLANCE WE HAVE MADE
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS BY
SUPPORTING SEVERAL STATEWIDE
SURVEYS.
CURRENTLY BE OUT IN THE FIELD
CONDUCTING A SURVEY OF THIRD
GRADE CHILDREN.
WHICH IS THE NATIONAL INDEX
GRADE FOR TRACKING DOWN DISEASE
IN CHILDREN FOR ESTIMATING THE
PREVALENCE OF DENTAL DISEASE.
THIS IS A LARGE SCALE EFFORT
INVOLVING ABOUT TEN THOUSAND
CHILDREN DRAWN FROM MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED SCHOOLS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
SAID THE SERVICE WILL PROVIDE A
BETTER PICTURE FOR A HEALTH RISK
FACTORS USE OF PREVENTIVE
SERVICES AND TREATMENTS. FOR NOW
I'M GOING TO DESCRIBE --
GIVE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE%
REQUESTS FOR POSITIONS A CITY
PATCHES A QUOTE.
QUESTING SEVEN POSITIONS THIS
INCLUDES ONE A A HABIT SO SHE
HAD COME PROGRAM ADVISORS. TO
ASSOCIATE GOVERNMENTAL PROGRAM
ANALYSTS ONE HEALTH PROGRAM
SPECIALIST IN ONE PROGRAM
SPECIALIST.
THESE STAFF MEMBERS WILL
COMPRISE OF FIVE TEAMS. TO WORK
WITH.
LOCAL HELL JURISDICTIONS AND
CONTRACTORS TO VALUE IT
APPLICATIONS DEVELOP.
WORK PLANTS AND NEGOTIATE OF ART
AND MONITOR CONTRACTS.
WE'RE REQUESTING ONE RESEARCH
SCIENTIST SUPERVISOR POSITIONS
WILL PROVIDE LEADERSHIP WITH A
LEADERSHIP TO THE SURVEILLANCE
AND EVALUATION SECTION.
AND ALSO WILL HELP US TO PROCURE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECT --
CONTRACT SPENT TO IMPLEMENT
SURVEILLANCE AND EVALUATION
ACTIVITIES.
BUT ALSO REQUESTING ONE HEALTH
EDUCATION CONSULTANT TO HELP
CREATE A CLEARING FOR
EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS AND
DEVELOPING TRAININGS.
AND ALSO TO WORK WAIT THE
NATIONAL AND STATE WIDE
ORGANIZATIONS.
NOW I'MGOING TO DESCRIBE OUR
RESPONSE TO THE DECLINING
REVENUE FROM PROPOSITION.
FIFTY SIX WE HAVE ADVISED THE
LOCAL HAS JURISDICTIONS TO THINK
ABOUT.
REVENUE STREAMS AND DEVELOPING
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS.
THIS INCLUDES EXPLORING THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OBTAINING
FEDERAL MEDICAID MATCHING
DOLLARS.
BUT ALSO MAKING ADJUSTMENTS TO
OUR PROGRAM COMPONENTS IN THE
AREA OF SURVEILLANCE AND
EVALUATION HEALTH CLICK TO SEE.
FUNDING FOR DEMONSTRATION
PROGRAMS AND SUPPORT FOR
COMMUNITY WATER FLUORIDATION AND
SCHOOL BASED PROGRAMS.
OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS WILL BE
DISCUSSING THE PROGRESS WITHOUT
ADVISORY COMMITTEE REGARDING.
WHAT HAS WORKED AND AS NOT TO
WORK?
AND WE LOOKED IN FOR THEIR INPUT
DEVICE OF AN EXPENDITURE PLAN.
WE CAN ADJUSTTHE FREQUENCY OF
THE SURVEYS THAT WE ARE
CURRENTLY CONDUCTING.
AND ALSO --
THE FREQUENCY OF REPORTING
SERVICE.
THE HAVE DECIDED TO FOCUS THE
HEALTH LITERACY EFFORTS ON THE
PROVIDERS.
AND WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES ON THE SMOKE
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN.
THAT IS TARGETED TOWARDS THE
PUBLIC.
WITH RESPECT TO COMMUNITY WATER
FLUORIDATION WITH PRIORITIZE
EXISTING WATER SYSTEMS REQUIRING
EQUIPMENT UPGRADE.
AND SYSTEMS THAT HAVE THE
NECESSARY APPROVALS TO MOVE
FORWARD.
WITH RESPECT TO INTERVENTIONS IN
SCHOOLS.
I MADE A PRIORITY THAT ALL.
LOCAL HOW JURISDICTION SHOULD
ENCOURAGE KINDERGARTEN CHILDREN
TO SEE EVEN ASSESSMENT BEFORE
ENTERING FIRST GRADE.
OUR GOAL IS.
TO DELIVER HELD THE CHILDREN TO
SCHOOLS --
BY PROMOTING THE KINDERGARTEN OR
HOW TO SUSMAN POLICY THAT HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO LINK A LARGE
PROPORTION OF CHILDREN TO SOURCE
OF DENTAL CARE AND ESTABLISH A
DENTAL FONG.
THE SAN FRANCISCO DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH HAS PARTNERED WITH
DISSENT SENTENCES GO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND A LOCAL DOWN
SOCIETY TO SCREEN.
ALL FOUR THOUSAND CHILDREN AND
LINK THE SCREEN SCHOOL SCREENING
TO TEN ESSENTIAL PUBLIC HEALTH
SERVICES.
THE SAYS IMPROVE THE ORAL HEALTH
OF KINDERGARTEN CHILDREN AS
EVIDENCED BY THE DECLINE IN THE
PREVALENCE OF TOOTH DECAY FROM
ABOUT 60% IN TWO THOUSAND ONE TO
ABOUT 32% IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SAN
FRANCISCO FOCUSED THEIR EFFORTS
ON ONE TWO FIVE YEAR OLD
CHILDREN TO BRING ABOUT THIS
CHANGE.
THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
RECOMMENDS TARGETING URBAN
SCHOOLS WITH GREATER THAN 50%
PARTICIPATION IN PRE INDEED USE
LUNCH PROGRAM ALL GREW TO
SCHOOLS FOR OUR PREVENTIVE
PROGRAMS.
THERE ARE MORE THAN FOUR
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS THAT MEET
THESE CRITERIA IN CALIFORNIA.
AND MANY SCHOOLS ALREADY HAVE
PROGRAMS.
WE HAVE INTERVIEWED MANY
PROGRAMS OPERATED BY COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS FOR THE
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTERS.
LOCAL HOW DEPARTMENTS DENTISTS
AND DENTAL HYGIENISTS TO
UNDERSTAND THAT MODEL REVENUE
STREAMS AND CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITIES.
SO IF YOU'RE PLANNING TO BRING
THESE PROGRAMS TOGETHER AND
CREATE A LEARNING COMMUNITY.
CURRENTLY LOCAL HOW
JURISDICTIONS ARE IDENTIFYING
EXISTING PROGRAMS AND GAPS IN
INTERVENTIONS IN SCHOOLS.
ASSESSING THE BIT BILLING THIS
OF SCHOOLS TO PARTICIPATE.
AND THE DIRECT ESTIMATING THAT
EQUIPMENT NEEDS AND IDENTIFYING
PROVIDERS HO ARE INTERESTED IN
PROVIDING SERVICES AND SCHOOLS.
SO THE GREATEST NEED.
NOW IS TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO DEVELOP
SUSTAINABLE MODELS.
THAT CAN SUIT INDIVIDUAL NEEDS
OF SCHOOLS.
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE USE UCSF
DOWN SCHOOL TO PROVIDE RESOURCES
AND TRAINING TO LOCAL HEALTH
PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALCHEMIST FAMILIAL
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
ALRIGHT SO APPRECIATE --
VALUE PRESENTATION AS VERY
THOROUGH --
THE THE TERMS OF THE PROP FIFTY
SIX REVENUE DECLINING --
I MEAN THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I
THINK --
MANY ORGANIZATIONS ARE FINANCED
THROUGH --
TO BACK REVENUES HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THOUSAND FIRST FIVE
COMMISSION SACRAMENTO --
BILL WE WE WHAT WE TRIED TO DO
IS HOW WE WOULD DO SUSTAIN LACY
OF AND NOT UNUSUAL WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH STATE BUDGET TO WRITE
SO THINK ABOUT ONE TIME
EXPENDITURES FOR EXAMPLE
FLIRTATION EQUIPMENT WOULD BE.
ONE I ONE TIME RIGHT THAT THE
CITY OR WHATEVER AGENCY WOULD.
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN THE
EQUIPMENT --
THEN YOU HAVE JOHN GOING
PROGRAMS AND IS THERE SOME
THOUGHT ABOUT THAT.
IN TERMS OF PROJECTING OUT TO
THE FUTURE GIVEN THE THE AND WE
WANT FEWER PEOPLE SMOKE SCIENCE
A GOOD THING RIGHT I MEAN IT'S
THAT THE MONEY IS NICE BUT
ULTIMATELY THE MAIN GOAL IS TO
GET FEWER PEOPLE SMOKE --
AT THAT --
IN TERMS OF BEING OUT SUSTAIN
CERTAIN PROGRAMS OVER A PERIOD
OF TIME THAT YOU IS THAT YOU
WOULD BUILD UP LIFT SAMPLE.
BUILD A LITTLE BIT RESERVE THAT
COULD EVEL THINGS OUT OVER TIME
INSTEAD OF IS PUSHING IT ALL OUT
AND THEN HAVING TO CUT CUT CUT --
SO I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S SOME
DISCUSSION AS TO AS YOUR
STRATEGIZING AYE YOUR VARIOUS
ACTIVITIES THAT THE AND LOOKING
FINE IT'S A LITTLE BIT TOO
BECAUSE YOU KNOW YOU NEED TO BE
PART OF THAT KIND OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT OKAY THIS IS IT DOES WALL
HOW WE'RE TRYING TO DO.
IT IN A WAY THAT.
MEETS THE GOALS OF WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH SO SURE
THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO SUSTAIN THE
EFFORTS RIGHT THAT YOU'RE
PUTTING OUT AS YOU'RE WORKING
WITH YOUR VARIOUS COMMUNITY
PARTNERS AND LOCAL PARTNERS AS
WELL.
EXHAUSTION HERE FROM YOUR NON
PROFITS WHAT THE FILM ACTUALLY
SERVER USEFUL AT MY IT GOES UP
AND DOWN AND UP AND DOWN RIGHT
THAT THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO DO
A SUSTAINED EFFORT THEY HAVE TO
MAINTAIN THEIR OWN WORK FORCE AT
CETERA SO.
IT'S IT'S THAT SOME OF THE AS
STEP AND FOR SOME OF THE
DISCUSSION WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
ABOUT --
SOME OF THIS --
COMES RELATED TO THE PROP FIFTY
SIX REVENUE.
WE HAVE FLORA SOME FLEXIBILITY
IN THE STATE OPERATIONS BUDGET
BECAUSE THE COMPONENTS LIKE THE
SEVEN SURVEILLANCE DEVALUATION
HELP THE TO SEE CAMPAIGN AND
EVEN THE DEMONSTRATION PROGRAMS.
WE HAVE SPELL SOME FLEXIBILITY
TO IN A STRETCH IT OVER A PERIOD
OF YEARS OKAY AND THE FUNDING --
FAR COMMUNITY WATER FLUORIDATION
AND EVEN SCHOOL BASED PROGRAM
CAN BE ONE TIME --
SO THAT CAN BE PLANNED IT WELL
IN ADVANCE.
AND IT RIGHT NOW WE HAVE SOME ON
OBLIGATED FUNDS THAT WE CAN USE --
TO SUPPORT THE DECLINING REVENUE
AND PROFIT TO SIX UNDERSTAND
YOU'RE LOOKING AT OTHER ALSO
OTHER POTENTIAL OTHER PRETENDING
THAT'S RIGHT COULD LEVERAGE TO
TO MAKE UP FOR AS WELL OKAY.
RIGHT EXCELLENT OKAY.
I THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WILL MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER.
FIVE ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE PROGRAM
GRANT AWARDS AND GOVERNOR'S TASK
FORCE ON BRAIN HEALTH.
OKAY FOR THE RECORD AGAIN MONICA
MORALIS --
SO THIS REQUEST IS IS AN
INCREASE OF THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE GENERAL FUND AND
THIS IS TO SUPPORT. TWO POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS A LOCAL
ASSISTANCE AND THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND STATE
OPERATIONS.
THE TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION WILL
SUPPORT GRANTS THAT FOCUS ON
WOMEN IN COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
AND A THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR SUPPORT TO PUT.
MONITOR AND EVALUATE THE GRANT
PROGRESS IN ADDITION IT WILL
SUPPORT IMPLEMENTATION IN OVER.
SKEWS ME AND THE ADMINISTRATIVE
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S TASK
FORCE ON ALZHEIMER'S PREVENTION
AND PREPAREDNESS.
MOVING ON TO HOW WE CAN EVALUATE
THE REQUESTS --
CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
TO REALLY HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW WE WILL
SHAPE BUT THE EFFORTS PERTAINING
TO THE GRANTS.
SO -- FOR US
RIGHT NOW WE'RE STILL KIND
EXPLORING HOW WE WOULD EVALUATE
THE PROPOSALS WE HAVE SOME
MECHANISMS IN PLACE THAT WE USE
IN THE DEPARTMENT CREATING
CRITERIA USING A COMMITTEE FOR
EXAMPLE SO ALL OF THOSE WILL BE
EXPLORED WITH ADMINISTRATION AS
A GET MORE FEEDBACK FROM
STAKEHOLDERS.
THAT'S ALSO THE CASE WHEN IT
COMES TO THE COMPOSITION OF THE
TASK FORCE AS I MENTIONED DID
CHANGE ITS NAME IT WENT FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S TASK FORCE FROM.
EXCUSE ME THE GOVERNOR'S TASK
FORCE FOR ON BRAIN HEALTH TO THE
GOVERNOR'S TASK FORCE ON AL
SUMMERS PREVENTION AND
PREPAREDNESS.
SURPRISE THIS IS A REALLY GOOD
MATCH AND DESCRIBES INTENTION
THE FOCUS OF THE TASK FORCE.
AS WE LEARN A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THE NEED AT THE COMMUNITY
AND STATE LEVEL WE WILL HAVE A
BETTER SENSE OF HOW --
THE PRIORITIES IN ACTIVITIES AT
THE A TASK FORCE WILL OUTLINE
[inaudible]
FOR OKAY [inaudible]
LU.
SENATE PARTICULARLY --
AND JUST GOING TO STATE THE
OBVIOUS WHICH IS JUST THAT WITH
THE LACK OF INFORMATION ABOUT
THE TASK FORCE IT'S REALLY HARD
TO ASSESS WHETHER THE
COMPOSITION GOALS DELIVERABLES
ALIGNED WITH THE LEGISLATURE'S
PRIORITIES.
OKAY YOU SHOULD FINANCE.
AS PREVIOUSLY STATED WERE STILL
WORKING THROUGH SOME OF THOSE ON
DETAILS ON TIME LINES FOR
CONVENING SINCE STAFFING
REQUIREMENTS AND ARE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS WITH.
THE LEGISLATURE ALSO WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AS WE MOVE THROUGH
THE THE PROCESS.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
SO I WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT --
CERTAINLY THE THIS VERY ISSUE SO
WE'RE VERY THROUGH THE
GOVERNOR'S INTERESTED IN US BUT
YOU KNOW THIS IS QUITE PUT SOME
RESOURCES AND THEY HAVE A TASK
FORCE IT'S ALSO SOMETHING THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE PARTICULARLY THE
STATE SENATE HAS BEEN VERY
INTERESTED IN AS WELL SO JUST
THE A BRIEF HISTORY --
SHE LAST YEAR --
ACTUALLY HELD A AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING LOOKING AT OF WHERE
WATER TO FINANCIAL DEMANDS THIS
TIME OVERTIME WITH AN AGING
POPULATION --
YEAH WE DID --
AND SO THAT WAS A IN THAT
ACTUALLY CAME OUT OF BECAUSE OF
OF PREVIOUS BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARING --
WHERE -- IT
SEEMED TO BE --
DIDN'T SEEM TO BE AS MUCH FOR SO
AND THE LA AS HEALTH AND AND I
WAS LOOKING AT FROM THIS BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE REALLY LOOKING FOR
FINANCIAL AT THE FUTURE OF THE
JUST ACTUALLY JUST LAST MONDAY --
THE A COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SERVICES WHICH IS CHAIRED BY A
CENTER HER TADO WHO SITS ON THE
SUBCOMMITTEE HELD A HEARING ON
AT EIGHT AGING AS WELL SERVICES --
FOR AGING WHICH I KNOW THIS IS
MORE ABOUT THE ALZHEIMER'S BY ME
CLEARLY ENCOMPASSES THAT ISSUE --
SO I KNOW AND MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES ARE CARRYING BILLS
INCLUDING MYSELF --
WE ACTUALLY WORKING WITH THE THE
SORCERERS DIRECTORS --
AROUND WHAT WHAT KIND OF
PROGRAMS A TASK FORCE TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT CAP PROGRAMS WE NEED
FOR FOR ADULTS WITH LIKE WITH
THE COGNITIVE.
DISABILITIES ACTION ALZHEIMER'S --
BECAUSE THE WAY WE HAVE THINK
STRUCTURED.
THE DATE TURF REALLY FIT AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT LONG TERM CARE
EXPENSES AND HOW WE'RE GOING TO
HELP PROVIDE LONG TERM CARE
SUPPORTS.
SO IS -- YOU
KNOW CERTAINLY AS THE
ADMINISTRATION AND FURTHER
DEVELOPS THE TASK FORCE AND SO
FORTH I THINK THERE'S A WE GET A
LOT OF ACTIVITY GOING
LEGISLATURE WILL BE SURE WE WORK
TOGETHER --
SO IT REALLY APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S INTEREST IN THE AND
HIS EXPRESSION OF THAT INTEREST
IN THE STATE OF THE STATE
ADDRESS AND UP AND AND VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THAT I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE VERY --
INTERESTED IN THIS ISSUE --
THAT HAVE APPROACH THE
LEGISLATURE I'M SURE OF APPROACH
TO GOVERNOR AS WELL SO.
I HOPE THAT WE CAN ALL WORK
TOGETHER ALL AND I APPRECIATE I
THINK WHEN --
KNOWS WE GET CLOSER. TO TWO
MILLION AND ONE THINGS THAT
WOULD MAKE NOTICE HOPEFULLY EVEN
BEFORE MAY --
BECAUSE INSTEAD OF HAVING
EVERYTHING DUMPED ON US --
ESPECIALLY THINGS LIKE THIS WERE
OKAY IT'S A TASK FORCE --
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S NOT THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT WE'RE
DEBATING IT'S REALLY ABOUT OKAY
HOW IS THIS IDEA OF ALL WHAT
KIND OF PIECES ARE THERE WHO'S
GOING TO BE AT CENTER THAT WE
CAN HAVE.
WE CAN TRY TO HOPEFULLY.
GET MORE INFORMATION ON THAT
AHEAD OF TIME --
AS WELL AS IS THAT IT IS IS THIS
OF OFFICE AND AND AND WE SERVE
MORE SOLIDIFY WHAT THIS IS AND
HOW WE CAN WORK TOGETHER TO
ACHIEVE THE AIMS.
MUTUAL AIMS WE ALL HAVE
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
DUMP SO HOPEFULLY WE DON'T HAVE
TO WAIT TILL MAY FOR THAT.
ITEM SO I KNOW YOU COME OF THE
NEW REVISED BUDGET BAY BUT
THAT'S NOT JUST THE MONEY SIDE
THING SO OKAY.
RIGHT NOT YOU.
AND I THINK WITH.
ALL RIGHT OKAY ISSUE NUMBER SIX
CHILDHOOD LEAD POISONING
PREVENTION PROGRAM IT PROJECT IN
ADDITION.
WE HAVE A NEW PERSON COMING UP
ALL RIGHT THESE BEINGS ARE.
UP.
AND NOW THEY ARE NEEDING
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH CHAU.
NAY BIGELOW SUPPORTING THAT DOES
THIS ACTIVITY EXCELLENT.
WRITER.
THIS INITIATIVE IS A REQUEST OF
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY SIX POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OVER THE
PERIOD OF FOUR YEARS WITH EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN FY. NINETEEN
TWENTY NINE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN FY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FIVE POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
IN FY.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
ONGOING.
THIS WAS SUPPORT A PERMANENT
POSITIONS TO IN OUR NEW DATA
SYSTEM THE SURVEILLANCE HEALTH
INTERVENTION ENVIRONMENTAL LEADS
DATABASE.
TITLE TO SHIELD.
THE NEW SHOW DATA SYSTEM WILL
REPLACE THE AGING RASCAL SYSTEM
THAT CURRENTLY SUPPORTS
MANAGEMENT OF TILE LEAD
POISONING PREVENTION ACTIVITIES.
AT THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL.
OUR TIãU CURRENTLY HAS LOST A
LOT OF ITS BUILT IN REPORTING
CAPACITY.
AND SO PUBLIC HEALTH BOTH
LOCALLY --
AT THIS AS AN AT THE STATE LEVEL
IS LIMITED IN TERMS OF THE WAY
THAT WE CAN ADEQUATELY AND
TIMELY RESPOND. TO REPORTS
QUESTIONS AND ALSO THE CASE
MANAGEMENT AND AN ENVIRONMENTAL
ASSESSMENT OF OUR CHILDREN.
AT THE STATE RIGHT NOW IS THE
KEEN -- TO
WORK WITH ALL RIGHT TIAS STEEP
PARTNERS IN THE DEPARTMENT TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND HOW WE DESIGN
A SYSTEM THAT CAN MEET THE NEEDS
AND WE'RE VERY CONFIDENT THAT.
MOVING FORWARD WITH THIS REQUEST
WILL GET US TO A PLACE WHERE THE
DATA WOULD BE MORE USABLE NOT
ONLY TO THE STATE BUT ALSO TO
OUR LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE CAME ON
AND GOT APPROVED THE BUDGET ACT
THAT INCLUDED THE INITIAL START
OF THIS VETO PROJECT.
THIS PROPOSAL TO DAY IS REALLY
THE CONTINUATION OF
IMPLEMENTATION --
OF OUR SHIELD ON PROGRAM SO.
THAT'S FOR RIGHT.
THANK YOU EN THE LA.
TONY PETTITT KALLIO.
I WE WOULD JUST NOTE I'M AS MY
COLLEAGUE --
DID IN THE EARLIER A PORTION OF
THIS HEARING THAT --
THERE ARE NUMBER OF DEPARTMENTS
THIS YEAR THAT ARE REQUESTING
FULL FUNDING FOR A. T. PROJECTS
BEFORE THE PAL PROCESS IS
COMPLETE.
IN THIS CASE WERE NOT
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED ABOUT IT
BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT DOES HOPE
TO AWARD A CONTRACT VERY SOON.
A IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING --
M. BECAUSE BUILDING IT OFF OF
THEIR EXISTING PLATFORM AND IT'S
MORE OF LIKE AN OFF THE SHELF
TYPE A SOLUTION --
BUT WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
SUGGESTIONS FOR THE LEGISLATURE
FIRST WOULD BE.
TO APPROVE SINGLE YEAR FUNDING
SO THAT --
THE THE THE LEGISLATURE CAN
CONTINUE TO RECEIVE UPDATES
THROUGH THE ANNUAL BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL PROCESS --
SECOND -- IT
MIGHT BE --
AS THE DEPARTMENT KNOWS ABOUT
THE SPECIFIC COSTS THAT ARE
PROPOSED BY BIDDERS --
IT MIGHT BE WORTHWHILE TO HAVE
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE AND
NOTIFICATION TO THE LEGISLATURE.
ABOUT THE PRECISE COSTS --
AND FINALLY IF THE DEPARTMENT
DOES GET AN UPDATE ABOUT
SPECIFIC COSTS FROM THE BIDDERS
BEFORE THE BUDGET DELIBERATIONS
ARE FINISHED --
IT WOULD BE GREAT.
TO GET AN UPDATE TO THE
PROPOSALS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CAN USE THAT INFORMATION TO MAKE
ITS DECISION [inaudible]
FINANCE.
IN THIS PARTICULAR I. T.
PROPOSAL WE THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLE VITAL TO GET ON
SOMETHING STARTED NOW --
WE WILL ALSO WANT TO NOTE THAT
YOU KNOW.
WE'RE TRYING TO WORK WITHIN THE
TIMING OF THE BUDGET PROCESS AS
WELL AND YOU KNOW SHOULD STAGE --
FOR AFTER WE HAVE BEEN NUMBERS
AND COSTS --
DIFFERS WHICH SIGNIFICANTLY
DIFFER FROM WHAT WE'RE EXPECTING
THERE'S PROCESSES AVAILABLE TO
BE ABLE TO ADJUST THAT UP OR
DOWN SPECIFICALLY CONTROL
SECTION ELEVEN OF THE BUDGET ACT
THAT ALLOWS.
FOR US TO COME BACK AND SAY IF
THE CHANGES ARE WITH NO FIVE
MILLION OR 20%.
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT HAS BEEN
AUTHORIZED JUSTIN SENSIBLE.
OKAY.
A SO WHAT SO WHERE ARE WAS SO AT
WHAT STAGE IS THIS PARTICULAR I.
T. PROJECT.
SO -- AS WE
MENTIONED THERE WAS WE SHOULD BE
FOR THE POWER PROCESS AND
WEARING A POWER PROCESS STAGE
ONE IS FULLY APPROVED AGE TO
FULLY APPROVED.
A THREE HAS BEEN KICKED OFF THE
PARTNERS ARE THERE WAS
DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY AND OUR
AGENCY SO WE'RE ACTUALLY IN
STAGE THREE RIGHT NOW PREPARING
ALL OF THE REQUEST --
FOR CONTRACTING SERVICES AND
STAGE FOR WILL THEN START AFTER
STAGE THREE FINISHED AND WE
EXPECT TO BE AND WANT TO BE ABLE
TO AWARD IN THE FIRST PART IN
JULY.
SO WE'RE IN THE POWER PROCESS
RIGHT AWAY WE HAVE A VERY SOLID
RECOMMENDED SOLUTION BASED ON A
LOT OF SOLUTIONS THAT WE HAVE IN
HOUSE ALREADY.
SO WE FEEL COMFORTABLE THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THIS BUT WE ALSO NO
AT THE END OF STATE FOR THERE IS
A RE BASELINE OF THE PROJECT
BASED ON THE RESPONSES THAT WE
GET BACK FROM OUR CONTRACTORS.
OKAY SO IN TERMS OF WHEN WE
MIGHT ACTUALLY KNOW IT ACTUALLY
COSTS
WITH NEARLY ALL THE INFORMATION
WHEN WHEN WHEN DO YOU THINK THAT
WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
SO -- WE WE
FEEL PRETTY COMFORTABLE WITH THE
COST WE HAVE BECAUSE WE VIEW
OTHER COSTS BUT WE WILL KNOW ALL
OF THE RESPONSES IN THE MAY JUNE
TIME FRAME WE THINK --
SO THAT WE COULD START IN JULY
AND BUT WITH CONCRETE ANY
CONTRACTS WE HAVE TO YOU KNOW.
BE COGNIZANT THAT IT COULD BE
DELAYED A LITTLE BIT LIKE THE
PRIMARY THERE'S ONE PRIMARY
DEVELOPMENT CONTRACT FOR AROUND
TEN MILLION THAT.
WE'D THAT'S THE THE CRUX ALL OF
THE OTHER ONES TEND TO BE
SOMEWHAT MORE OVERSIGHT AND
OTHER THINGS SO WILL HAVE MORE
INFORMATION ON THAT AT THAT TIME
BUT BUT IT IS A MULTI YEAR
PROJECT OR EAST ON AGILE
TECHNOLOGIES AND AND WE WOULDN'T
WANT TO SLOW DOWN IN.
THE MIDDLE YEAH WELL AND AND
I'VE BEEN JOE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
AYE JOE PROSJE SO BUT I ALSO
WENT TO YOU KNOW MAKE NOTE THAT --
SO.
OUR ROLE TO APPROPRIATE OUT TO
THE BUDGET APPROPRIATE CELL
WHILE BILL IS SURE TO WERE KEEP
THE PRICE OF WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THAT -- AND
THAT THE PROJECT IS IN ALL IS IS
GOING IN AND THE PROFIT
DIRECTION BECAUSE AS I SAID.
EARLIER WITH ANOTHER I. T.
PROJECT I THINK MOST ACTUALLY
YOU KNOW THE ONES THAT GO WELL
YOU DON'T HEAR ABOUT.
THAT'S GOOD --
THE ONES THAT DON'T WE HEAR
ABOUT.
SO -- I'D.
LIKE TO AYE AYE I'D LIKE TO IS
SHE THOSE ALREADY HERE AND UP
ABOUT THEM SO THAT ON HERE SO I
DON'T HAVE TO HEAR TOO MUCH
ABOUT THE GUY THAT.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS --
SO IT AS MUCH AS YOU CAN KEEP A
SURPRISED --
ON PROGRESS AND AND AND THAT
THAT WOULD BE APPRECIATED.
WE ABSOLUTELY CAN DO THAT I MEAN
AS WE RELEASE THE CONTRACTS --
AS RACE THOUGH REPORTS FOR
OFFERS WE'LL --
WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE YOU ONLY
GET THOSE BACK ABSOLUTELY OKAY
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
BUT I DO APPRECIATE GETTING A
THEY A SYSTEM FOR A CHILDHOOD
LEAD.
DOES THAT IS GOING TO BE --
MORE --
FUNCTIONAL AND ALSO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION FOR FOR
PEOPLE BECAUSE THAT'S OBVIOUSLY
AN AREA OF GREAT.
INTEREST AND OF VERY OF GREAT
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPORTANCE SO.
APPRECIATE INVESTMENT ALL RIGHT
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN MORE CHILD
THE CHILD OF THE POISONING
PREVENTION PROGRAM REPORTING AND
RESULT OF TWO SENATE BILLS.
YEAH.
THIS REALLY COMPLIMENTED THINK
THE PREVIOUS REQUEST IN TERMS OF
THE DEMAND THAT THE PROGRAM HAS
ON REPORTING.
ON THIS ISSUE SEVEN IS A
GOVERNOR'S REQUESTS TO INCREASE
EXPENDITURES STORY OF SEVEN DOT
SEVEN HUNDRED SIXTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN STATE
OPERATIONS. TO SUPPORT SIX
POSITIONS FROM THE TOUGH FUND --
THE NISHA REQUEST IS DUE TO THE
NEW REPORTING MANDATE ON SB.
NINETEEN TEN NINETY SEVEN AND SB.
TEN FORTY ONE A LITTLE
BACKGROUND ON ON THOSE --
A NEW MANDATE SO SB TEN FORTY
AND TEN NINETY SEVEN REQUIRES
REPORTING OF LET SCREENING BLOOD
LET TESTING CASE MANAGEMENT
ENVIRONMENTAL DESIGNATIONS WE
ALSO ARE REQUIRED.
TO READ A POST THE INFORMATION
ON OUR WEBSITE REQUIRED.
TO WORK WITH --
ARE AN INVESTIGATION OF STAFF TO
REPORT ON WHAT WAS THAT BECAUSE
OF THE LEAD EXPOSURE IF IF IT
HAS BEEN ABATED AND YOU KNOW
MALLORY DID AN ABATEMENT TOOK
PLACE.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF JUST
DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS THAT IS
P. -- TEN
NINETY SEVEN HAS ON THE PROGRAM
IN ADDITION THERE'S A
REQUIREMENT FOR US TO WORK WITH
THE H. C. S. ON MATCHING.
OF OUR DATE SPECIFIC DATA SETS
BOTH LOOKING AT HOW MANY MEDI
CAL CHILDREN HAVE BEEN SCREENED
FOR LEAD AND THOSE THAT ARE NOT
IN A MEDICAL ALSO SCREEN FOR
LEAD.
SO -- AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE FOR AS KLAY AND
PAPER -- YOU
KNOW WRITTEN DOWN THERE EITHER
SENT TO US BY YOUR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS OR STAFF COLLECT
THAT INFORMATION WE THEN HAVE.
TO ENTER IT INTO RASCAL AND SO
FORTH SO THE REQUEST FOR US IS
READY TO MEET THE MANDATE TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN.
REPORT IN A TIMELY MANNER AND
ALSO TO POST INFORMATION AND
PROVIDED TO STAKEHOLDERS AT
NEEDED FOR POLICY DECISION
MAKING.
THANK YOU ELIA.
I WE JUST WANTED TO MAKE ONE
POINT ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR
PROPOSAL WELL IT'S NOT ACTUALLY
ABOUT THE SPECIFIC MERITS OF THE
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL BUT WE WILL
POINT OUT THAT.
SB TEN FORTY ONE ALSO REQUIRES
THE DEPARTMENT TO NOTIFY HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS ABOUT THE TESTING
REQUIREMENTS AND INFORM --
INFORM THEM ABOUT THE RISKS OF
LEAD POISONING --
THE DEPARTMENTS NOT PROPOSING
ANYTHING NEW IN THIS REGARD WITH
THIS PROPOSAL AND HAS KINDLY YOU
KNOW PROVIDED OUR OFFICE WITH
THE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
EXTENSIVE OUTREACH EFFORTS THAT
THEY CURRENTLY DO WHICH INCLUDE
GOING TO EVENTS PER OF DOING
PRESENTATIONS THAT CAN TO HAVE
FREE CONTINUING.
MEDICAL EDUCATION COURSE --
IN THE LAKE --
AND THE DEPARTMENT ALSO
INDICATED TO US THAT THEY WANT
TO USE SOME OF THE INFORMATION
COLLECTED THROUGH THIS REPORTING
PROCESS TO BETTER TARGET THEIR
OUR EACH TO HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS.
SO THAT ALL MAKES GREAT SENSE --
TO US THE ONLY POINT MAKE IS THE
ULTIMATE GOAL HERE REALLY IS TO
INCREASE TESTING OF YOUNG
CHILDREN AND THEN PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY INTERVENTIONS TO
IMPROVE THEIR HEALTH SO --
WE JUST SUGGEST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE KEEP AN EYE ON THIS
NOTIFICATION EFFORT BECAUSE IF
THE DOESN'T REALLY INTO THE INTO
THE DAY IT DOESN'T REALLY MATTER
HOW MUCH OUR EACH IS DONE IF THE
HOURS OUT REACHES AND
EFFECTIVELY LEADING.
TO AN OF TESTING AND
INTERVENTIONS [inaudible]
FINANCE --
AT THIS WHEN WE FEEL COMFORTABLE
WITH THE PROPOSED RESOURCES SOME
REQUESTED UNDER THIS ON PROPOSAL --
WOULD HAVE ANYTHING MORE TO ADD.
THE A IS I GUESS A COUPLE
QUESTIONS ONE IS IS THAT --
GIVEN --
THAT THE LA IS CONCERNS ARE YOU
GONNA BE ABLE TO PROVIDE --
COLLECTIVE RIGHT DATA IS.
TO THOSE OUTCOMES SO HOW MANY
PEOPLE ACTUALLY ARE WE SEEN
INCREASE AND TESTING AND AND
ALSO ACTION ON THOSE RESULTS
RECOVERY COLLECTING THAT KIND OF
DATA. TO BE SURE WE CAN --
THE REPORT BACK AND SINCERELY
MAKING áREA CHEATING ARTICLE.
YET WE FEEL VERY CONFIDENT THAT.
WITH THE BILLS AND OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE G. D.
BETTER TO UNDERSTAND A LITTLE
BIT MORE WHERE ARE THE GAPS WERE
WE GOING HOW CAN WE IMPROVE THE
EDUCATION TO PROVIDERS.
HOW CAN WE TARGET A LITTLE BIT
BETTER WITH THE DATA SYSTEM IN
THE FUTURE AS WELL OUR GOAL IS
TO DO SOME CHILDREN ADDED WERE
THE COMMUNITIES THAT WERE FAIRLY
NOR WITH THAT WE NEED TO DO MORE
OUR REACH WITH STILL?
ARE IN TEN TO THROUGH THIS --
PARTNERSHIP WITH DH CS AND ALSO
THE INTERNAL CHANGES THAT WE'RE
DOING IN THE PROGRAM WE BELIEVE
WILL SET POINT IS TO ACTUALLY BE
IN A SITUATION TO DO BETTER
TARGETING OF OUR REGION WITH
PROVIDERS AND COMMUNITIES AS
WELL OKAY BUT THAT DATA WOULD BE
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE.
YES SO WE ARE REQUIRED TO POST
INFORMATION ON OUR WEBSITE OKAY
THAT DEFINITELY WILL BE
AVAILABLE OKAY BUT WE WANNA BE
SURE WE HAVE DATA WE CAN SEE
WHAT THEY WERE ACTUALLY
ACHIEVING THOSE GOALS RATES I'M
FREE SHEET YOU KNOW.
WE WE WE DO THINGS AND SOMETIMES
THINGS HAPPEN SOMETIMES THINGS
DOWN RIGHT AND SO AND THEN WE
HAVE TO BE JUST WHAT WE DO SO
WELL IN KNOWS THAT AND THEN WE
THINK ALL THESE THINGS RIGHT
TIME.
I DO VALUATION PROGRAM
EVALUATION SO WE WE DON'T WE DO
THINGS BECAUSE WE EXPECT FROM TO
GET A CERTAIN ITSELF BUT TO
THOSE OF DOESN'T ALWAYS HAPPEN
AND THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO
MEASURE THINGS YOUR PUBLIC
HEALTH YOU KNOW THIS AND THEN WE
GO OKAY MAYBE.
WITH THIS THAN WORK AS WELL AS
WE THOUGHT IT WOULD AND WE GO.
MAKE SOME ADJUSTMENTS --
THE OTHER QUESTION IS IS THAT SO
THE FOR THE STAFFING POSITIONS
THE FIVE POSITIONS.
SO WHAT WE'RE HOPING IS AS YOU
MOVE FROM RASCO WHOSE SHIELD
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE YOU
KNOW THE WITH THIS BETTER SYSTEM
THAT.
ARE YOU.
SO SOME OF THIS IS A AND STAND
OUT DATA ENTRY EXTRACTION OF
INFORMATION WE GOING IS IS THAT
OF THE SOME OF THAT WORK BURDEN
GOING GET RELEASED THAT REDUCED
WITH SHIELD --
IS THIS THIS IS A STAFFING BASED
ON THE FACT THAT YOU'RE STILL
HAVING TO DEAL WITH RASCAL RIGHT
NOW AND WOULD BE.
WITH THE NEW IT SYSTEM WOULD WE
ASK MANY PEOPLE BECAUSE THE THE
NEW SYSTEM WOULD BE MORE
EFFICIENT AND AND AND MAKE IT
EASIER TO DO CERTAIN THINGS.
YEAH THAT'S A FAIR QUESTION SO
RIGHT NOW WE'RE WE HAVE
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
RECORDS ON A PAPER.
THAT WE STILL NEED TO ENTER INTO
RASCAL AND WILL ENTER INTO THE
FUTURE DATA SYSTEM SHIELD --
WE ALSO HAVE THE TRIPLED THE
REPORTING AND OUTREACH
ACTIVITIES THAT WE NEED TO DO.
SO WHAT WE FORESEE IS THAT WE
WILL BASICALLY THE STAFF THAT
CURRENTLY IS WORKING ON RASCAL
WERE TRANSFERRED TO SHIELD BUT
WE WILL ALSO UTILIZE THEM TO
CONTINUE ON SOME OF THE TRAINING
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO THE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ON A
NEW DATA SYSTEM --
HELP WITH THE REPORTING OF THE
NEW REQUIREMENTS GET A LITTLE
SAVVIER ON TECHNOLOGY TO DO THAT
YOU'LL MAPPING THAT WE FORESEE.
SO IT FOR US --
BECAUSE OF THE MANDATES OVER THE
PAST FOUR FIVE YEARS ON THE
PROGRAM WERE TRYING TO ACTUALLY
PLAY CATCH UP AND AND THAT'S
KIND OF WHERE WE'RE AT NOT SURE
IF YOU [inaudible]
OKAY --
ACTUAL IN THE THE NEW SHOW FOR A
WILL REDIRECT SOME OF THE DATA
ENTRY SERVICES THE MANUAL
EFFORTS AS ACCOUNT MAKES ALL
THOSE TYPE OF THING.
BUT IT'S A TRULY CASE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM TO WILL BE ABLE TO
REDIRECTION OF THOSE RESOURCES
TO MANAGING CASES BASED ON THE
NEEDS OF EACH INDIVIDUAL AND WE
THINK THAT AND I. T. SIDE WERE
ALSO EXPANDING THE WHOLE HELP
DESK ENVIRONMENT. TO PROVIDE
BETTER CUSTOMER SERVICE OUT TO
THE FIELD TO ALL THOSE OF
EXPANDED FUNCTIONS TO MAKE THIS
A MORE EFFECTIVE PROGRAM.
RIGHT WELL BECAUSE EVERY TIME WE
MAKE AN I. T. INVESTMENTS --
I'D LIKE THEM THEM USUALLY ASKS
LIKE OKAY SO WITH THIS NEW IT
SYSTEM.
HOW YOU KNOW HOW?
ARE YOU GET EFFICIENCIES LIKE WE
DON'T NEED AS A PEOPLE ARE
THINGS THAT THAT AND ENHANCE OUR
CAPACITY BUT SO THEY'RE NOT
DOING THINGS TO FEED THE CURRENT
SYSTEM ETCETERA SO --
BUT NO I THINK ALSO IN WHEN YOU
HAVE BETTER AND MORE EFFICIENT
SYSTEMS.
NEEDS RESULT IN SOME EFFICIENCY
SELL EITHER GROWTH IN CAPACITY
OR DECREASE AND AND STAFFING
NEEDS SO IT IT WILL ONCE IT'S
IMPLEMENTED SO --
YEAH WE WANTED TRACK THAT.
AS WE MAKE OUR VARIOUS
INVESTMENTS I APPRECIATE THAT --
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW RIGHT EXACTLY
DELUDE BACKLOG YOU NEED THE
PEOPLE TO DEAL WITH IT RIGHT AND
WHAT'S THE BACKLOGS GOTTEN.
THEN AND NOW THEN WE I THINK ARE
A WELL WHAT WHAT HAPPENS THEN
RATE AND AND SO --
SO WE JUST WANTED THAT AND AND
CERTAINLY THERE THERE'S MORE
WORK TO DO IN THE AREA SO THESE
PEOPLE MAY NEED TO BE RETRAINED
RE DIRECTED AT CENTER --
ARE OR OR YOU SAY WELL ACTUALLY
WE CAN WE GOT EVERYTHING COVERED
SO WE CAN ACTUALLY REDUCE OUR
STAFF AND MAYBE THIS BILL AND
WORK DO SOMETHING ELSE WITH
SOMEBODY ELSE AND IN THE STATE.
SO -- BUT SO
IS WHY KEEP THEM MIND ANYTIME WE
TALK ABOUT I. T. THE RESULTING
EFFICIENCIES THAT WE EXPECT FROM
THE NEW IT SYSTEMS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
AND I THINK --
THAT WRAPS IT UP FOR YOUR TEAM I
THINK THE MOVING ON TO WAKE.
OKAY THANK YOU --
WAKE LOCAL ASSISTANT ESTIMATE
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELVES THE
RECORD.
HELLO MY NAME IS DOCTOR
CONTINENTAL AND THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER FOR
FAMILY HEALTH.
GOOD MORNING CHRISTINE NELSON
I'M SHE FOR THE WITH DIVISION
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT SO ISSUE
NUMBER.
EIGHT OUR LOCAL SYSTEM VESTMENT
[inaudible]
GREAT.
SO -- WITHIN
THE WEEK AGENDA THERE ARE THREE
QUESTIONS SO FIRST ALL STAR WITH
A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE CHANGES
IN THE WAKE PROGRAM ESTIMATE.
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION DO
CONTINUE TO SEE A DECLINE IN
PARTICIPATION IN THE WAKE
PROGRAM.
BUT WHAT WE SAW IN CALIFORNIA IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WAS THE DECLINE
WAS LESS THAN WHAT IT HAD BEEN.
IN PREVIOUS YEARS WE CURRENTLY
SERVE JUST UNDER ONE MILLION
PARTICIPATION PARTICIPANTS EACH
MONTH AND EXPECT TO SPEND SEVEN
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS ON FOOD.
IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
ABOUT HALF THE BABY'S BORN IN
CALIFORNIA EACH YEAR ARE
ENROLLED IN THE WICK PROGRAM.
AND THE ONLY PROGRAMMATIC CHANGE
IN THE PAST YEAR IN IN THE
ESTIMATE IS IN FALL OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN U. S. T. A. DID --
APPROVED A AN INCREASE TO THE
DOLLAR OF THE FRUIT AND
VEGETABLE DOLLAR AMOUNT DOLLARS
A MONTH TO NINE DOLLARS A MONTH
SO THAT WASN'T.
A COST INCREASE IN THE PROGRAM
THERE AND WE HAVE SUFFICIENT
FUNDS TO COVER THAT.
EACH YEAR USDA DOES PRODUCE A
REPORT WHICH WE CALL THE PROGRAM
REACH REPORT THEY ESTIMATE THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE PROGRAM AND
COMPARE THAT TO THE NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE THAT WERE ACTUALLY SERVED.
AND PRODUCE A PERCENTAGE WHAT WE
CALL OUR OUR PROGRAM REACHER
COVERAGE RAE.
AND THE LAST REPORT CAME OUT
THIS MONTH OR EARLY THIS MONTH
AND IT'S LOOKING AT TWENTY
SIXTEEN DATA.
WITHOUT REPORT CALIFORNIA
SERVICE SIXTY FIVE POINT 6% OF
THE ELIGIBLE TO PARTICIPATE -
EXCUSE ME ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS
IN CALIFORNIA IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN AND THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE IS 54% FOR THAT YEAR.
AT THE SLIGHT INCREASE IN OUR
COVERAGE RATE FROM THE PRIOR
YEAR WHERE WE ARE AT SIXTY FIVE
POINT ZERO SO WE'LL WE'LL TAKE A
SLIGHT INCREASE.
OF ONE OF THE INTERESTING
CHANGES IN THAT YEAR AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN IT WAS THE FIRST YEAR
FIRST TIME IN SEVERAL YEARS THAT
THERE WAS A DECREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS.
SO THERE WAS A DECREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT WE SERVE
BUT THERE WAS A LARGER DECREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE SAID
WE HAVEN'T SEEN THAT AND A
NUMBER OF YEARS.
SO WE ARE DOING A NUMBER OF
THINGS TO MAXIMIZE PARTICIPATION
IN THE PROGRAM AND I'VE SHARED
WITH THE COMMITTEE IN THE PAST
OLD AS JUST TO HAVE A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF SOME THINGS THAT
WE'RE DOING.
IN OUR FIRST AREA OF DATA AND
RESEARCH WE'RE EXCITED THAT WE
ARE CONTINUING TO HAVE A GOOD
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CAL FRESH
PROGRAM WHERE WE MATCH.
WITH DATA WITH CAL FRESH DATA WE
SELECT ONE MONTH EACH YEAR SO WE
LOOK AT MARCH DATA ENROLLMENT
DATA FOR BOTH PROGRAMS.
THE FIRST YEAR WE DID IT WAS
LOOKING AT TWENTY SIXTEEN DATA.
AND WE WERE ABLE TO IDENTIFY
VISUALS THAT WERE ELIGIBLE FOR
WORK BUT NOT IN WORK AND THEN
VICE VERSA.
AND THEN WE DID IT ALSO FOR
MARCH OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
WE'RE JUST FINISHING UP FOR
MARCH OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
HAVE SEEN SOME.
SOME INTERESTING THINGS WERE
FAMILIES GOING FROM ONE PROGRAM
TO ANOTHER OR THEY WERE IN BOTH
PROGRAMS ONE YEAR AND ONE
PROGRAM THE NEXT YEAR AND THEN
BOTH AGAIN AND SO.
LOTS OF CHANGES HAPPENING THERE.
WERE ALSO REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
OUR MOST RECENT PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM WHERE WE'RE
ABLE TO DO THE SAME TYPE OF A
MATCH WITH MEDICAL THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME THAT WE'VE DONE THAT
AND WE'RE JUST FINISHING UP THAT
ANALYSIS.
SO WITH BOTH OF THOSE TWO TWO
TYPES OF ANALYSIS WE DO PROVIDE
MAPS TO OUR LOCAL AGENCIES THAT
IDENTIFY HOT SPOTS WHERE THERE
ARE.
A NUMBER OF WEEK OF POTENTIAL
ELIGIBLE --
FOR INDIVIDUALS AND SO WE CAN
TARGET OUR OUTREACH EFFORTS AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT MIGHT BE
HAPPENING DIFFERENTLY IN
DIFFERENT IN THOSE COMMUNITIES --
ANOTHER BIG AREA THAT WE WORK ON
IS --
IMPROVING OUR PROGRAM SERVICES
SO BOTH LOOKING AT REDUCING
BARRIERS.
TWO AND ROLLING OR PARTICIPATING
IN THE PROGRAM AND ALSO
INCREASING.
THE BENEFITS OR THE RELEVANCY OF
THE PROGRAM THERE SO WE'VE
IMPLEMENTED A NUMBER OF POLICIES.
TO MAKE --
ENROLLMENT IN THE PROGRAM EASIER
WERE ALSO WORKING WITH USDA TO
APPROVE -- A
COUPLE PILOTS ONE FOUR
TELESERVICES FOR BREAST FEEDING
SUPPORT.
AND OTHER FOR RECERTIFY.
PARTICIPANTS ONLINE RATHER THAN
IN PERSON --
AND THEN OF COURSE THE BIG
CHANGE THAT WE'RE MAKING FOR THE
BENEFITS IS IMPLEMENTING THE
WHAT CARD SO WE'LL BE MOVING
FROM PAPER VOUCHERS TO THE
ELECTRONIC CARD.
WE GO LIVE WITH OUR PILOT IN
NAPA AND SOLANO COUNTY IS ON MAY
SIXTH ON JUST ABOUT TWO MONTHS
FROM NOW.
WE'RE REPLACING OUR COMPUTER
SYSTEM THAT WE'VE HAD IN PLACE
FOR ABOUT TWENTY FIVE YEARS WITH
THE TRANSFER SYSTEM THAT'S BEEN
USED IN OTHER STATES THE MOST
RECENT WAS THE YORK AND SO WE'VE.
MOVED THAT CODE OVER MAKINGS AND
NUMBER OF REVISIONS FOR
CALIFORNIA.
AND THEN SETTING GETTING GROCERY
STORES AND ALL OF OUR LOCAL
AGENCIES READY TO GO.
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR COMMENTS
FINANCE.
SO -- IF.
IT IF AND I WOULD MAKE NOTE AND
I THINK OF BAD THAT SO BILL WERE
ABOVE AVERAGE AND ARE WITH
PARTICIPATION SO THAT'S GREAT --
I THINK I CAO FRESH THOUGH I
THINK THAT SORT OF THE OFFICE I
THINK WE'RE KIND OF LOW COMPARED
TO OTHER STATES --
TERMS -- CAL
FRESH OF DISSIPATION AND THEY
HAVE I DO BELIEVE THEY HAVE A
LOWER COVERAGE RATE THAN OTHER
STRAIGHT YEAH SO --
SO I DO APPRECIATE YOUR PUTTING
TRANSIT THE TWO TOGETHER AND IT
SAYS THAT YOU'RE LOOKING --
FOR IS IS YEAR.
BUT AS YOU'RE DOING THIS I GUESS
HE SAID THERE ARE SOME
INTERESTING FINDINGS --
pASSUME YOU HAD A CHANCE TO TAKE
A LOOK AT SOME OF THE STUFF LIKE
THE SIMS IDEAS OR THINGS THAT
WERE GOING TO DO.
TO IMPROVE OUR WAY CREATES EVEN
MORE I MEAN WE'RE AT WAS IS UP
WITH WAS FOR THE SIXTY SIXTY
FIVE FIFTY FIVE PROCESO SO I
MEAN.
THAT'S IT SAYS THAT IT IS HARD
TO GET CLOSE TO A HUNDRED GREAT --
BUT THAT DALE DO YOU UNDERSTAND
WHAT KIND OF IN THE PROGRAM
CHANGES THE SEE HAPPENING AS A
RESULT OF THIS EXAMINATION OF
THIS COMPARISON OF DATA.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
WANT TO SEE IS IS ARE THE TYPES
OF IS IT CONSISTENT ACROSS THE
STATE OR ARE THERE DIFFERENT
THINGS HAPPENING DIFFERENT PARTS
OF THE STATE.
OF WIKI AND CAL FOR US OPERATE
VERY DIFFERENTLY AND WE HAVE
DIFFERENT PROVIDERS AND WITH
WORK WE DON'T OPERATE THROUGH
ALL COME COUNTY HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ONLY ABOUT FORTY
DIFFERENT COUNTY HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS.
AND THEN WE HALLS ALSO HAVE A
NUMBER OFNONPROFIT AGENCIES SO
THE WICCAN ROMAN HAPPENS IN A
DIFFERENT PLACE TO THERE MIGHT
BE DIFFERENT THINGS HAPPENING
THERE.
BUT WE ALSO WANT TO SEE ADD
DEMOGRAPHICALLY HAPPENING
DIFFERENTLY IN DIFFERENT PLACES
AS WELL SO WE CAN DEFINITELY
LOOK AT HOW DO WE BETTER PARTNER
WITH -- AT
THE WITH CAL FRESH OF THE
ENROLLMENT SITE ARE WE LOSING
PEOPLE AT A CERTAIN TIME DURING
AND WE KNOW WITH CHILDREN THAT
AROUND TEN MONTHS OR SO CHILDREN
TEND TO START TO BEGIN TO DROP
OFF THE WORK PROGRAM.
AND HEY MIGHT UPTAKE IN THE COW
FIRST PROGRAM AT THAT TIME SO IS
THERE SOME KIND OF MESSAGING WE
COULD SAY YOU DON'T HAVE TO
LEAVE ONE PROGRAM TO JOIN THE
OTHER.
THOSE TYPES OF THINGS.
I JUST WANTED TO HAS TO THAT IS
THAT.
I THINK THAT THE INTERESTING
QUESTION IS IF YOU'RE ELIGIBLE
FOR ALL THREE PROGRAMS WHY DON'T
YOU PARTICIPATE IN ALL THREE
PROGRAMS MET SO I THINK THAT ALL
THREE AGENCIES ARE VERY
INTERESTED IN THAT SO.
WHERE DO YOU HAVE HIGHER
PENETRATION OF MEDI CAL
ENROLLMENT BUT NOT A BLANK AND
THEN WHAT HAPPENS WHEN IS IT
REVERSE WHY WOULD THERE BE SOME
PLACES WHERE THERE'S HIGHER
WICKETLESS MEDIC HOUSE SO WE'RE
WORKING TOGETHER?
TO TRY TO CREATE A YOU DON'T BUY
DIRECTIONAL INFUSION OF
INFORMATION AND SUPPORT IN
TRYING TO GET ALL ELIGIBLE
PEOPLE IN THE ENROLLED WHEREVER
THEY CAN BE.
BUT SINCE SAID THE SUBCOMMITTEE
ACTUALLY OVERSEAS ALL --
THREE VERY VERY INTERESTED AS
RESULTS AND ALSO HEARING FROM
THE YEAR PARTNER AGENCIES AND
THIS ABOUT HOW MUCH THEY THINK.
I A YES AT THAT.
WOULD YOU GATHERING GUESSES THE
OKAY WELL GIVEN THIS DATA WHAT
THE HOW MUCH FOR HOT IS SO SO
YOU'RE IT DOES HAPPEN HOW THE
HEAVY MORE PERCENT DO YOU THINK
WE MIGHT BE A BUMP THIS UP THAT --
BASED ON THE DATA THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE
YOU MISSING THAT PAVE WHETHER
ALL THOSE PROGRAMS I REALIZED --
MAKE THE VARIOUS BARRIERS AS TO
WHY THEY MIGHT STILL NOT WANT.
TO ENROLL WORK OF THE QUALIFIED
FOR THAT BUT AS YOU KNOW THE
FACT WE QUESTIONS IF YOU QUALIFY
FOR ALL THREE ONE ACTION ROLLED
ALL THREE BUT I MEAN.
WHAT WHAT LOOKS LIKE THE
POSSIBILITY AT LEAST OF WHO THEY
ARE BECAUSE THEY HAPPEN TO BE
CAO FRESH?
I MEAN DO YOU HAVE IT'S THE
SENSE OF THE SCALE OF THAT.
I THINK ONCE WE COMPLETE THE
MEDIC HOW MUCH WE MADE A QUICK
TO ANSWER THAT BE OKAY.
THERE MAY BE INDIVIDUALS THAT.
ARE IN NEITHER CAO FRESHER WORK
AND THAT WOULD AND SO JUST
LOOKING AT CAO FRESH A WILL BE
MISSING A NUMBER OF PEOPLE BUT
WE'RE MAKING ASSUMPTIONS THAT.
THERE WILL BE MORE EL AND MORE
INDIVIDUALS IN MEDI CAL THAT ARE
NOT IN EITHER OF THE NUTRITION
PROGRAM SO WHEN YOU THINK YOU
MIGHT BE ABLE TO FIND THAT OUT
BY -- WE ARE
OUR REPORT IS IN THE REVIEW
PROCESS THAT OUR DEPARTMENT
RIGHT NOW SO WE'RE WE'RE GETTING
CLOSE OKAY SO MAYBE BY TIME WE
TALK TO YOU AGAIN.
WE HAVE A STRATEGY FOR
INCREASING PARTICIPATION I THINK
WHAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT AS THIS
NEW DATA LINCOLN RIGHT REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT'S VERY NEW.
TO THE AGENCIES ARE STILL
THINKING ABOUT AND I AGREE WITH
YOU AND BE GOOD TO SAY.
CAN NOW HOW CAN WE DO THIS
BETTER HOW CAN WE SHARE DATA
ALCHEMY CAM.
IDENTIFY THESE HOT SPOTS AND
THEN WHAT WOULD BE THE
STRATEGIES THAT WE WOULD USE TO
RAISE PARTICIPATION OF HOT SPOTS
THAT WE'RE NOT READY YET TO DO
THAT BECAUSE WE JUST BARELY HAVE
THAT ARE YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND.
OKAY ABOUT THAT'S OUR GOAL AND
THE OTHER UNKNOWN HERE'S HOW
WELL OUR WHOLE NEW YOU WEAK
SYSTEM.
IMPACT THIS VARIABLE BECAUSE AS
YOU KNOW IT DOES MODERNIZE OUR
ENTIRE DELIVERY OF SERVICES IT
MAKES IT MUCH MORE EFFICIENT AND
LESS STIGMATIZING TO
PARTICIPANTS MUCH MORE ENGAGING
MUCH MORE MODERNIZED SO.
WE'RE HOPING THAT TO ME REALLY
ACT IS THAT SO I GUESS THAT'S OF
WHEN YOU EXPECT TO HAVE SOME OF
THAT INFORMATION AND WHEN WE
MIGHT BE ABLE. TO TO TO TO LEARN
ABOUT IT SO SOUNDS LIKE YOU HAVE
A REPORT COMING UP PRETTY SOON.
I'D LIKE A FEW MONTHS.
AND THE YEAR.
SO TELL ME AGAIN THAT IT YOU
WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR A
SPECIFIC LIKE GOALS FOR NO I
ACTUALLY I CHAU JUST CARRY IT I
MEAN YOU SAID FELT LIKE THIS
REPORT PENDING LIKE HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE WE E. EVERY TALKING
ABOUT TO ARE THE OPPORTUNITY I
REALIZE NOT EVERYONE.
MADE US OR GET A ROLE LIKE
WHAT'S THE I'M JUST GET A SENSE
OF THE SCALE OF WHAT WHAT WHAT'S
THE OPPORTUNITY AND OF COURSE
THE FOLLOW UP IS IS THAT WHAT
YOU GONNA DO AND WHERE DO YOU
THINK WE MIGHT ACTUALLY LAND.
I DON'T THINK WE SET A TARGET
GOAL YET TILL WE TALK WITH OUR
CERTAINLY THIS ALLIANCE WITH OUR
OTHER AGENCIES OUR SISTER
AGENCIES IN COORDINATION IS A
TOP PRIORITY FOR INCREASING WITH
PARTICIPATION.
WE JUST HAVEN'T HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SET A GOAL SO
IT'S HARD FOR US TO REALIZE I'M
JUST SAYING WHEN DO YOU THINK
YOU MIGHT BE ABLE TO DO THAT BY
AND I'D SAY THAT YOU THAT YOU
GOT IT ALREADY SO I'M JUST LIKE.
BY. THREE NEXT YEAR AND THE YEAR.
EXCEL A JET IS FOR SUMMER OR
FALL IN ACTIVE CONVERSATIONS
RIGHT NOW WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF
BUT WITH THE REGULAR MEETINGS
LIKE WE'RE ALL HOPING TO HAVE
SOME SORT OF STRATEGY OVER THE
NEXT YEAR OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL
I'M I'M HOPING YOU COULD HELP
YOU WITH.
THE ABLE TO SHARE SOMETHING WITH
US BY YOU KNOW.
BEGINNING NEXT YEAR [inaudible]
EXCITED OKAY.
RIGHT I MEAN BE GREAT IF YOU CAN
SHARE SOMETHING ELSE BY MAY BUT
I REALIZE THAT THAT MAY NOT
HAPPEN YET. TWO OTHER AGENCIES
RIDLEY BEHIND OF IDAHO BUT DON'T
WORRY I'LL ASK THEM.
TO WE ALL HAVE TO COME HERE YOU
JUST HAVE THE FIRST [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THAT.
HEY IT'S GOOD NEWS RIGHT.
AND HE SAID THAT THAT THE STUFF
YOU WANT TO TELL ME ABOUT THE
SAY.
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY --
THANK YOU WITH ALL RIGHT WELL
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
NINE CALIFORNIA HOME VISITATION
PROGRAM EXPANSION. FOR NOW WE'RE
TO OUR NEXT TO THIS [inaudible]
ADOLESCENT HEALTH. TO INTERVIEW
PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELVES.
ABSOLUTELY LESLIE CALLAS GATE
CHIEF OF THE AND C. H. TO VISION.
FROM AND LESLIE GAFFNEY
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTER FOR FAMILY HEALTH RIGHT
WONDERFUL. THREE SO I WILL GIVE
AN OVERVIEW OF OUR HOME VISITING
PROGRAM AND THEN ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS --
AS WE KNOW DECADES OF RESEARCH
ON EARLY CHILDHOOD HOME VISITING
SHOW THAT HOME VISITS BY A
TRAINED PROFESSIONAL DURING
PREGNANCY.
AND IN THOSE FIRST YEARS OF LIFE
IMPROVES THE LIVES OF CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES.
HOME VISITING HAS BEEN
DEMONSTRATED TO LOWER RATES OF
CHILD INJURY.
CHILD ABUSE AND NEGLECT AND
SMOKING DURING PREGNANCY WHILE
IMPROVING RATES OF IMMUNIZATION
BREAST FEEDING AND LANGUAGE
DEVELOPMENT.
WE KNOW THAT HOME VISITING IS
WELL PLACED TO ASSIST PARENTS
AND LEARNING HOW TO PROVIDE
THEIR CHILDREN WITH THE STRONG.
AND SAFE AND STABLE AND
NURTURING CURRENTLY THERE ARE
FEDERAL FUNDING ARE CALIFORNIA
HOME VISITING PROGRAM SERVES
PREGNANT AND NEWLY PARENTING
FAMILIES IN TWENTY THREE
COUNTIES USING THE N. F. P. AND
AS IT HFA EVIDENCE BASED HOME
VISITING MODELS.
THE PROGRAM MEETS THE NEEDS OF
FAMILIES WHO HAVE ONE OR MORE
RISK FACTORS AS RICK RISK
FACTORS INCLUDE IN IN ADEQUATE
INCOME.
UNSTABLE HOUSING EDUCATION LESS
THAN TWELVE YEARS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND
DEPRESSION AND OR MENTAL ILLNESS.
IN STATE FISCAL YEAR SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN OUR HOME VISITORS MADE
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND HOME VISITS.
AND THEY SAW APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY THAT ARE --
THREE THOUSAND MOMS.
SO WE KNOW THAT EIGHT THAT HOME
VISITING HAS AN IMPACT IN OUR
STATE AND I KNOW THAT YOU ENJOY
HOME VISITING IN SACRAMENTO AS
WELL.
SO I REQUEST WE ARE REQUESTING
THIRTEEN POSITIONS AND TWENTY
THREE MILLION NJ IN IN GENERAL
FUNDS.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
AND ANNUALLY THEREAFTER TO
EXPAND THE CALIFORNIA HOME
VISITING PROGRAM.
PUBLIC HEALTH WILL DEVELOP A
COLLABORATIVE WITH OUR LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS ON A
SYSTEMATIC AND COMPREHENSIVE.
DECISION MAKING APPROACH TO
EVALUATE AND SELECT A NEW MODEL
AND WHERE BEST TO EXPAND OUR
HOME VISITING PROGRAM.
IN ORDER TO FOCUS ON LOW INCOME
AND YOUNG MOTHERS.
EXPANDING HOME VISITING EFFORT
INTO OTHER COUNTIES AND
EXPLORING THE ADOPTION OF
ADDITIONAL EVIDENCE BASED MODELS
WILL ENSURE THE HEALTH AND
RESILIENCY NEEDS OF MORE OF A
LOCAL FAMILIES IN OUR STATE.
SO YOU WANT TO KNOW HOW --
WE HAD WE PLAN TO EVALUATE
ADDING ADDITIONAL MODELS TO OUR
HOME VISITING PROGRAM.
AND AT THIS TIME WE DON'T KNOW
WHICH NEW MODELS WILL BE
SELECTED BUT THROUGH OUR
SYSTEMATIC APPROACH AND WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE L. WITH OUR
LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS.
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT TRULY
UNDERSTAND THE LAY OF THE LAND
AND UNDERSTAND WHAT MODELS ARE
CURRENTLY BEING IMPLEMENTED AND
WHAT THAT WHERE THE NEEDS ARE
AND WHAT THEY DIGITAL MODELS
NEED TO BE ADDED TO REALLY MEET
THE NEEDS OF THE OF THEIR
POPULATION.
SO WE ARE IN CURRENT CURRENT COM
WHAT THEIR NEEDS ARE.
AND YOU ALSO WANTED TO KNOW WHAT
ADDITIONAL COUNTIES WOULD
RECEIVE FUNDING FROM THE
EXPANSION.
AND AT THIS POINT WE DON'T HAVE
MONEY FOR ALL COUNTY SO WE
REALLY WANT TO GO THROUGH OUR
SYSTEMATIC NEEDS ASSESSMENT
PROCESS TO REALLY IDENTIFY WHERE
THE GAPS IN SERVICES WHERE THE
GAPS IN HOME VISITING.
AND THEN HOW TO REALLY MEET THE
GAPS WITH THIS AT NEW ADDITIONAL
FUNDING [inaudible]
OKAY ALEJO
AS FOR ANY MEDICAL ALE AND WE
JUST SINCE YOU DO HERE --
THE DEPARTMENTS AND DIFFERENT --
IN DIFFERENT HEARING SO WE
THOUGHT IT MIGHT BE HELPFUL TO
ALSO PROVIDE SOME CONTEXT ABOUT
HOME VISITING OVERALL IN THE
STATE.
SO CURRENTLY THERE'S HOME
VISITING THAT'S THE HOME
VISITING PROGRAM IN C. PH --
JUST THIS YEAR THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES STARTED ITS HOME
VISITING PROGRAM IN THE CAL
WORKS.
OF WITH THE CAL WORKS FAMILIES --
FIRST FIVE ALSO HAS HOME
VISITING PROGRAM AS WELL AS
EARLY HEAD START AND THEN SOME
OTHER LOCAL PROGRAM SO.
WITH THIS PROPOSAL AND THEN
WHAT'S BEING SPENT IN THE CAL
WORKS PROGRAM --
WE ESTIMATE THIS WOULD NEARLY
DOUBLE.
THE AMOUNT BEING SPENT RELATIVE.
TO EIGHTEEN A DREADFULLY DOUBLE
THE AMOUNT OF SPENDING ON HOME
VISITING.
OKAY THANK YOU FINANCE
[inaudible]
RIGHT --
OKAY SO --
APPRECIATE INVESTMENT HOME
VISITING IS SOMEONE WHO IS A FOR
A FORMER FIRST FIVE
COMMISSIONERS A PEDIATRICIAN
STUDIED HOME VISITING --
AND THIS AND LOOK AT THE
RESEARCH ABOUT IMPACTS CERTAINLY
YELLOW WE TALK ABOUT THE TWO
MODELS SO WE START WITH --
NURSE FAMILY PARTNERSHIP IN.
HAS AMERICA I MEAN CERTAINLY FOR
EXAMPLE THERE SPENDING
PARTNERSHIP ABLE TO MODEL
EXTENSIVE EVALUATION ABOUT ITS
EFFECTIVENESS I THINK THE
CONCERN IS --
OTHER INTENSIVE USES VERY HIGHLY
TRAINED PERSONNEL ALSO TEND TO
BE FAIRLY EXPENSIVE --
AND AND SO I GUESS.
THE UNDERSTAND YOU IN YOUR
TESTIMONY SAID YOU'RE SER
WORKING WITH THE LOCALS ABOUT
LOOKING AT OTHER MODELS BUT I
GUESS THE OTHER PART THOUGH.
AND I REALIZE SOMETIMES THERE
MAY BE A BIT OF A POSSE OF DATA
IS IS THAT WE ALSO WANT TO BE
SURE.
IS THAT THE MODELS THAT THERE
THAT THIS IS ALSO BASED ON
EVALUATION DATA SHOWS THAT
MODELS EFFECTIVE RIGHT --
SO AND A NEW STAND AND SERVE THE
HOME VISITING WORLD PEOPLE.
NOW DAVID TRYING TO LOOK FOR
LESS EXPENSIVE LESS INTENSIVE
MODELS AND WE HEAR SACRAMENTO WE
WE WE HAD DINNER SALLY
PARTNERSHIP WE ALSO BIRTH AND
BEYOND AND SO FORTH AND I I I I
THINK THAT --
CERTAINLY OF COURSE WE WANT TO
WORK WITH THE OF THE LOCAL HELP
YOU BUY BE ASKING THIS BUT I
MEAN YOU NEED TO ALSO PEOPLE
NEED TO SHOW THE EVIDENCE THAT
THEIR MODEL.
WORKS RIGHT WHAT THAT IS HOW HOW
MUCH IMPACT THAT PARTICULAR
MODEL BECAUSE I MY GUESS IS IS
THAT I DON'T KNOW ALL THE
DIFFERENT MODELS THAT MY GUESS
IS THAT.
THE NURSE FAMILY PARTNERSHIP IS
PROBABLY THE MOST INTENSIVE WITH
HOW THIS HIGHLY TRAINED FOR
STYLE THING SOME OF THE MODELS
ARE EVEN MORE SO THAN THAT
THAT'S KIND OF LIKE THAT SO THE
AND USUALLY PEOPLE ARE LOOKING
AT HOW CAN I DO IT.
FOR YOU KNOW STRETCH MY DOLLARS
FATHER REACH MORE FAMILIES IT'S
UNDER A LOTS OF VERY IMPORTANT
GOOD REASONS --
BUT AT SAME TIME FORCE --
YELLED THEN THE QUESTION IS IS
THAT WHAT KIND OF IMPACT EVERY
GO STILL ACHIEVE THE SAME KIND
OF OUTCOMES THAT WE HAD WITH THE
OTHER MODELS SO --
THEN KNOWING THAT FIRST FIVE
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED A LOT I MEAN
THOUGH THAT MAY THE FIRST FIVE
TO DONE EVALUATION TO LOOK AT
SOME OF THAT EVALUATION DATA AND
SAY OKAY NOW ONLY.
YOU KNOW I KNOW THIS IS THE
MODEL YOU USING BUT WHAT KIND OF
VALUATION DO YOU HAVE THAT SHOWS
THAT THIS IS.
GOING TO BE EFFECTIVE ONE MAKE
THAT INVESTMENT IS WE'RE LOOKING
AT WHICH MODELS WHAT ACTUALLY.
I GUESS TECHNICALLY ADOPTER
CHURCHES ARE EXCEPT FOR FOR THIS
KIND OF FUNDING SIDE OF YOU ADD
ANY COMMENTS ABOUT THAT.
WELL WITH IT HFA MODEL WE DO
COLLECT DATA SO WE'RE VERY AWARE
OF OF THE NEED TO COLLECT DATA
AND ACTUALLY SO RESULTS AND SO
THAT WILL BE A CRITERIA WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT OUR AT OUR
COUNTIES LIKE WHAT MODELS ARE
YOU CURRENTLY.
ALSO UTILIZING IN YOUR COUNTY
AND HOW ARE YOU COLLECTING DATA
SO WE DO HAVE THAT COMMITMENT TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND HOW THIS
INVESTMENT IS REALLY GOING TO
CHANGE LIVES.
AND NOT JUST.
TO START UP A MODEL AND NOT AND
THEN WALK AWAY FROM THAT WE HOW
WE ARE IMPLEMENTING OUR OTHER.
MODELS OKAY AND I UNDERSTAND THE
HHS HAS A CIVIL LIST THE
DIFFERENT MODELS THAT THEY'VE
HAD.
IN THE TRAITOR EFFECTIVENESS
SELF.
ALL RIGHT I COULD ADD TO THIS
PLEASE WE WE WILL BEGIN BY
LOOKING OUT THE TWENTY MODELS
THAT HAVE BEEN REVIEWED AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AS BEING EVIDENCE
BASED MODELS.
BUT WHAT'S IMPORTANT REMEMBERS
THAT NOT EVERY EVIDENCE BASED
MODEL COMES WITH NOT ONLY THE
IMPLEMENTATION BUT THE TRAINING
AND A DATA PLATFORM RIGHT SO
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TO ALSO
ESTIMATE AS YOU KNOW WHAT COMES
ALREADY PREPARED WHAT WOULD WE
HAVE TO DEVELOP.
AND I ALSO WANT TO ADD THAT --
WHILE HOME VISITING --
IN GENERAL.
I BELIEVE THERE'S A LOT OF
BENEFIT FOR VULNERABLE FAMILIES.
THERE IS A HUGE BURDEN ON LOCAL
COUNTY'S AND TRYING TO
COORDINATE THESE EFFORTS AND
THAT TOO WE'RE INVOLVED WITH OUR
LOCAL M. C. H. DIRECTORS ABOUT.
YOU KNOW HOW DO YOU CHOOSE WHAT
TO PUT WOMEN IN WHAT ARE THE
DIFFERENT OPTIONS HOW DO YOU
TRIAGE AND HOW DO YOU MAKE THOSE
TO SORT DECISIONS AND THEN
IDEALLY WE WOULD.
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO GET TO SO
THEN WHAT WHAT DID YOU HOPE TO
ACHIEVE IN DID YOU ACHIEVE WHAT
YOU WANTED BUT THAT REFER ALL.
SO IT'S IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY THAT
COMES WITH A BURDEN.
ON NOT ONLY FOR FOR US TO HELP
TO GUIDE THIS DISCUSSION BUT A
HUGE BURDEN FOR OUR LOCALS TO TO
MANAGE RIGHT NOW.
WELL I THINK THERE'S STILL LIKE
A PRE SHEET THE VESTMENTS IN
HOME VISITATION --
BOTH BY THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION THAT WE PUT IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET AND ALSO SO
AND ALSO.
I THINK ABOUT HOW THE DIFFERENT
PIECES COORDINATE EIGHT GOV AND
IT'S GREAT WE HAVE LOCAL FOLKS
TO STEPPED UP THE NINE YOU'LL
SUPPORTED.
FUNDING FOR THAT WHEN I WAS ON
THE FIRST FIVE COMMISSION WAY
BACK ACTIVITY AND AND THEN THE
STATE INVESTMENT TO AND BE SURE
THAT WE TRY TO COORDINATE
BETWEEN THEM CELL.
IF IT'S HELPFUL TO YOU WE ALSO
CO LEAD THE STATE INTERAGENCY
TOYS ON ON HOME VISITING I
PLEDGE TO HERE'S AN INTERAGENCY
TEAM OUT OF THIS.
SO IT WAS ORIGINALLY --
WE STARTED THAT AS WHEN HOME
VISITING FEDERAL DOLLARS CAME
HERE BUT SINCE CAL WORKS IS NOW
INVOLVED WE'VE EXPANDED THEM IN
PERSON I ALSO PARTICIPATE SO
WE'RE MAKING AN EFFORT AT THE
STATE LEVEL TO COORDINATE AND
MARK FUHRMAN ANOTHER.
ALL RIGHT EXCELLENT [inaudible]
OKAY.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS ARE A TO
ISSUE NUMBER TEN BLACK INFANT
HEALTH PROGRAM EXPANSION.
SO AGAIN ALI WILL GIVE AN
OVERVIEW AND THEN ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS --
ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA'S HAS
EXPERIENCED SIGNIFICANT DECLINES
IN ITS OVERALL IN THE MORTALITY
RATE AND IS CURRENTLY RANKS
THIRD IN THE NATION WITH THE
LOWEST INFANT MORTALITY RATE.
THE RATE OF MORTALITY AMONG
BLACK ADMINS DYING BEFORE THEIR
FIRST BIRTHDAY CONTINUES TO BE
MORE THAN TWO TIMES HIGHER THAN
THE RATE AMONGST WHITE INFANTS.
CALIFORNIA ALSO RANKS FIRST IN
THE NATION WITH THE LOWEST
MATERNAL MORTALITY RATE GET
AFRICAN AMERICAN MOTHERS.
NEARLY FOUR DIE NEARLY FOUR
TIMES AS LONG EXCUSE ME.
AFRICAN AMERICAN MOTHERS ARE
NEARLY FOUR TIMES AS LIKELY TO
DIE FROM PREGNANCY RELATED
CAUSES THAN WHITE MOTHERS.
IMPROVEMENTS IN CLOSING THE GAP
BETWEEN BLACK AND WHITE INTENT
AND MATURE MATERNAL MORTALITY
RATES HAVE BEEN MADE IN
CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE SO
ALL FAMILIES REGARDLESS OF RACE
REALIZE THEIR DREAMS.
OUR REQUEST CITY PH REQUEST
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION IN
STATE GENERAL FUND.
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY AND ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER TO EXPAND THE B. I.
H. PROGRAM TO IMPROVE BLACK
MATERNAL AND INFANT HEALTH.
M. C. H. C. PH M. CH REQUEST
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE EXPANSION
OF THE B. I. H. MODEL INCLUDING
ADDING STRATEGIES TO INCREASE
PARTICIPANT RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION.
DATA COLLECTION EXPANSION OF B.
I. H. SITES AS WELL AS MODEL
REFINEMENT.
IN YEAR ONE WE PLAN TO COMPLETE
OUR FINAL B. I. H. ANALYSIS ON
OUR MODEL.
WE WANT TO INVEST IN THE
EXPANSION AND RETENTION OF
PARTICIPANTS THAT CURRENT B. I.
H. SITES WE PLAN TO EXPAND THE
CURRENT B. I. H. DATABASE AND
SET PERFORMANCE MEASURES.
AND WE WANT TO DEVELOP A
STATEWIDE CAMPAIGN.
AND YOUR TO WE WILL CONDUCT A B.
I. H. MODEL REVISION BASED ON
OUR EVALUATION RESULTS WE WILL
PROVIDE TA TO OUR EXISTING B. I.
H. SITES.
AS WELL AS RELEASE AN RFA TO
ALLOW FOR THE EXPANSION OF B. I.
H. TO NEWLY TARGETED VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES.
IN YOUR THREE WE WILL COLLECT
AND ANALYZE DATA PERFORMANCE
MEASURES HOMEOWNER MODEL.
AND MONITOR PROGRESS.
YOU WANTED TO UNDERSTAND HOW.
THE EXISTING ALLOCATIONS.
OF THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET
FOR THE P. THE CALIFORNIA P. P.
AYE INITIATIVE WILL COORDINATE
WITH THIS WITH THESE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES.
WE WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT AT ITS
CORE B. I. H. IS IS ADDRESSING
TOXIC STRESS AMONG AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMEN.
AND P. E. I. A IS GOING TO FUND
THOSE WRAPAROUND SERVICES TO
SUPPORT THOSE WOMEN.
WHAT YOU MAY NOT NOTICE EACH
YEAR IN CALIFORNIA NEARLY TWENTY
THREE THOUSAND AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMEN GET GIVE BIRTH?
THE H. IS ABLE TO TOUCH NEARLY
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED OF THOSE
PREGNANT WOMEN.
WE ARE ABLE TO UTILIZE THIS NEW
APPROPRIATION OF RESOURCES TO
COLLABORATE WITH COUNTIES AND
THE BLACK COMMUNITY ON THE
DEVELOPMENT OF COMPREHENSIVE
ROBUST STRATEGIES TO REALLY
REDUCE THE BLACK WHITE DISPARITY
GAP.
WE KNOW THAT NOT ALL WOMEN ARE
ABLE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO TOUCH
OUR INTERESTED IN OUR BLACK
INFANT HEALTH MODEL.
OR ABLE TO MAKE IT THROUGH THE
V. I. H. PROGRAM RIGHT NOW AS AS
IT'S DESIGNED THEREFORE WE WILL
USE THE ADDITIONAL BE ICE
DOLLARS TO IMPROVE RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION.
AND RESULTING IN MORE WOMEN
BEING ABLE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE B. H. MODEL AND THE
ADDITIONAL P. E. I RESOURCES
WILL ABLE WILL BE THE WRAPAROUND
SERVICES FOR THOSE WOMEN NOT
INTERESTED IN PARTICIPATING IN
THE I. H..
OR DON'T HAVE THE LEVEL OF NEED
OR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE MODEL.
WE KNOW THAT BECAUSE NOTHING WE
DON'T HAVE A SOLID WE DON'T HAVE
SECRET SAUCE YET WE DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT IS GOING TO TURN
THE CURVE.
ON THIS PROBLEM IT'S GONNA TAKE
EVERYONE WORKING TOGETHER TO
REALIZE SUSTAINED IMPROVEMENT
CURRENTLY WE ARE WORKING LOCALLY
WITH OUR LOCAL AND C. H.
DIRECTORS AS WELL AS STATE
LEADERS TO REALLY.
THINK OUT LOUD TOGETHER ABOUT
THE INEQUITIES AND HOW TO REALLY
CLOSE TO THE GAPS WE KNOW THAT
RESULTS ARE IMPORTANT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THE INVESTMENT IS
GETTING WHAT WE WANT.
SO WE'RE GOING TO BE USING
RESULTS BASIC WORK GOING TO
TEACH THE COUNTIES ABOUT RESULTS
BASED ACCOUNTABILITY AND WE WILL
BE USING THAT SO THAT WE CAN
COME BACK REPORT ON THE PROGRESS
THAT WE'VE MADE.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU LA L..
FINANCE.
RIGHT --
NIGHT AT THE REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT THE NEAR HERE IN SACRAMENTO
HAD EFFORT THAT --
THAT THAT MADE A SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION AND IT'S VERY
UNFORTUNATE ELIMINATE THE
SEVERITY BUT MADE A SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION AND EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT --
WE CONTINUE TO INVEST.
AND AND THIS AND TRY IN AN
EFFORT -- TO
REAL.
ELIMINATE THESE DISPARITIES NOW
COURTS TO CHALLENGE ABOUT
LEADING THE DISPARITY IS IS THAT
FORTUNATELY PART OF THE SPACE
YOU MENTION TOXIC STRESS COMES
FROM -- YOU
KNOW OUR GENERAL BACKGROUND OF
SOCIETY RACISM OTHER TYPES OF
THINGS THAT ARE HOW RIGHT NOT
GOOD ACTUALLY ELIMINATE
DISPARITY ITSELF BUT WE
CERTAINLY SHOULD TRY TO PROVIDE
THE KIND OF SUPPORT SIN.
PROGRAMS --
FOR THOSE WHO ARE INTERESTED TO
THAT WOULD HELP AT LEAST --
REDUCE THAT MEANTIME I THINK
WE'VE GOT TO THINK OF OTHER
THINGS WE DO.
TO GET AT THE ROOT OF THE
PROBLEM FOR NOT ONLY OFFER THEM.
THE AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
AND ALSO THE COMMUNITY IS WELL.
SO APPRECIATE --
THIS THIS INVESTMENT AND
HOPEFULLY I I KNOW THAT YOU FIVE
FROM BELIEVES WHAT'S GOING ON
SACRAMENTO INSECT MY COUNTY.
CLIP FRIED TO SOME SOME --
SOME --
INFORMATION THAT'S USEFUL AS
WITH AFFORD THEM.
A ALL RIGHT HOUSE MOVE ON THE
ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE HITS JACK'S --
JEGS THE SCREENING PROGRAM LOCAL
ASSISTANCE ESTIMATE.
FIRST ONE MORE UP WEBSITES GIVE
SOMETHING [inaudible]
WELL. TEN THIRTY SOMEONE HERE.
FOR WHEN I S. MATERNAL CHILD
HEALTH --
ALISON HEALTH MEDICAL OVERSTATED
I THINK MY PIECE OF PAPER
SLIPPED OUT.
YES NUMBER.
ELEVEN SO WE ARE REQUESTING FIVE
PERMANENT POSITIONS AND SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND ON GOING EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY HALF OF WHICH WOULD BE
STATE GENERAL FUND AND THE OTHER
HALF WOULD BE REIMBURSED
MAJORITY --
SINCE TWO THOUSAND HOUSE
SERVICES THESE PROGRAMS INCLUDE
BLACK INFANT HEALTH.
ARE ADOLESCENT FAMILY LIFE
PROGRAM OUR INFORMATION
EDUCATION PROGRAM AS WELL AS THE
GENERAL M. C. H. FUNDING THAT WE
GIVE TO LOOK HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS.
HISTORICALLY THIS TITLE NINETEEN
PROGRAM HS BEEN MANAGED BY THE
DEPARTMENT AS A PASS THROUGH
FUNDING TO THE LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS WITH VERY MINIMAL
PROCESSING --
LAST YEAR LAST FISCAL YEAR DH CS.
REVIEWED OUR TITLE NINETEEN
INTERAGENCY AGREEMENT AND
COMMUNICATED SOME OVERSIGHT
REQUIREMENTS THAT THEY HAD FOR
US THAT WERE NOT BE HAD BEEN.
HAD NOT BEEN REQUIRED IN THE
PAST BUT ARE IMPORTANT FOR
FEDERAL AUDITING PURPOSES AND SO
EFFECTIVE JUNE FOURTH OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN DH CS BEGAN
REQUIRING THE SUBMISSION OF
SECONDARY DOCUMENTATION WITH
EVERY INVOICE.
THAT SUBMITTED BY CA CV PH TO
VERIFY THE DRAWDOWN OF TITLE
NINETEEN REIMBURSEMENTS --
THE COLLECTION OF THAT SECONDARY
DOCUMENTATION WAS AN EXISTING
CONTRACT REQUIREMENT FOR THE
LOCAL AGENCIES BUT HAD NEVER
BEEN A REQUIREMENT THAT THAT BE
SUBMITTED TO THE DEPARTMENT --
SELECTING OUR REQUIREMENT FOR US
OF THESE ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS
AN INCREASE THE NEED FOR M. C.
H. PERSONNEL TO CARRY OUT THIS
TASK [inaudible]
HELLO.
THE FENCE NOW.
OKAY AND JUST TO CLARIFY SO --
TO THIS IS ABOUT THIS IS TITLE
NINE SO WE DO WE HAVE ALSO HAVE
A TITLE FIVE MC EACH BLOCK GRANT
FROM THE FEDS.
AND THAT SEPARATE [inaudible]
POT.
V. V. LOCALS YOU.
THE THE LOCAL AGENCIES USE LOCAL
DOLLARS TO AUGMENT THEIR TITLE
FIVE BUDGETS O DRIVE DOWN
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FROM TITLE
NINETEEN TO SUPPLEMENT THOSE
ACTIVITIES OF THE USER.
ID MY DIFFERENT TITLES YEAH
FEDERAL FUNDS SO ACTUALLY EASY
TO FIVE TWO TWO DRAW DOWN MORE.
OKAY SO ACTUALLY VISITED THE A
GAS BLOWBACK ON HERE SO AT OF
TITLE NINETEEN THIS FUNDING.
FOR MEDI CAL ASSISTANCE IT'S
AMERICA MEDI CAL DOLLARS
MEDICARE IT'S ON THE CONNECTICUT
KNOWLEDGE OKAY RIGHT AND WHAT
WERE USING IT FOR SPECIFICALLY
WITH IN OUR TITLE NINETEEN
PROGRAM ANY TITLE FIVE PROGRAMS.
TO THEN CONNECT MEDI CAL
PATIENTS WITH CERTAIN EXCEPTIONS
GALLAGHER AND RUN OUT.
OKAY SO THIS SO BASICALLY WHAT
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR HERE AND THIS
REQUEST IS ACTUALLY. TO GET
GREATER OVERSIGHT DESIGN A CMS
IS MONEY THAT WE'RE SEEING THIS
NOW IN THIS IN THE MENTAL HEALTH
AND OTHER TYPES OF THINGS WE'VE
BEEN DOING THAT PLACES. TO BE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THAT KIND OF
OVERSIGHT.
NOW LADIES ASK ANOTHER QUESTION
SO ASIDE FROM WHAT CS ONCE THEY
USUALLY WANT BETTER BILLING AND
NOW TRACKING ETCETERA.
IT IS THAT ARE WE ASKING EVERY
GETTING THE KIND OF INFORMATION
WE NEED TO IN TERMS OF OVERSIGHT
TO KNOW --
TO BE SURE WE HAVE DATA ON THE
HOUSE ACTIVELY THE MONEY'S BEING
USED BY OUR VARIOUS LOCALITIES.
BUT A PALM.
THEY REPORT ANNUALLY TO US ON
THEIR TITLE FIVE ACTIVITIES
CONCERN. FOR THOSE ACTIVITIES
AND THEY TELL US WHICH OF THOSE
ARE.
ALL ADDITIONAL TITLE NINE OKAY
PORT FOR THOSE ACTIVITIES AND
THEN THOSE REPORTS ARE SUBMITTED
TO THE BAND SO WE MONITOR WHAT
THEY DO WITH THE MONEY OKAY SO
SO YOU YOU HAVE.
THROUGH YOUR TITLE FIVE
REPORTING SERVICES DOCUMENTS YOU
ACTUALLY YOU DO YOU ARE GETTING
DATA ABOUT THE HOUSE ACT OF WHAT
THEY'RE SPENDING THE MONEY ON
HOW EFFECTIVE THEY WHAT KIND OF
RESULTS ARE GETTING FROM THAT.
WE KNOW WHAT THEY'RE SPENDING
THEIR MONEY ON I DON'T WANT TO
MISLEAD YOU THAT I KNOW ALL OF
THE PERFORMANCE MEASURES OF
EFFECTIVENESS OF THEM BUT WE DO
KNOW WHAT THEIR GOALS ARE AND IF
THEY'RE MEETING THEIR CALLS.
OKAY ITSELF NOT ONLY TO GOALS
FOR THE MONITOR MEETING THEM OR
NOT.
ALL RIGHT THAT'S THAT OKAY.
SOMETIMES I GET THE WELL THEY
SAY THEY'RE GOING TO DO THIS I
DON'T KNOW DAY DOING IT OR NOT.
DAY DID AS A DATE BUT THEY'RE
DOING IDEA ACTUALLY TV WHAT
THEY'RE GOOD DAY THEY SAID THERE
IT'S JUST THAT SOME OF THE
PERFORMANCE MEASURES ARE NOT
ALWAYS ALWAYS EFFECTIVENESS
MEASURES CHAIR.
RIGHT TO WRITE DIFFERENT
MEASURES CLARIFIED THAT OKAY ALL
RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OKAY.
ALL RIGHT I GUESS NOW WITHOUT TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE GENETIC
DISEASE SCREENING PROGRAM LOCAL
SUS AN ESTIMATE.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME IF YOU CAN INTRODUCE
YOURSELF FOR THE RECORD.
I'M RICHARD ONLY I'M THE
DIVISION CHIEF FOR THE TONIGHT
EGGS THE SCREEN PROGRAM.
AND I'M GONNA START OUT THE BY
GIVING YOU JUST AN OVERVIEW OF
THE CASE LOWER EXPENDITURE
CHANGES --
FOR BOTH OUR NEWBORN SCREENING
PROGRAM PRENATAL SCREENING
PROGRAM.
SO FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY OF THE GPS GDS
P. ESTIMATE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET SHOWS TOTAL EXPENDITURES
OF JUST OVER A HUNDRED AND FORTY
ONE MILLION.
WAS TO REMIND YOU OUR FEES
SUPPORTED THROUGH THE GENETIC
DISEASE TESTING FONG.
AND THAT REPRESENTS AN INCREASE
OF ABOUT SEVEN MILLION OVER THE
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN REVISION.
MORE THAN HALF OF THE INCREASE
IN OUR ESTIMATE FOR NINETEEN
TWENTY IS --
TO TO PROJECTED EXPENDITURES
REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH A
NEWBORN SCREENING EXPANSION
PROVISIONS.
ENACTED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
THROUGH YOUR INITIATIVE.
AS YOU KNOW WILL BE ADDING
SPINAL MUSCULAR ATROPHY OR
ESTIMATE TO THE CALIFORNIA
NEWBORN SCREENING PANEL AND
TWENTY TWENTY TO DO ITS ADDITION
TO THE FEDERAL RECOMMENDED
UNIFORM SCREENING PANEL AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND WE'VE TO
TELL THE THE SMA RELATED
INCREASES AND OUR NEWBORN
SCREENING BCP.
WHICH IS ISSUE THIRTEEN WILL
TALK ABOUT IN A MINUTE.
OTHER SMALL ADJUSTMENTS IN OUR
ESTIMATE FOR NINETEEN TWENTY DUE
TO CHANGES IN BOTH A NEWBORN
SCREENING AND PRENATAL SCREENING
CASELOADS.
BASED ON A PROJECTED DECREASES
AND THE NUMBER OF LIVE BIRTHS.
OUR BUDGET ESTIMATES A NEWBORN
SCREENING PROGRAM CASELOAD OF
ALMOST FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY NINE
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN TWENTY
THAT'S THE STATE WIDE BURSTS.
AND THAT'S A DECREASE OF ABOUT
TEN THOUSAND NEWBORNS HER 2%
COMPARED TO THE NUMBER.
LISTED -- IN.
FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FOR FOR
PRENATAL SCREENING BASED ON A
PARTICIPATION RATE OF 71%.
OUR BUDGET ESTIMATES --
OF PRENATAL SCREENING PROGRAM
CASELOAD OF ALMOST THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY TWO THOUSAND WHICH IS
A CORRESPONDING TO ABOUT.
TEN THOUSAND ABOUT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS OF THE TOTAL INCREASE IN
THE NINETEEN TWENTY GDP GDS P.
ESTIMATE REFLECTS INCREASED
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY FOR LOCAL
ASSISTANCE --
DUE TO CHANGING METHODOLOGIES
FRIDGE PROTECTING STRING
SCREENING COSTS.
INCREASED PRENATAL SCREENING
EXPENDITURES ACCOUNT FOR ABOUT
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION OF THAT
TOTAL AND APPROXIMATELY TWO
MILLION AS FOR NEWBORN SCREENING
COST INCREASES IN ADDITION TO
THOSE REQUIRED. FOR SMA.
SO BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU A THAT DELIVER THEM
FINANCE.
ALL RIGHT WILL ALWAYS GO AHEAD
AND MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ITEM
WHICH ALSO WRITTEN THE WORDS
FREE.
SERVICE.
SO THIS IS OUR NEWBORN SCREENING --
BC P. AND WITH PROJECTED --
JUST OVER FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
IN INCREASED EXPENDITURES OF
FROM THE GENETIC DISEASE TESTING
FUN -- WHICH
INCLUDES SEVERAL POSITIONS TO BE
PHASED IN OVER OF THE NINETEEN
TWENTY FISCAL YEAR FOR NEW
LABORATORY IN FOLLOW UP STAFF.
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER THESE NEW
EXPENDED EXPENDITURES WILL BE
REQUIRED.
FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF STATEWIDE
SMA NEWBORN SCREENING AND TWENTY
TWENTY TO COMPLY WITH OUR
STATUTORY MANDATE.
AND WILL BE EXPANDING SCREENING
THROUGH LABORATORY DEVELOPED.
INCLUDING NEW INSTRUMENTS RESUME
AT OUR RICHMOND LABORATORY --
CONCERN NO FDA APPROVED A
NEWBORN SCREENING.
AND THE NEW PERSONNEL WILL BE
REQUIRED TO DEVELOP --
VALIDATE VERIFY AND ULTIMATELY
CARRY OUT THE ON GOING PROCESSES
A SCREENING FOR US A MAN OUR LAB.
AND A RELATED ACTIVITIES SUCH AS
CHANGES IN OUR FOLLOW UP PROCESS
THROUGH A SCREENING INFORMATION
SYSTEM AND EDUCATION RELATED TO
ABNORMAL SCREENING RESULTS.
A AS WE DID WHEN WE BEGAN
SCREENING FOR TWO DISORDERS AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN GDS P. PLANS TO
CARRY OUT ALL PROCESSES FOR
IMPLEMENTATION ON SCHEDULE.
AND SO WE HAVE NO CURRENT
CONCERNS ABOUT THE EXPECTED
LAUNCH OF A SEMI SCREENING BY
JULY.
TWENTY TWENTY OKAY THANK YOU --
ACTUALLY IN OUR REPORT THE
RESCINDED BASICALLY SAYING
BETWEEN 200-019-82000 AND NINE
FOURTEEN MILLION THEY HAD SAID.
DETECTION AND TO EAT AT OVER
THERE DO WE HAVE MORE RECENT
DATA WAS THAT THE ARE WAS THAT
AN ERROR ENDED AND AND DATE.
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE YOU WITH
MORE AND MORE RECENTLY OKAY YEAH
BETWEEN THE NINETEEN EIGHTY
THOUSAND NINE SECONDS NOW 201-9
BUT I'D THIS CLUE.
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING ON CBO CATCHING THESE
CONDITIONS EARLY.
OFTENTIMES THE DAMAGES RAPE AND
THAT A LOT OF DAMAGE THREE BEEN
DONE SO --
APPRECIATE THE THE PART IT'S
HARD WORK IN IMPLEMENTING --
OF THE BILL THAT I AUTHORED AND
MAKING SURE ITSELF THAT SAVING
LIVES SELF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
EIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS ALL
RIGHT AND LOOK FORWARD WE HAVE
ANOTHER CONDITION WE CAN.
THEY'VE MARKETS WITH CELLS.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL
RIGHT SO WELL WHAT WE'LL DO NOW
IS WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENTS ON
ISSUES I GUESS TWO THROUGH --
THIRTEEN SO I THINK WE'LL DO IS
THIS IF YOU'RE ONLY CUT AND SO I
NORMALLY HAVE A ONE MINUTE RULE
VOTE SINCE TERE'S SO MANY ITEMS.
IF YOU'RE TALKING JUST ABOUT ONE
OF THE CHANGES IF YOU TRY TO
KEEP WITH A MINUTE THAT'S GREAT
IF YOU HAVE A COUPLE MORE I'M
GONNA GIVE YOU A FEW MORE
MINUTES BECAUSE I KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF YOU HAVE THE WHOLE TIME
AND I GUESS SO WILL.
WILL BE FLEXIBLE BUT ALSO BATES
JUST -- ALSO
URGE PEOPLE --
TO TO GENERALLY BE BRIEF BUT I
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
COME AND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MICHELLE GIVENS WITH
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND WANTED TO
PROVIDE COMMENTS ON A FEW ITEMS
TODAY --
RELATED TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR WHO
WANTED TO THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THEIR
COMMITMENT TO KEEPING THE LOCAL
ORAL HEALTH PROGRAMS HOLE --
AS DOCTOR KUMAR STATED THERE'S A
LOT OFPROCESS IS GOING ON
AROUND EVALUATION AND SCREENINGS
AND SO FORTH AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT WERE CONTINUE SO
WE APPECIATE THAT COMMITMENT
THERE.
EMIGRATING ISSUE NINE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HOME VISITING PROGRAM
AND CHECK IS VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO BE A PART OF THE
CONVERSATION AS THE ADDITIONAL
MODELS ARE BEING EXPLORED THERE
ARE A WHOLE HOST OF EVIDENCE
BASED MODELS BUT THERE COULD.
ALSO BE SOME THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
EVIDENCE BASE THAT CALIFORNIA
CONTEST OUT AND CREE EVIDENCE
AROUND AND SO WE'D LIKE THAT
CONVERSATION TO BE MUCH BROADER --
FOR THE BLACK INFANT HOLD
PROGRAM AND WE TO SUPPORT --
THE ADMINISTRATION'S
THOUGHTFULNESS AND INVESTMENT
INTO ADDRESSING --
AFRICAN AMERICAN INFANT
MORTALITY HOWEVER WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN TOLD FROM OUR LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS WHO I AM AND
MINISTER THE PROGRAMS IS THAT
IT'S VERY PRESCRIPTIVE IN
DIFFICULT AND WE'RE NOT
NECESSARILY SEEING THE RESULTS
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO IN ALL OF
THE JURISDICTIONS.
AND SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT THINGS
THAT HAVE BEEN INNOVATIVE SUCH
AS WHAT SACRAMENTO COUNTY IS
DONE WE WOULD LIKE THE
CONVERSATION TO ME BUT TO BE
MUCH BROADER.
AND THAT WE'RE NOT ONLY
EXPANDING THE PROGRAM --
AWAY TO EVALUATE THE EFFICIENCY
SO THAT WE CAN BE SUCCESSFUL AS
A WHOLE.
AND LASTLY AROUND ISSUE ELEVEN
AM JUST RECOGNIZING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO HAVE
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS FOR AND
THEIR MATERNAL CHILD ADOLESCENT
HEALTH PROGRAM AND FROM A
STAFFING PERSPECTIVE.
WE JUST WANNA RECOGNIZE THE
CHANGES TO THE LOCAL LEVEL AS
WELL IN TERMS OF THE AMOUNT OF
REPORTING THAT WE'RE HAVING TO
PROVIDE --
BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT SO WE
HOPE THAT AS THEY CONSIDER THOSE
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS THAT THEY
WOULD PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE DOWN TO THE
LOCALS AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SUSAN TO
MORRIS ON BEHALF OF THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL HIS ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE
PROGRAM.
AND I WOULD JUST UNDERSCORE THE
IMPORTANCE OF RESEARCH INTO
WOMEN AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR --
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT AND I
WOULD NOTE THAT RESEARCH IS FOR
THE FUTURE AND WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH TO ADOPT AN
APPROACH TODAY THAT REACHES
PEOPLE WHO ARE AFFECTED BY THE
DISEASE NOW.
IN THE COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME HELLO MY
NAME'S KAREN FARLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WITH ASSOCIATION.
AND I WANTED TO UNDERSCORE THE
GRAY EFFORT THE STATE AND LOCAL
STAFF FOR DOING TO MODERNIZE THE
PROGRAM.
IN WHICH PARTICIPANTS WILL
ALWAYS BE YOUNG AND THEY EXPECT
A LOT OF TECHNOLOGY WHEN THEY GO
TO DO BUSINESS SO GETTING THE
EBT CARDS IN THE NEW AND MY
SYSTEM ARE IMPORTANT.
BUT THE STATE PROGRAM IN THE
LOCALS NEED A LOT OF HELP INTO
INTRODUCING OTHER TECHNOLOGY AND
EVEN YOU KNW THE COMPLICATIONS
THAT COME WITH THAT.
BUT PARTICIPANTS EXPECT TEXTING
THEY EXPECT VIDEO CONFERENCING.
IN AT A STATE LEVEL IF WE CAN
REALLY EXT EXPEDITE HORIZONTAL
INTEGRATION SO THAT WE CAN
MAXIMALLY INCREASE PARTICIPATION
AND CAL FOR OCEAN.
MEDI CAL AND WORK THAT WOULD BE
REALLY HELPFUL IN ALL THIS
TECHNOLOGY AND OF RISK
MANAGEMENT QUESTIONS COME INTO
THAT BUT THAT'S VITALLY
IMPORTANT --
SECONDLY I BROUGHT THIS UP THE
LAST TWO YEARS THE LOCAL
AGENCIES HAVE FOUR YEAR GRANT
CONTRACTS WITH THE STATE.
IN THOSE CONTRACTS --
WERE QUITE INFLEXIBLE AND IT WAS
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO SPEND ALL
THEIR MONEY SO WHEN YOU COMBINE
THAT WITH DECREASED
PARTICIPATION.
IT'S ONLY GOING TO INCREASE THE
FEDERAL DOLLARS THAT.
IN THE STATE STAFF HAS WORKED
REALLY DILIGENTLY TO WORK ON
THIS CONTRACT IS VERY
CHALLENGING BUT THEY REALLY NEED
SUPPORT TO BE ABLE TO SPEND
THOSE DOLLARS WHEN THEY COME
HERE AND ADDRESS ALL THE THINGS
THAT COME UP.
IN SIX DIFFERENT TYPES OF PARENT
ORGANIZATIONS WITH CHANGING
FACTORS EACH YEAR.
AND THEN THIRDLY WE WOULD HOPE
THAT THE FISCAL SYSTEMS WORKING
SMOOTHLY --
WHICH HAS JUST BEEN WORKING WITH
THAT SYSTEM LAST FEW MONTHS AND
THERE'S BEEN SOME SERIOUS DELAYS
AND INVOICING.
AND THE STATE'S STAFF HAVE BEEN
WORKING REALLY HARD TO MAKE THAT
WORK BUT WHEN THE LOCAL AGENCIES
ARE HAVING TROUBLE MAKING
PAYROLL --
BECAUSE THE SYSTEM IS SLOW AND
THERE'S MULTIPLE STEPS WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU FOR ASKING A WITH KP
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF THE
NURSE FAMILY PARTNERSHIP HERE ON
THE GOVERNOR'S HOME VISITING
PROPOSAL VERY HAPPY TO SEE THAT
WE ARE LOOKING AT EXPANDING
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA HOME
VISITING PROGRAM.
AND THE ADMINISTRATION'S
COMMITMENT TO EARLY CHILDHOOD
ISSUES AS WELL IS THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE'S ONGOING
COMMITMENT OVER THE YEARS.
WE BELIEVE THAT AN OF P. IS WELL
POISED TO EXPAND WITH THE RIGHT
RESOURCES WE ARE HIGH TOUCH
MODEL WERE HIGH ACUITY MODEL
IT'S A TWO AND A HALF YEAR MODEL.
IF IT'S FOLLOWED TWO DURATION
AND WE BELIEVE THAT OUR OUTCOMES
REALLY SHINE THROUGH IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE CAN PROVE WITH OUR MOMS
AND FAMILIES.
AND BABIES ARE GOING THROUGH THE
PROGRAM SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
THE ADMINISTRATION ON THE
PROPOSAL TO ENSURE THAT THE
GREATEST NUMBER FAMILIES RECEIVE
THE SERVICES THAT THEY NEED. TO
BE HEALTHY AND FRIDAY THE AND
BEING INCLUDED IN THE
INTERAGENCY TASK FORCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
WHEN THE --
TO WHAT'S ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK A FEW ITEMS THAT WE HAVE
COMMENTS ON IN RESPONSE TO DPH
ISSUE NUMBER FOR THE ORAL HEALTH
PROGRAM WE'RE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL STAFF FOR
THIS PROGRAM.
OVER WERE CONCERNED WITH THE
REDUCTION OF FUNDS --
DEVOTED TO THE PROGRAM HOWEVER --
WE KNOW THAT ORAL HEALTH IS
CRITICALLY ON AND PARTICULARLY
FOR LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS --
WE KNOW THAT THE STATE ORAL
HEALTH PROGRAM PLAYS A CRITICAL
ROLE IN SUPPORTING LOCAL EFFORTS
TO PREVENT ORAL DISEASE AS WELL
AS PROVIDE CHILDREN WITH ACCESS
TO ORAL HEALTH LITERACY.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THIS PROGRAM
PROVIDES A STATE LEVEL FRAMEWORK
FOR EVALUATING --
OVERALL HEALTH STATUS OF
CALIFORNIANS --
WITH THAT SAID WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE REDUCTION OF THE FUNDS
FOR THAT PROGRAM THAT WOULD
REDUCE OFFERED AT THE LOCAL AND
STATE LEVEL AND WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER OTHER
FUNDING SOURCES. TO SUPPORT THIS
WORK -- IN
RESPONSE TO DPH ISSUE NUMBER --
FIVE WE SUPPORT THE INVESTMENT
INTO RESEARCH FOR TARGETING
ALZHEIMER'S.
IN IN REGARDS TO WOMEN AND
PARTICULARLY COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR A WE KNOW THAT.
NOT ENOUGH OF RESEARCH EXISTS
AMONG THIS POPULATION SO WE KNOW
WE HAVE TO CLOSE THESE LONG
STANDING GAPS.
WESLEY --
FOR DPH ISSUE NUMBER TEN OF THE
BLACK INFANT HEALTH PROGRAM --
WE SUPPORT ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR THIS PROGRAM AND WE KNOW
THAT THE SIGNIFICANT NEED IN
ADDRESSING THAT DISPARITY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON BRANAGH
PITTMAN SPENCER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION ON
TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR WE ARE VERY
PLEASED WITH THE WORK THAT
DOCOR KUMAR ANDY PETER DOING ON
IMPLEMENTING THE STATEOR HEALTH
PLAN.
WE WERE I'VE BEEN PART OF THAT
THAT EFFORT AND JUST REALLY
THINK THAT IT'S BEEN A GREAT JOB
WE'RE VERY GLAD TO SEE THAT
HAPPENING WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
HIS REQUEST --
FOR ADDITIONAL STAFF AND WE AS
WELL ARE VERY DISAPPOINTED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
REDUCE SOME FUNDING FROM THE
THIRTY MILLION IN OF PROPOSITION
FIFTY SIX WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT
THE AUTHORITY IS THERE --
BUT AGAIN I THINK I'VE MENTIONED
THIS IS REALLY I MEAN JUST
GETTING GOING GETTING ITS FEET
UNDER IT AND THE WE JUST DON'T
WANNA SEE ANY REDUCTION THERE WE
DO RECOGNIZE THAT I'M.
LOOKS LIKE THERE'S NOT GONNA BE
ANY CUTS TO THE LOCAL PROGRAMS
WHICH IS EXCELLENT TO HEAR.
THERE WERE SOME THINGS THAT HE
AYE DOCTOR KUMAR MENTIONED THAT
MAYBE CUT THAT WE ARE A LITTLE
CONCERNED AROUND ABOUT AROUND.
THE SURVEILLANCE CREATING AT YOU
KNOWN OVERS OVERSEEING IT DID
MORE DATA DE COMMUNITY WATER
FLUORIDATION AS WELL AS SOME OF
THE GRANT PROGRAM SO WE REALLY
ARE HOPING THAT THE FINAL BUDGET
WILL INCLUDE THAT THIRTY MILLION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON KATIE AND YOUR
CHILDREN NOW --
I JUST WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUES APPLE C. PEN
AND AND CDA AROUND ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR AND JUST.
ADD THAT SUSTAINING FUNDING --
FOR FOR THE STATE ORAL HEALTH
PROGRAM IS CRUCIAL TO BOTH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE STATE PLAN
AS WELL AS THE LOCAL PLANS THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
RIGHT SAYING NO ONE ELSE AT THE
MICROPHONE --
WE WILL BE HOLDING OPEN ISSUES
NUMBER 234-567-8910 ELEVEN
TWELVE AND THIRTEEN ALL RIGHT --
SO WE'RE GOOD NOW THE MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER FOURTEEN WITH
SEVERAL PROPOSALS FOR INVESTMENT.
AND SO WE'LL BEGIN WITH THE
FIRST IS THE STAKEHOLDER
PROPOSAL FOR TO IMPLEMENT A
STATEWIDE ALZHEIMER'S
INFRASTRUCTURE SO WE CAN HAVE
THE FOLKS COME UP --
AND APPROPRIATE FINANCE IN LA --
PEOPLE AT THE TABLE [inaudible]
AND ALL RIGHT.
OKAY WE GOT EVERYONE HERE
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY WELCOME THE TO PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF FOR THE
RECORD.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M SUSAN TO
MORRIS REPRESENTING THE
ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION IN
CALIFORNIA.
A GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR PAN AND
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS THANK YOU
FOR INCLUDING AGENDA TODAY --
SENATOR PAN I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK ON THE CHEST DATA
LAST YEAR AND INTRODUCING SB.
FIVE TWELVE EARLIER THIS WEEK
AND I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
DEMONSTRATED YOUR COMMITMENT TO
PLANNING FOR AN AGING POPULATION.
WE HEARD FROM GOVERNOR NEWSOME
IN HIS STATE OF THE STATE
ADDRESS WE CAN'T TALK ABOUT
AGING WITHOUT ADDRESSING
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE.
AND THAT'S WHAT I'M HERE TO DO
TODAY.
EARLIER WE HEARD FROM DOCTOR
SMITH ABOUT PROGRESS THAT WE'VE
MADE ON CHRONIC CONDITIONS IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THERE WAS ONE
NOTABLE OMISSION IN HER
PRESENTATION AND THAT WOULD BE
DISCUSSION OF ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE.
AND ARE OF PUBLIC HEALTH
MEASURING PUBLIC HEALTH STATUS
IN CALIFORNIA WE SHOW UP IS
NUMBER TWO ON THAT LIST AS THE
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH IN OUR
STATE --
WHAT WE DO KNOW TODAY ABOUT
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE IS THE
BURDEN IS LARGE TWO POINT TWO
MILLION CALIFORNIANS ARE
DIRECTLY IMPACTED?
IF THIS DISEASE WERE A CITY
WOULD BE THE SECOND LARGEST CITY
IN CALIFORNIA.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT HALF OF PEOPLE
WITH THIS CONDITION HAVE NOT
BEEN DIAGNOSED THEY DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO TREATMENT AND A PLAN
OF CARE.
BECAUSE THEY LACK A DIAGNOSIS.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THIS
POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA HAD
ABOUT NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND ER
VISITS LAST YEAR SO WE HEARD
ABOUT THE OPIOID OPIOID CRISIS
FROM DOCTOR SMITH WHERE THERE
WERE EIGHT THOUSAND ER VISITS
LAST YEAR.
A MANSION NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
E. R. VISITS.
WE HAVE A LOT OF INFORMATION WE
HAVE A STATE PLAN ON AGING --
OUR STATE PLAN ON ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE THAT WAS ADOPTED IN
TWENTY ELEVEN HIT WAS PASSED IN
THIS VERY ROOM BY SENATOR ALL
QUIST.
THE NUMBER ONE GOAL IN THAT PLAN
WAS TO ELIMINATE STIGMA AND TO
DEVELOP A STATEWIDE CULTURALLY
COMPETENT PUBLIC AWARENESS
CAMPAIGN WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR
THAT -- A
DECADE LATER.
WE ALSO HAVE THE PEOPLE TWENTY
TWENTY THAT HAVE NOT BEEN ACTED
ON IN CALIFORNIA ONE IS TO
IMPROVE DIAGNOSIS.
THE OTHER IS TO REDUCE HOSPITAL
ADMISSIONS.
AND MOST RECENTLY WE HAVE A
HEALTHY BRAIN INITIATIVE ISSUED
BY THE CDC IT CAME OUT JUST THIS
FALL.
SO WE HAVE A WE HAVE A FRAMEWORK
WE HAVE A ROAD MAP WE HAVE A
PATH FORWARD.
AND WE URGE THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE LEGISLATURE TO EMBARK ON THE
WORK IMMEDIATELY BUT THIS TEN
MILLION DOLLAR.
ONE TIME PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU --
WE'RE VERY ENCOURAGED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WERE EXCITED
ABOUT THE TASK FORCE AND HOW
THAT CAN POINT US TO A FUTURE
DIRECTION.
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE NOW AND WE WITH
THIS FUNDING --
WE WILL HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
START A PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH
IN CALIFORNIA RAISE PUBLIC
AWARENESS IMPROVE DETECTION
REDUCED HOSPITAL ADMISSIONS.
THANK YOU.
OKAY COMMENTS FROM ILLEGAL.
FINANCE.
RIGHT.
WILL CERTAINLY IS IT --
I APPRECIATE --
YOUR ADVOCACY IN THIS AND I KNOW
WE'VE HAD WE'VE TALKED WITH WHAT
YOU'VE PRESENTED BEFORE IN A
PREVIOUS BUDGET SUB COMMITTEES I
PRECIADO GOVERNOR'S INTERESTS --
AND ESTABLISHMENT OF A TASK AND
THEN AND THEN WITH THAT
LEGISLATION AND BILLS AND SO
FORTH BUT I I I I ALSO HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING ABOUT --
YOU KNOW TAKING.
NOTE THIS PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH
AND PROVIDE SOME SOME RESOURCES
BY THAT BECAUSE SET THIS IS THIS
IS A BIG HUGE PROBLEM RIGHT.
FOR THE STATE.
OF PEOPLE LIVE IN OUR STATE AND
A WE NEED TO BE YEAH WE WE NEED
REALLY NEED TO WORK ON
STRATEGIES.
TO HOW DO WE HELP SUPPORT
FAMILIES HOW WE TAKE CARE OF
PATIENTS WHO WHO ARE WHO ARE
SUFFERING FROM THIS DISEASE.
SELL UP WILL KILL.
POLITICS AND PUBLIC COMMENT WE
FINISHED ALL THE INVESTMENTS BUT
THE CARD HOLDER THING OPEN AT
THE END BUT THANKS SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP WE APPRECIATE IT
VERY MUCH OKAY THANK YOU.
YES I WILL BE TAKING PUBLIC ON
AT THE END OF HEARING ALL THE
PROPOSAL SO NEXT UP WILL TAKE UP
IS ACTUALLY THE THE COLD
PROPOSAL FOR MANAGING
HYPERTENSION [inaudible]
CAN HARD.
SO YOU GOT THREE MINUTES
TOGETHER SO YOU GUYS FIGURE HOW
YOU WANT TO BE AT THE TIME.
PRESENTING ABOUT FIRST OF ALL
COUNT THAT AGAINST YOUR TIME IF
YOU PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELVES
FOR THE RECORD.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR PAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS JOHN MIME THE CHIEF OF THE
DIVISION OF GENERAL SURGERY
MARIN GENERAL HOSPITAL IN A
BOARD MEMBER OF THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION BAY AREA
DIVISION.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JAMIE MARK
AND I'M WITH THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION I'M JUST HERE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
WELCOME THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BACKGROUND I'M A GENERAL SURGEON
OF PRACTICE FOR NEARLY TWENTY
YEARS AND I'VE WITNESSED
FIRSTHAND THE IMPACT OF HIGH
BLOOD PRESSURE ON MY PATIENTS
LEADING TO KIDNEY FAILURE HEART
DISEASE.
ANEURYSM STROKES AMONGST AND
MANY OTHER CONDITIONS THESE
RESULT IN CANCELED OPERATIONS
PROLONGED HOSPITAL STAYS AND
INCREASED HEALTH CARE COSTS.
I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE WE NEED
TO CHANGE THOSE TO TO STICKS
HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE IS A MAJOR
IN MODIFIABLE RISK FACTOR
CONTRIBUTING TO HEART DISEASE
AND STROKE WHICH ARE TWO OF THE
LEADING CAUSES OF DEATH IN
CALIFORNIA.
HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE IS KNOWN AS
THE SILENT KILLER BECAUSE IT
OFTEN HAS NO SIGNS OR SYMPTOMS
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE DO NOT KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE HYPERTENSION.
AND MANY LIVE FOR YEARS
COMPLETELY UNAWARE OF THE HIDDEN
DANGER FOR THIS REASON SEVEN OUT
OF TEN PEOPLE HAVING THEIR FIRST
HEART ATTACK AND EIGHT AND TEN
PEOPLE HAVING THEIR FIRST STROKE.
HAVE HYPERTENSION ONLY ABOUT 53%
OF ADULTS WITH HYPERTENSION HAVE
THE CONDITION UNDER CONTROL IN
CALIFORNIA ALMOST ONE IN THREE
ADULTS HAS HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE
WITH SOME COUNTIES HAVING
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER PREVALENCE.
HYPERTENSION DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTS COMMUNITIES F COLOR
ESPECIALLY AFRICAN AMERICAN AND
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITIES THE
PREVALENCE OF HYPERTENSION AND
AFRICAN AMERICANS IS THE HIGHEST
IN THE WORLD IT DEVELOPS EARLIER
IN LIFE.
AMONGST AFRICAN AMERICANS ADULTS
AGE TWENTY AND OLDER NEARLY HALF
OF THEM HAVE HYPERTENSION AND
THE NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY.
43% OF ADULTS HAVE HYPERTENSION.
THE COSTS FOR THE NATION ARE
ESTIMATED AT INCLUDING THE COST
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES
MEDICATIONS TO TREAT HIGH BLOOD
PRESSURE AND MISS DAYS FROM WORK.
GIVEN THE STATISTICS IT IS
SURPRISING THAT CALIFORNIA DOES
NOT PROVIDE ANY GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS FOR EITHER CARDIO
VASCULAR OR HYPERTENSION
PREVENTION.
OR FOR EDUCATION OR TREATMENT.
BY ALLOCATING FUNDING NOW IN THE
STATE BUDGET TO PREVENT
HYPERTENSION IN CALIFORNIA WE
CAN IMPROVE AND SAVE LIVES AS
WELL AS SAVE THE STATE FUNDS
OVER THE LONG TERM.
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL IN THE
AMOUNT OF TEN MILLION DOLLARS
SEEKS TO CREATE A FIVE TO SEVEN
COUNTY.
PILOT PROGRAM WITH THE GOAL OF
REDUCING THE PREVALENCE OF
HYPERTENSION AND INCREASING THE
BLOOD PRESSURE CONTROL RATE
AMONGST ITS PARTICIPANTS.
THE FOUNDATIONS OF THE PROGRAM
WILL INCLUDE.
IN HOME BLOOD PRESSURE
MONITORING ELECTRONIC MONITORING
OF BLOOD PRESSURE READINGS AND
USING TRAIN COMMUNITY HEALTH
CARE WORKERS TO RAISE AWARENESS
AND EDUCATE PATIENTS ON THE ON
HYPERTENSION.
AND TO MAKE HOME VISITS TO
ENSURE THAT THERE ACCURATELY
MEASURING THEIR BLOOD PRESSURE.
FOLLOWING THE RECOMMENDED
GUIDELINES AND MAKING LIFESTYLE
MODIFICATIONS.
OUR GOAL IS FOR AT LEAST THE
MAJORITY OF THE PARTICIPANTS TO
BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE CONTROL.
BY ALLOCATING FUNDING IN THE
STATE BUDGET TO ADDRESS HIGH
BLOOD PRESSURE IN CALIFORNIA WE
CAN IMPROVE AND SAVE LIVES AND
IMPROVE THE STATE'S FINANCIAL
HEALTH THE LONG TERM.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO
SPEAK TODAY AND FOR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU COMES FROM LA --
FINANCE.
SET ASSOCIATES A QUESTION SO
YOU'RE ASKING FOR TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE DO PILOT FIVE
SEVEN COUNTIES --
A BILL IS COUNTIES COME IN
DIFFERENT SIZES TOO BUT I MEAN
HOW HOW THE TEN MILLION DOLLARS
HOW MANY PEOPLE DO YOU EXPECT TO
REACH WITH THE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS.
AND AND I WOULD ALSO JUST TAKE
NOTE THAT SO SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT --
OUT SO WE COULD ARE YOU THAT
OKAY WELL DEAR MEDI CAL PATIENTS
SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT GAME
PAID THROUGH MEDI CAL SIFT
THROUGH SEPARATE FUND AND SO
ANYWAY TO YOU CAN YOU CAN YOU
DRESS LIKE.
SO OKAY WE HAVE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS AND YOU SORT OF HAD A
LIST OF THINGS THAT YOU MIGHT
SPEND THE MONEY ON BUT COULD YOU
BREAK IT DOWN A LITTLE MORE AS
TO HOW MANY PEOPLE WHO EXPECT TO
REACH FOR THE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IF WE ALLOCATE THE MONEY.
FOR THIS AT THE END OF THE DAY
WHAT ARE WE ARE WE GET A FEEL
SAY WE ACCOMPLISHED SO OBVIOUSLY
THE GOAL IS TO REDUCE I
PRETENDED I HOPEFULLY I THINK
EVERYONE CAN AGREE ON THAT AND
THAT'S A TO SAYS HE SAID.
VERY COMPELLINGLY IT'S L. IT'S A
KILLER IT DISABLED PEOPLE AT THE
SILENT KILLER.
SO WHAT WE GET FOR TEN MILLION
BUCKS AND THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION.
SO WE'LL WORK WITH DPH TO
IDENTIFY --
TRUMP'S BY DENNIS FIND THE
COUNTIES SO LOOKING AT URBAN AND
RURAL COUNTIES THAT AVE HIGHER
RATES OF HYPERTENSION AND THEN
COUNTIES WITH --
HIGHER RATES OF HYPERTENSION AND
ANGST --
COMMUNITIES AT HIGHER RISK.
SO IN TERMS OF THE POPULATION --
THAT WILL BE REACHED KIND OF
LOOKING WORKING WITH THE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND AND I AM
LOOKING AT COMMUNITY CLINICS AND
FQHCS. FOR THOSE MEDI CAL
PATIENTS WE HAVE LEARNED THAT
MEDI CAL DOES COVER.
BUT PRESSURE COPS UT OFTEN
TIMES IT'S NOT PRESCRIBED SO
HOPEFULLY WILL BE ABLE TO
EDUCATE --
PRACTITIONERS THAT THEY SHOULD
GET -- BUT
PRESSURE CUFFS REIMBURSED BY
MEDI CAL AND THEN FOR THOSE THAT
ARE NOT ON MEDI CAL THE FUNDS
WILL PROVIDE FREE BUT THE BLOOD
PRESSURE CUFFS SO ACTUALLY MS AS
CARE SO --
THIS ISN'T THE FIRST TIME WE'VE
HEARD THIS PROPOSAL I THINK YOU.
BROUGHT THIS UP BEFORE SO HAVE
THERE BEEN SOME CONVERSATIONS
FOR EXAMPLE WITH CD PHD HAVE
SOME DATA AND ABOUT.
WHICH CARRIED REALIZE YOU'RE DO
YOU HAVE BEEN ALLOCATE THE MONEY
ATBANG SOME CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
WHICH AT LEAST WHICH COUNTIES
YOU'D BE LOOKING AT AND ALSO DO
YOU HAVE SOME.
FAQ EIGHT SEES OUR LOCAL HEALTH
PLANS AND SAID YEAH WE
INTERESTED IN AND AND AND AND
AND PARTICIPATING IF YOU ARE
ABLE TO GET THE FUNDS I MEAN HOW
FAR AWAY.
IS HAS ANY OF THAT EXPLORATION
HAPPENED YET IN ERMS OF TRYING
TO MAYBE MAKE THE PROPOSAL LOW
MORE SPECIFIC AND CONCRETE.
SO WE HAVE HAD A INITIAL
CONVERSATIONS WITH CD PH
HONESTLY WE HAVE STATISTICS THAT
I'M HAPPY TO SHARE WITH YOU --
TERMS OF EACH COUNTY WHAT THE
RATES OF HYPERTENSION ARE IN
TERMS OF THE WHOLE COUNTY YOU
KNOW WE CAN SOLVE CHEST DATA SO
WE CAN OKAY BUT YOU HAVEN'T YET
EVEN WITH THAT SO I'M JUST LIKE
HAVE YOU.
LIKE MAYBE THEY'RE DOWN WHICH
COUNTIES YOU THINK WOULD BE THE
ONES YOU'D BE AND HAVE YOU
APPROACH SOME PEOPLE THOSE
COUNTY SAID YEAH WE WOULD BE THE
ONES WHO WANT TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS KIND OF THING IF WE COULD
ACTUALLY GET THE MONEY.
RIGHT I KNOW WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
THE COUNTIES WITH THE PH OKAY
ALL RIGHT AND THEN THE COMMITTEE
HEALTH WORKERS IN THE END THE A
BIG BELIEVER IN COMMITTEE HEALTH
WORKERS.
BUT SOMETIMES IN TERMS OF
DIFFERENT KINDS OF MODELS.
OF I MEAN DO YOU SEE THEM
OPERATING OUT OF CLINICS OR
DOCTORS OFFICES --
OUT THE PART OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AND IF THEY WERE ACTING OUT THE
PART EYE SOUTH HOW DO THEY
CONNECT UP WITH INDIVIDUAL
CLINICIANS HAVE FEW THOUGHT OUT
MORE ABOUT THIS --
COMMITTEE HEALTH WORKER MODEL
HOW YOU WOULD MAKE THAT
OPERATIONALIZE YES WE ENVISION
THAT THE COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER
WILL WORK OUT OF THE CLINIC OR
PHYSICIAN'S OFFICE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT.
OKAY WELL --
I THINK THERE'S A COMPELLING
CASE YOU'RE MAKING ABOUT --
WHY THIS IS IMPORTANT I IS WHAT
MIGHT BE HELPFUL AT LEAST IN MY
MIND THAT I HAVE OTHER PEOPLE
THE COMMITTEE THIS --
AND I REALIZE THAT YOU KNOW YOU
DON'T HAVE ANY MONEY YET BUT
THEY NEED TO TO SEE WHETHER.
NOW YOU SIR PICKED FIVE SEVEN
COUNTIES TEN MILLION BUT MAYBE
TO START THINKING ABOUT.
THANK.
WHO WHOSE COALITION THE WILLING
RIGHT NOW WHO WHO WHO MIGHT BE
IF WE WERE ABLE TO GET THE MONEY
TO BUY THAT THAT WOULD BE?
A LITTLE MORE CONCRETE ABOUT
OKAY IF YOU GIVE US THE MONEY WE
WOULD THEN BE ABLE THOUGH WELL
WE GOT WE GOT THREE COUNTIES ON
BOARD AND WE HAVE THESE HEALTH
PLANS AND THEY THINK THEY WOULD
BE ABLE TO REACH EXT NUMBER OF
PEOPLE IN OF COURSE DEPARTMENT
DOES.
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE --
TO CERTAIN THAT DEBT AND ON SOME
BUT AND SOME BUDGET PROPOSALS
BUT I THINK IT'S THAT THAT MIGHT
HELP MAKE IT WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
GET. TO GO BACK TO MY FIRST
QUESTION WE'RE GONNA GET BACK
FOR THAT TEN MILLION DOLLARS YES
IT'S A PROBLEM WE A LOT PEOPLE
TELLING US HEY WE CAN GET SOME
MONEY BECAUSE SOFT YOU KNOW
THAT'S ALL BUT BAKER MOVEMENT ON
THE PROBLEM.
MAYBE WITH SOMETHING A LITTLE
MORE CONCRETE THAT YOU KNOW YOU
DON'T WORK OUT EVERYTHING
BECAUSE BUT IT'S KIND OF LIKE
WHAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT HAPPENED THIS
MONEY WOULD BRING OUT GET LOST
THE HIT THE SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM
RIGHT AND I REALLY LIKE THE IDEA
OF USING COMMITTEE HEALTH
WORKERS EDUCATE PEOPLE AND SO
FORTH SO --
THAT AND JUST.
CATHOLIC FEELING LIKE SO WE WILL.
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND SEE RIGHT
NARROWED DOWN COUNTIES HERE
QUESTION WE WERE TRYING TO LEAVE --
SOME LEEWAY FOR YEAH YOU HAVE TO
TAKE A AND THAT'S A LIKELY YOU
HAVE TO TAKE THEM IN ADVANCE BUT
I AM JUST SO LIKE OKAY WELL THAT
THAT.
IS IS THAT SAID IF I COULD BE
INTERESTED IN HOW WILLING AND
READY. TO TO YELL SO I THINK
THAT THAT'S ALWAYS HELPFUL RIGHT.
NOW THERE ARE SOME.
SOME COUNTIES THAT HAVE RECEIVED
BY BRING THEM AT THE STATE
THROUGH CDC GRANTS BECAUSE WE
HAVE ANY OTHER.
GENERAL IN GENERAL ARE A DOLLARS --
APPROPRIATE IT TO THE PROGRAM.
BUT COUNTIES HAVE WORKED ON
DIABETES AND CARDIOVASCULAR
DISEASE PREVENTION INITIATIVES
LOOKING AT TRYING TO DRIVE DOWN.
REPRESENTS IN RETENTION SO I AM
IMAGINE YOU KNOW.
ON DISCUSSION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT THAT SOME OF THOSE
COUNTIES WOULD LIKE --
TO FURTHER SOME OF THOSE
PROJECTS OR CONTINUE TO WORK IN
THAT SPACE --
ESPECIALLY GIVEN SOME OF THE CDC
DOLLARS HAVE GONE AWAY.
OF MORE WORK TO DO WE WILL
DEFINITELY SHARE INFORMATION
WITH YOUR YOUR STAFF OKAY AND
ENOUGH CELEBRITY UP THE ONE AT
THERE'S AND NATIONAL%
COLLABORATIVE.
TARGET BP WITH THE AMERICAN
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION KIND OF
PROVIDES A NATIONAL FRAMEWORK
THINK YOU'RE VERY IMPORTANT
POINTS.
FROM A TAURUS YOU UTILIZING
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS IN
PARTICULAR I THINK IS ONE PATH
FORWARD BUT THANK YOU FOR THIS
COMING OUT SIDE I THINK IF WE
CAN GET --
MAIL.
MAYBE SOME FURTHER DEVELOPMENT
OF SOME OF THESE IDEAS THAT
MIGHT.
HELP THE HELP HOPE FOR HELP MOVE
THIS ALONG AND OKAY MY FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE AT LEAST.
A NO I APPRECIATE THAT OUT WE DO
HAVE THAT NATIONAL MODEL THAT
RIGHT OUT THE ENTIRE PROGRAM
THAT.
RUNS AN OUTSIDE TO FIND PARTNERS
IS A HERE'S THE MODEL.
ARE YOU AIDED SAYS ONLY BE
INTEREST IN PARTICIPATING IN
RIGHT.
OKAY.
AND WE END THE BILL WILL VISIT
THE I. E. S. ALL.
THAT WE STILL HAVE SEVERAL
MONTHS BEFORE MAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON AMANDA MCALLISTER
HONOR.
AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA WOULD YOU BE TO Q.
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
NETWORK.
TERROR RUSSELL SLAVIN DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF POLICY COMMUNITY
BUILDING UP THE LOS ANGELES LGBT
CENTER.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HEARING US TODAY --
WE ARE HERE ON BEHALF OF A BROAD
COALITION OF SERVICE PROVIDERS
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS AND
COMMUNITY ADVOCATES --
BECAUSE FOR FAR TOO LONG LESBIAN
BISEXUAL QUEER WOMEN HAVE BEEN
AND VISIBLE AND HEALTH CARE
SYSTEMS.
AND THAT IS DESPITE FACING
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS TO CARE AND
SIGNIFICANT HEALTH DISPARITIES --
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE --
TWO AND A HALF MILLION LESBIAN
BISEXUAL IN QUEER WOMEN --
THIS IS A POPULATION THAT'S BEEN
HISTORICALLY UNDER SERVED AND IS
A DESIGNATED HEALTH DISPARITIES
POPULATION --
BY THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
HEALTH --
HAS BEEN BI SEXUAL IN QUEER
WOMEN EXPERIENCE SIGNIFICANT
HEALTH DISPARITIES SUCH AS
HIGHER RATES OF SMOKING.
ALCOHOL USE ANOTHER SUBSTANCE
USE --
HIGHER RATES OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HIGHER RATES OF CANCER
MORTALITY AND THE LIST GOES ON
THESE DISPARITIES ARE EVEN MORE
PRONOUNCED FOR LESBIAN BISEXUAL
AND QUEER WOMEN OF COLOR IN
TRANS GENDER LESBIAN BISEXUAL IN
QUEER WOMEN --
DESPITE THE MAJOR EXPANSIONS OF
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE STATEWIDE
LESBIAN BISEXUAL IN QUEER WOMEN
STILL STRUGGLE TO ACCESS CARE --
THIS LESBIAN BISEXUAL IN CORBIN
ARE LESS LIKELY TO HAVE A
REGULAR DOCTOR AND 30% HAVE PUT
OFF NECESSARY HEALTH CARE EVEN
WHEN THEY HAVE INSURANCE --
MANY I'LL BE Q. WOMEN DO NOT
FEEL COMFORTABLE DISCUSSING
THEIR SEXUAL ORIENTATION WITH
THEIR PROVIDER AND HALF OF
EXPERIENCED DSCRIMINATION IN A
HEALTHCARE SETTING --
AND LESBIAN BISEXUAL IN CRIMINAL
MORE LIKELY TO BE LIVING IN
POVERTY TO HAVE.
TROUBLE ACCESSING TRANSPORTATION
AND DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH THAT
REVENT THEM FROM GETTING IN TO
SEE THE DOCTOR WHICH IS WHY
WE'RE HERE TODAY REQUESTING THAT
CREATION OF AN L. B. Q. WOMEN'S
HEALTH EQUITY FUND.
AND I WOULD JUST ADD --
TO BREAK THAT DOWN A LITTLE --
THE SEVENTEEN AND A HALF MILLION
WOULD BE BROKEN DOWN INTO TWO
PARTS FIFTEEN AND A HALF MILLION
WOULD GO TO THE CREATION OF THE
LESBIAN BISEXUAL QUEER WOMEN'S
HEALTH EQUITY FUND UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH.
AND THAT WOULD FUND FOUR CORE
COMPONENTS THE FIRST THE SIX AND
A HALF MILLION TO FIND EIGHT
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS THAT WILL
PROVIDE HEALTHCARE NAVIGATION
ASSISTANCE AND LINKAGE TO CARE.
WITH THE GOAL OF INCREASING
HEALTH CARE UTILIZATION RATES
AND PREVENTATIVE SCREENINGS.
THREE MILLION WOULD FUND
LOCALIZE COMMUNITY NEEDS
ASSESSMENT ENSURING UNDERSERVED
VOICES GUIDE PROGRAMS --
AND THE SERVICES FOR YEARS TO
COME THREE MILLION FOR COMMUNITY
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH BOTH
BROAD TOPIC OF PUBLIC EDUCATION
CAMPAIGNS AS WELL AS TARGETED
KIND OF IN DIVIDE VISUALIZED
EFFORTS AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES.
NAMELY LBT WOMEN OF COLOR OLDER
ADULTS AND YOUNGER ADULTS AND
THREE MILLION FOR TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS INCLUDING
NONTRADITIONAL HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS. TO WIN LESBIAN
BISEXUAL QUEER WOMEN ACCESS CARE
THEIR IDENTITY IS FORMED AND
THEY ARE RETAINED.
IN THAT SYSTEM THE REMAINING TWO
MILLION WOULD GO TO RESURGENT
RESEARCH AN INVENTORY IN
EXISTING PROGRAMS IN ADDITION
WE'VE A SUBMITTED YESTERDAY A
SIGN A LETTER BY THIRTY
ORGANIZATIONS AND WE ALSO HAVE A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY POSTCARDS WITH
US TODAY FROM COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
AND TO OUR KNOWLEDGE THIS WILL
BE THE FIRST EVER.
UP PROGRAM OF DEDICATED FUND
BURKE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU COMMENTS
MILLIA.
FINANCE OKAY.
SO --
CHáVEZ SO THE QUESTION OF OTHER
PEOPLE SO GIVEN THAT WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING --
FOR AND THAT APPRECIATE YOU
BROKE IT DOWN TO WRITE A
DIFFERENT.
WAYS THEM PARTS GOING TO BE USED --
HOW?
HOW HOW MANY?
THAI PEOPLE YOU THINK YOU'RE
GONNA BE ABLE ARE HAVING
COMMITTEES YOU THINK YOU'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO REACH RIGHT
WE HAVE --
DEMO PROGRAMS NEED TO SET NEEDS
ASSESSMENT NOW THEY OF DECIDING
ABOUT HOW HOW GIVEN THE NOW BY
HOW MANY PEOPLE YOU CAN REACH
AREA DO COMMITTEE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING HEALTH PROVIDERS --
SO.
CAN YOU PERHAPS SPEAK TO GIVE IN
THIS PART OF MONIES FIGHT NOT
SUFFICIENT REACH EVERYBODY BUT
HOW HOW HOW FAR DO YOU THINK
YOU'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET
AND YEAH.
YEAH WITH THE WITH THE STATE AND
I THINK SOME OF THIS WOULD BE.
ARE YOUR NUMBERS FOR THE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS WHICH I
THINK WOULD HAVE THE MOST DIRECT
IMPACT ON ONE ON ONE IN TERMS OF
YOU KNOW LINKAGE TO CARE --
MODELING AND AFTER OUR
INTEGRATED CARE PROGRAM WE WOULD
EXPECT THAT FOR EACH FULL TIME
EMPLOYEE WHOSE FUNDED UNDER THIS
PROGRAM THEY WOULD HAVE ABOUT
SIXTY CLIENTS SO ABOUT A
THOUSAND CLIENTS PER YEAR.
AND THIS IDEA WAS A
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS FOR A
THREE YEAR GRANT PROGRAM AND THE
HOPE IS THAT --
DOES ADD THOSE PROJECTS THERE'S
BUILT IN EVALUATION --
WITHIN THE THAT THE
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS SO THAT
WE CAN REALLY SEE WHAT'S FOR THE
EFFECTIVE MODELS HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE WE REACHING WHAT IS THE
IMPACT HOW CAN WE MEASURE IT AND
THEN HOPEFULLY BUILD ON THAT AND
AND AND USE THE SAYS AS THE
START OF OF SOMETHING THAT.
CAN REACH FOLKS GOING INTO THE
FUTURE.
AND YOU SEE ANY OPPORTUNITIES.
TO MIGHT BE A LEVERAGE OTHER
FUNDS --
FEDERAL OR NOT PROFIT OR OTHER
TYPES OF FUNDS.
I MEAN I DON'T THINK THERE'S A
TON OF MONEY COMING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT RIGHT NOW FOR
LESBIAN BISEXUAL PER WOMEN BUT
WE WOULD ABSOLUTELY BE WILLING
TO LOOK INTO THAT EFFORT.
WELL THIS IS AS IF YOU PROVIDE
SOME HEALTH CARE.
FOR THIS POPULATION BUT THERE
ARE MEDI CAL YOU DON'T HAVE TO
TELL THEM THAT [inaudible]
IT'S THE LEE AND I MEAN I HINK
THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE EXCITED TO
BE ABLE TO SEE SOME OF THAT --
EQUITY MEASURES THAT ARE COMING
OUT OF MEDICAL CALLIN THE NEXT
FEW YEARS WHERE WE CAN REALLY
TAKE A LOOK AT HOW THIS
POPULATIONS BEING SERVED BY MEDI
CAL AND I THINK.
WE WOULD ABSOLUTELY BE ABLE --
TO TO USED --
AND AND LIBERTIES PROGRAMS --
AS EXAMPLES OF OF HOW MEDICAL
CAN REACH IT EQUITY GOALS --
GOING FORWARD OKAY.
EXCELLENT ALL RIGHT WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED THANK
YOU.
RIGHT -- THE
NEXT ITEM IS --
THE STICKER PROPOSAL FOR THE
SAFE COSMETICS PROGRAM
AUGMENTATION [inaudible]
COME.
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN BUT YOU DO
NEED TO INTRODUCE YOURSELF FOR
THE RECORD.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR PAN AND
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS IT'S VERY
NICE TO SEE YOU AGAIN MY NAME IS
JANET NUDELMAN I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF PROGRAM AND POLICY.
AT BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS WE ARE THE ONLY
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION SOLELY
DEVOTED TO PREVENTING BREAST
CANCER BY LAMINATING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL LINKS TO THE
DISEASE.
I GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR PANNING
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS I'M LINDA
JUDY'S I AM A CALIFORNIA
LICENSED PHYSICIAN AND SURGEON.
BOARD CERTIFIED IN OBSTETRICS
AND GYNECOLOGY AND REPRODUCTIVE
ENDOCRINOLOGY AND INFERTILITY
AMOUNTS TO A BIOCHEMIST AND A
FACULTY MEMBER AT UCSF.
I COME TODAY AS THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE OF REPRODUCTIVE AND
DEVELOPMENTAL ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH. FOR THE INTERNATIONAL
ORGANIZATION ON OBSTETRICS AND
GYNECOLOGY KNOWN AS SPEAKER.
RIGHT BOOK RIGHT AND WE'RE GOING
TO BE SPLITTING OUR THREE
MINUTES. THREE MINUTES TO FIGURE
OUT DIVIDE BETWEEN YOURSELVES
OKAY.
SO OUR PROPOSAL SEEKS A GENERAL
FUND AUGMENTIN IT'S PROGRAM.
OF ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY AND A
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER TO SUPPORT ONE TIME
INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADES TO THE
PROGRAM'S ELECTRONIC REPORTING
SYSTEM AND PRODUCTS DATABASE.
AN ADDITIONAL ENFORCEMENT
RESEARCH AND OUTREACH STAFF.
THIS BUDGET IS IDENTICAL THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL IS IDENTICAL TO
THE STAKEHOLDER PROPOSAL THAT WE
SUBMITTED LAST YEAR.
WHICH WAS APPROVED BY YOUR
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE THANK YOU.
AND ALSO INCLUDED IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE BUDGET BILLS
APPROVED BY BOTH HOUSES BUT
SADLY REJECTED BY GOVERNOR BROWN.
THE CALIFORNIA SAFE COSMETICS
PROGRAM PROVIDES CRITICAL
INFORMATION TO CONSUMERS AND
WORKERS TO HELP THEM AVOID
BEAUTY AND PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS CONTAINING CHEMICALS
LINKED TO CANCER AND BIRTH
DEFECTS.
YET IT DOESN'T HAVE THE FUNDING
IT NEEDS TO MODERNIZE ITS
REPORTING SYSTEM.
CONDUCT OUTREACH TO WORKERS AND
CONSUMERS TO HELP THEM UTILIZED
THIS IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH TO
ALL OR ENSURE THAT COSMETIC
COMPANIES ARE COMPLYING WITH THE
SAFE BECAUSE MEDIC ACTS
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
ALTHOUGH THE SAFE BECAUSE MEDICS
PROGRAM LAUNCHED ITS PUBLIC
DATABASE FIVE YEARS AGO THE
INFORMATION IT PROVIDES FOR
CONSUMERS AND WORKERS ALIKE.
IS MORE NECESSARY THAN EVER WE
HOPE THAT THE ESTEEMED MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE WILL ONCE
AGAIN SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT BUT
MODEST REQUEST.
AND I'D LIKE TO INVITE DOCTOR
DUTIES TO ADDRESS THE SCIENCE
LEAKING CHEMICALS IN COSMETICS
TO HARM TO HUMAN HEALTH.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE --
OUR FIGO COMMITTEE TWENTY
FIFTEEN DISSEMINATED A CALL TO
ACTION. FOR INCREASED AWARENESS
OF THE RIGOROUS SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE.
THAT ENDOCRINE DISRUPTING
CHEMICALS EXPRESSION LEE WITH
EXPOSURES DURING CRITICAL STAGES
OF DEVELOPMENT.
ARE CAN INCREASE THE RISK OF
ADVERSE INCLUDING CANCERS
DEVELOPMENTAL DISORDERS
METABOLIC AND REPRODUCTIVE
DISORDERS.
AT UCSF OUR PROGRAM FOR
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT DEVELOPED A TOOL KIT
CALLED TOXIC MATTERS FOR HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS. TO ADVISE ON
PATIENTS AVOIDING EVERYDAY
EXPOSURES TO TOXIC CHEMICALS
ESPECIALLY DURING PREGNANCY AND
ONE OF THE RESOURCES WE IST IS
THE CALIFORNIA STATE COSMETICS
PROGRAM.
WE BELIEVE THAT PHYSICIANS AND
THE PUBLIC SHOULD KNOW ABOUT
WHAT KEPT TOXIC CHEMICALS ARE IN
THE FULL RANGE OF CONSUMER
PRODUCTS THAT THEY USE MAINLY TO
DECREASE THEIR RISKS.
ALSO WE KNOW THIS IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
SMALL EXPOSURES CAN ADD UP TO
HARM DEPENDING ON TIMING DOSE
AND DURATION.
AND AT PARTICULARLY DURING
DEVELOPMENTAL PERIOD SUCH AS
PREGNANCY AND IN CHILDREN.
FURTHERMORE CUMULATIVE EXPOSURES
CAN ALSO HARM ESPECIALLY THOSE
WHO USE CHEMICALS EVERY DAY SUCH
AS BEAUTY SALON WORKERS WHO WERE
EXPOSED TO PROP SIXTY FIVE
CHEMICALS IN THE PRODUCTS THEY
USE FOR LONG PERIODS OF TIME
EVERYDAY.
ALL DAY.
THE BASE OF SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE
IS ROBUST LINKING HUMAN HARM TO
HUMAN HEALTH FROM TOXIC
CHEMICALS IN PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS AND BEING INFORMED
ABOUT THESE HIDDEN DANGERS
EMPOWERS CONSUMERS AND POLICY
MAKERS ALIKE TO IMPROVE THE
PUBLIC HEALTH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU COME AS FAMILIAL.
FINANCE.
NOW ALL RIGHT.
OKAY WORLD THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS PROPOSAL --
BACK AGAIN WILL --
CERTAINLY --
YOU KNOW WE HEARD THIS LAST YEAR
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT THINK ACTUALLY
BY NOT ACTUALLY DOING A C. M. IS
NOT OF THE HUGE SUM OF MONEY TO
STATE GO AHEAD.
OF THE MIGHT MAKE IT A LITTLE
EASIER THIS YEAR BE SURE THAT
THE THAT THAT --
SAFE BECAUSE MAKE PROGRAM NOW IS
IS HAS RESOURCES NEEDS TO
ACTUALLY FUNCTION THE WAY IT'S
SUPPOSED INTENDED WHEN WE
ORIGINALLY PASS THAT SO.
I APPRECIATE YOUR PRESENTATION
THANK YOU THE GREAT.
THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH SO
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE FOR
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS OF PEOPLE
CAN.
COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE.
IN THE HOPES EACH TRADE FIFTY WE
KEEP THE CAR I KNOW THERE'S FOR
PROPOSALS --
KEEP IT TO A MINUTE I'LL GIVE A
LITTLE LATITUDE IF YOU TRY TO
COVER MORE THAN ONE BUT THANK
YOU FOCUS. TO MADDEN REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF CARDIOLOGY
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION'S BUDGET
REQUEST FOR TEN MILLION DOLLARS.
WHEN I TALKED CARDIOLOGISTS WHEN
THEIR BIGGEST FRUSTRATIONS IS
WITH OF OF PATIENTS COMING IN
AND THEIR BLOOD PRESSURE MIGHT
BE AT A LEVEL WHERE IT'S ALREADY
BECAUSE?
SIGNIFICANT HEART DAMAGE AND
THEY SAY IF THEY HAD ONLY KNOWN
EARLIER THEY COULD HAVE GOTTEN
ON TOP OF THIS WE LOOK AT THIS
PILOT PROGRAM IS A GREAT WAY TO
GET PEOPLE ENGAGED.
IN MONITORING THEIR HEALTH THEIR
CONNECTIONS WITH THE LOCAL
HEALTH CARE WORKERS IN THE
CLINICS TO MONITOR THEM COME OUT
TO THEIR HOUSE MAKE SURE THEY'RE
USING IT PROPERLY WE THINK IT'S
VERY EXCITING IF WE CAN GET
AHEAD OF THE CURVE.
WE CAN MAKE SOME REAL INROADS IN
TRYING -- TO
STOP THE PROGRESSION OF THIS
DEADLY DISEASE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
YOU'RE [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND BILL
ALLEY --
WITH ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP
ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTER FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
CLEAN WATER ACTION FRIENDS OF
THE EARTH AND NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL.
IN SUPPORT OF THE A PROPOSAL --
TO FIND THE COSMETICS
PROGRAMMING MILLION REALLY MAKE
IT WORK FOR CONSUMERS IN TERMS
OF HEALTH ISSUES ESPECIALLY FOR
YOUNGER PEOPLE EXPOSURE. TO
PREGNANT WOMEN AND CHILDREN IN
pLOT OF TEENS ARE USING COST
MEDICS THE MAP HARMFUL
INGREDIENTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
BRENT SPENCE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN A COG
THE COGS MEMBER THE COALITION
THAT IS SUPPORT ABOUT THE SAFETY
OF COSMETIC PROGRAM AUGMENTATION
AND WE APPRECIATE YOU WOULD GO
IN THE BUDGET THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU LISETTE VAN FLEET ON
BEHALF OF BREAST CANCER ACTION
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHY NAIL
SALON COLLABORATIVE AND THE
COMMON WEAL BY MONITORING
RESOURCE CENTER IN SUPPORT OF
THE REQUEST TO INCREASE THE
BUDGET FOR THE SAFE COSMETICS
PROGRAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
LINDA DINNER WITH ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK A WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF
THE STATE CALLED HOLDER PROPOSAL
FOR THE L. G. B. WOMEN'S HEALTH
EQUITY FUND WE FIND THAT THIS
WILL HELP FACILITATE IDENTITY
AFFIRMING.
CARE AND COORDINATION FOR FOR AT
THE MOMENT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
I THINK YOU NEED TO BE --
MEYER --
HERE ON BEHALF OF A NUMBER OF
SMALL COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA
THAT SUPPORT THE SAFE BECAUSE
MEDICS PROGRAM INCLUDING.
BEAUTY COUNTER CALIFORNIA BABY
EO PRODUCTS ON SKIN CARE OCO
INTERNATIONAL AND SERIOUSLY FAB.
WHICH IS THE BEST NAME FOR A
COMPANY OF ALL OF THE NO THERE'S
BROAD SUPPORT NOT JUST IN THE
NGO COMMUNITY BUT ALSO IN THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY FOR MAKING
THIS.
IMPORTANT PROGRAM FUNCTION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THAT IT'S
REALLY A GREAT NAME.
FREE WITH THE WELCOME.
HELLO RACHEL HENRY --
OUR REGION TRAINING INSTITUTE
DIRECTOR AT THE SACRAMENTO LGBT
COMMUNITY CENTER HERE ON BEHALF
AND OF THE CENTER IN IN SUPPORT
OF THE LESBIAN BISEXUAL CARE
WOMEN'S HEALTH PROPOSAL --
AS ONE OF THOSE TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION CALIFORNIA WOMEN WHO
IDENTIFY AS A LESBIAN I HAVE HAD
FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE WITH
HEALTH CARE DISCRIMINATION GIVEN
MY IDENTITY.
HOW TO SPEND MY ENTIRE ADULT
LIFE FIGHTING --
FOR RELEVANT HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SUCH AS STI AND
CERVICAL CANCER SCREENINGS IN
FIGHTING OFF UNNECESSARY MEDICAL
INTERVENTIONS SUCH AS A
PREGNANCY TEST AND BIRTH CONTROL.
AND I WAS ADVOCATE WHO PROVIDES
PROFESSIONAL CULTURAL COMPETENCY
TRAININGS I ALSO KNOW THAT
PHYSICIANS ARE HUNGRY FOR MORE
KNOWLEDGE AND RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT L. B. Q. WOMEN'S HEALTH --
THIS IS EVIDENT IN ART THE FACT
THAT ARE TRAINS CONSISTENTLY
FILL UP IN ARE ALWAYS OUT OVER
CAPACITY FOR THESE CULTURAL
COMPETENCY TRAININGS.
IS FOR THESE REASONS AND MANY
MORE THAT THE SACRAMENTO LGBT
COMMUNITY CENTER STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI.
MY NAME'S ANTI MASANYA I'M A
NURSEPRACTITIONER PROVIDING
PRIMARY CARE AT THE LOS ANGELES
LGBT CENTER FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
HEALTH HEALTH CLINIC.
THERE I MANAGE THE DEALER HEALTH
PROGRAM FOR LESBIAN BISEXUAL IN
CLEAR WOMEN.
IN THIS PROGRAM WE TAKE A WHOLE
PERSON APPROACH STRIVING TO MEET
THE MULTIPLE ON MET PHYSICAL AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS AND THIS
MARGINALIZED.
AND OFTEN OVERLOOKED POPULATION
TARA AND AMANDA OUTLINED FOR YOU
SINCE SET THIRTY SIX AND DATA
ABOUT THE DISPARITIES IN THIS
POPULATION.
THOSE NUMBERS ARE THE PATIENTS
THAT I SEE DALY.
OFTENTIMES I AM THE FIRST
PROVIDER THAT THEY'VE SEEN IN
MANY YEARS AN EXAMPLE OF THIS IS
MY PATIENT WHO WILL BE HAVING A
HYSTERECTOMY IN TWO WEEKS FOR
CANCER THAT COULD HAVE.
SHOULD HAVE BEEN CAUGHT WITH THE
ROUTINE TIRED OF ANSWERING
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS QUESTIONS
ABOUT HER HUSBAND OR BOYFRIEND
SHE WAS WARY OF EXPLAINING THAT
SHE DIDN'T NEED A PREGNANCY TEST
OR BIRTH CONTROL.
HER SEXUALITY HER IDENTITY WAS
DISMISSED SO SHE FELT DISMISSED.
I HEAR SIMILAR STORIES LIKE THIS
ALMOST DAILY THE LACK OF LESBIAN
BISEXUAL AND QUEER WOMEN'S
CULTURALLY COMPETENT HEALTH CARE
IS A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
AND THIS IS WHY CALIFORNIA NEEDS
TO FUND THE LESBIAN BISEXUAL
INCREMENTS HEALTH EQUITY FUNDS
OKAY THANK YOU.
WELCOME AYE THERE --
MY NAME IS AMY CAN I MANAGE THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROGRAM AT THE
LOS ANGELES LGBT CENTER --
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE L. B.
Q. EQUITY FUND I JUST WANT TO
TELL YOU A STORY ABOUT A CLIENT
OF OURS.
WHO CAME TO THE CENTER --
SHE IS A LESBIAN IDENTIFIED
CLIENT TO IS IN A VIOLENT
RELATIONSHIP WITH HER PARTNER --
DURING ONE OF THEIR FIGHT SHE
WAS --
STRUCK IN THE HEAD AND ALSO HER
HEAD WAS THROWN INTO THE SIDE OF
A CAR.
WHEN SHE PRESENTED TO THE
EMERGENCY ROOM THE MEDICAL
PROVIDERS SAID TO HER YOU COULD
NOT HAVE SUSTAINED A BRAIN
INJURY BECAUSE A WOMAN CANNOT?
HIT YOU THAT HARD ENOUGH TO
SUSTAIN AN INJURY.
SO SHE WENT AWAY FEELING
EMBARRASSED AND ASHAMED AND SHE
DID NOT SEEK MEDICAL OR MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT.
AFTER THAT FOR MANY YEARS SO HER
SYMPTOMS WENT UNTREATED SHE'S
NOW DEALING WITH PTSD.
AND POSSIBLE NARAL COGNITIVE
ISSUES AND THIS COULD HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED WITH CULTURALLY
COMPETENT CARE --
THESE WOMEN ARE VISIBLE WE NEED
TO HELP THEM WE NEED TO SUPPORT
THEM THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
VISITOR MEMBERS MANY WE ON
BEHALF OF THE PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COUNSEL --
UNFORTUNATELY IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS PROPOSAL WE DO APPRECIATE
THAT THIS YEAR UNLIKE LAST YEAR --
WE ARE SEEKING GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS TO FUND THIS BUDGET
AUGMENTATION RATHER THAN PLACING
A FEE ON MANUFACTURERS.
HOWEVER HOWEVER THERE ARE SOME
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
WITH THE DATABASE --
THE FIRST OF WHICH IS THAT WERE
JUST FUNDAMENTALLY OPPOSED TO
THE STATE FUNDING A DATABASE --
THAT PROVIDES INFORMATION THAT'S
READILY AVAILABLE ON THE PRODUCT
LABEL WE DISCUSS IS CONCERNED
WITH THE COMMITTEE LAST YEAR.
WE ARE ALSO OPPOSED. TO THE
DATABASE WHICH REQUIRES
REPORTING OF CHEMICALS
REGARDLESS OF HOW MUCH IS IN
THERE AND WHETHER IT'S PRESS
POSES A HUMAN HEALTH RISK --
AND LASTLY WE ARE UNAWARE OF ANY
OTHER STATE DATABASE ON ANY
OTHER PRODUCT CATEGORY AND
THAT'S JUST WORTH NOTING --
FOR FOR PURPOSES OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
WE ALSO QUESTION THE VALUE OF
THIS DATABASE TO THE CONSUMER
BECAUSE BASED ON INFORMATION
THAT WE GOT FROM A DPH REPORT IN --
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE NUMBER
OF WEBSITE HITS FOR THIS
DATABASE AVERAGED ABOUT TWELVE
HUNDRED HITS A MONTH.
IF YOU COMPARE THAT TO THE
NUMBER OF PRODUCTS THAT ARE
PURCHASED AND USED EVERY SINGLE
DAY IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S A FRACTION --
SO WE REALLY QUESTION THE USE OF
THE CONSUMER USE OF THIS DATA
BASE -- ONE
OF THE LAST THINGS I'D LIKE TO
NOTICE I'D CAUTION THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROVING THIS --
BUDGET PROPOSAL BECAUSE THERE IS
A BILL THAT'S PENDING IN THE
LEGISLATURE THAT RELATES.
TO THIS VERY DATABASE SB.
FIVE SEVENTY THREE AND SHOULD
THAT BILL PASSED ON A I'M SURE
THAT THE SAME GROUPS WILL BE
BACK IN YOUR COMMITTEE NEXT YEAR
ASKING FOR A MUCH LARGER BUDGET
AUGMENTATION BECAUSE THE SCOPE
OF THAT BILL DOES SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE THE SCOPE OF THE SAFER
BECAUSE MEDICS PROGRAM.
AND THEN THE VERY LAST ITEM IS
THAT WE ARE.
WE LOOKED AT THE BUDGET SUMMARY
IN DETAIL COMPARED TO LAST
YEAR'S AND IT'S LARGELY THE SAME
HOWEVER WERE CONCERNED.
THAT -- WE
ARE DISCUSSING IS IN A BUDGET
ITEM NAMELY BUDGET ITEM ONE TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE SIX SEVEN
REQUIRES.
COMPANIES TO REPORT TO THE STATE
DATABASE WHETHER THEIR PRODUCTS
ARE INTENDED FOR PROFESSIONAL
SALON USE. FOR CONSUMER USE
WHICH DID A FRESH READING OF THE
ORIGINATING STATUTE IS NOT
AUTHORIZED IN THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME ALONE THE COOKING NOTICE
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE FRAGRANCE
CREATORS ASSOCIATION --
INDUCTION TO THE COMMENTS THAT --
YOU DO WE JUST MDE ON BEHALF OF
THE PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
COUNCIL --
WE DO JUST WANT TO REEMPHASIZE --
SORT OF THE INTERPLAY THAT WILL
BE HAPPENING WITH SB FIVE
SEVENTY FOUR AND THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL KIND OF MOVING
SIMULTANEOUSLY BUT RECOGNIZING
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL WILL HAVE TO
BE ACTED ON PRIOR TO THAT THE
FINAL OUTCOME OF THAT BILL.
AND YOU KNOW THOSE POLICY
DISCUSSIONS ARE OF COURSE GOING
TO BE ON GOING WE'RE STILL
EVALUATING THE IMPACTS OF THE
LEGISLATION --
AND WE CERTAINLY ARE GOING TO
ENGAGE WITH THE OFFICE OFFICE
AND AND THE SPONSORS OF THAT
LEGISLATION --
BUT I JUST FOR EXAMPLE WANT TO
POINT OUT YOU ONE OF THE
ELEMENTS OF THE BUDGET PROPOSAL
IS -- TO AT
IT AND VESTED GATE IN --
THE CURRENT POLICY LET --
LANGUAGE --
WHAT COULD BE CONSIDERED TRADE
SECRET WOULD BE DRASTICALLY
REDUCED SO I'M NOT SURE YOU KNOW
THERE IS GOING TO BE SOME
INTERPLAY THERE AND THEN JUST
BECAUSE I CAN'T HELP MYSELF --
AND THE WORD ABUSE I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT THERE'S CURRENTLY ONLY
FOUR HUNDRED AND TEN PRODUCTS ON
HE DATABASE THE EVEN CLAIM
ANYTHING IS TRADE SECRET AND
THAT'S OUT OF SEVENTY THREE
THOUSAND SO.
IT IS -- A
VERY SMALL NUMBER BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING ON ALL.
THE QUE THANK YOU.
IT WILL COME TOGETHER FIGURE OUT
OKAY SO --
AGAIN I'M WITH --
ANY OTHERS DON'T SEE ANY OTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE WE WILL
HOLD -- EACH
THE FOR STAKEHOLDER.
AT PROPOSALS --
AND SO --
AND THEN WE WILL CONSIDER THEM
ACTUALLY AFTER PROBABLY AFTER
MAY -- SO
WITH THAT --
I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S HEARING.
AND SEE EACH SO YEAH SO ALTHOUGH
THOSE ITEMS OPEN I'LL FOR
STAKEHOLDER PROPOSALS AND SO
WITH THAT THAT CONCLUDES THE
AGENDA FOR THIS HEARIN OF THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE
OF THE SENATE BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW.
COMMITTEE AND WE ARE NOW
ADJOURNED THANK YOU